seat.  Our session will begin
soon.
>> Welcome to Google io 2018.
We welcome to you celebrate
platforms at goog e.  By now you
have checked into registration
to receive your badge.  You need
to ride the io shuttles and tone
ter the after-hours activities
at
Throughout the event make sure
to visit Google.
com/io or download the mobile io
app for the most up to date
schedules and      For questions
for assistance, stop by the
information desk located a
Krause from the code labs
building or chat with
Sessions will take place in the
amphitheater and at the eight
stages throughout the venue.  If
you haven't already, reserve a
seat for your favorite session
the io website or Mobile App.
And, if you miss a session,
don't worry.  Recordings will be
available online
Be sure to visit the CodeLabs
building for hands-on experience
with
ready the code kiosks and
self-paced tutorials.  Google
staff will be on hand for
helpful advice and to provide
direction
Make time to visit the office
hours to meet one-on-one with
Googlers and ask all your
technical questions and get
If you are looking to network
with Googlers and fellow
developers join one of the
several meet ups hosted in the
Finally, we would like to invite
you to visit the Sandbox domes,
where you can explore, interact
with our
After session is done for the
day, stick around for food,
music, drinks, and fun.  Be
prepared foresaw prices along
the      We would like to take
this opportunity to remind you
we are
dedicated to providing an and
inclusive experience for
Everyone.  By attending Google
io you agree to our code of
conduct posted throughout
Your opinion is valuable to us.
After the event look for a
feedback
Thanks for attending and have a
wonderful time exploring Google
io.
.  .
Io18
.
.  Hash
>> Welling come. Thank you for
joining.
Our session will be begin soon
welcome.  Thank you for joining.
Our session will begin soon.
soon.
>> Hi guys.
>> All right. So, we're going
to cover what is new in Chrome
Dev Tools.
>> PAUL IRISH: And we're good
go to be capturing what has been
going on from the Chrome Dev
Tools team in the past year, the
the features and function
>> JASON MILLER: Just says
joke.
>> PAUL IRISH: We're going to
be covering a few different
things.  We're going to go
through offering, accessibility,
performance and jaufy script
capturing feature areas of the
>> PAUL IRISH: To kick things
off we want to look at
authoring.  In authoring this is
really the experience of us
crafting a nice user experience
for Everyone who is enjoying
our web content, and this is
create a nice feel, a nice look,
and there is a
I can first possible way is the
classic, the reliable way.
I work in my editor, I load it
up, I tweak things in DevTools,
you know, copy paste what I
like, bring it back to my edit
to are, save and refresh.  That
old save and refresh cycle.
Good.
Now, previous I/O' we've also
talked about work spaces.  This
is a way where we take your
entire project like your get
checkout essentially, drag them
to DevTools and DevTools can now
work with that, save to
disk and you have access to the
entire
folder there and really makes
for a fast >> PAUL IRISH:
This is great if it is your
project, but there is also this
other case of I want to make
changes and I don't necessarily
have, like, a get checkout of
it, but I still want to try
things out.  And, that is what
local overrides is
So, like Jason, if you wanted to
make changes on Paul Irish.
>> JASON MILLER: Right F.
>> PAUL IRISH: So far you would
not have good access, so that
works for me.  But local
overrides would work for your
de-a face meant.
I'm going to go show a little
bit of how this works in
actuality.  Let's switch over to
my screen for a
So, we have here the Google io
extended site.  Nice little
page, but I feel like making
some changes and it's not my
So, first thing is you will head
over to sources panel, and in
this little drop down we go to
overrides.  First thing that we
have to do, just once, is set
this up so we just need to
So, I'm just going to go right
in here and you just need to put
this someplace on disk.  Really
anywhere.  .  And, we're going
to be using the disk to kind of
back all these changes.  So,
once you select, you click allow
so that DevTools has permission
to work with this folder. >>
JASON MILLER:  It only gets
permission inside that folder,
in that root? >> PAUL IRISH:
Yeah.  Yeah.
So, I this that I is all good.
And, now -- let's make some
changes.
This guy right here, actually,
>> JASON MILLER: Something
nice. >> PAUL IRISH: Let's
go -- hot pink is a good choice.
I like hot pink.
>> JASON MILLER: Hot pink.
>> PAUL IRISH: Wow.
>> PAUL IRISH: Probably needs
>> JASON MILLER: Yeah, some
>> PAUL IRISH: All right.
>> PAUL IRISH: Now, I don't
know if you saw that.  Let me
just do that again.  Refresh.
Oh, sticking around post
refresh.  I like that.
Now, the cool thing here is that
I can make changes to kind of
anything.  Say, for instance,
this text beneath
here, the hosted 534 viewing
parties.  Cool.  I think that
number needs an upgrade.  I
don't know exactly where this
text
is, it could be in the
JavaScript file, maybe the html.
So, I'm going to select and copy
So, command shift P brings up
this >> PAUL IRISH: Nice.
And, I'm going to show search.
This will s across all the files
that are loaded into the page.
And, okay.
So, here we have just the html.
All right.  Easy enough.  We can
make a change to that. >>
PAUL IRISH:  Good.  We hit
control S.  And, you can see
this little purple.
That this is telling me that
this file is linked to the
network file.
And, this also means if I right
click this and open it, this is
just, this html file that I just
changed is just a regular old
file on disk.  I can drag this
into my texted it tore and make
changes there, and they will
instantly be reflected if I just
refresh. Over 9,000. >>
PAUL IRISH:  Nice.  So, this
enables a lot of cool things,
and you can make dice changes,
prototype
If you get to a point where
you're like okay, made some
changes, they feel good, but
were they all again?  There is
another little pain that you can
access to summarize everything
that has happened.  Again, you
can use command shift P or you
can just open up the little menu
down here on the bt the bottom
and go to changes.  The changes
view will tell you what change.
Now, in this case it is
minifiedCSS society is not
entirely useful to look at the
dif, but then again I could open
this file and pretty
print it and at that point I
(Laughter)
>> PAUL IRISH: All right.
Let's go back to the slides.
All right.
So, you saw it in my demo search
across all files, and we've been
looking at other Places to
surface more content via search.
>> JASON MILLER: Yeah. So, one
of the ways that we're doing
that is through improvements to
the network search.  So, in the
network tab we've had search for
a while.  It's just like a bar
that shows up at
the bottom, and that bar is only
searching urls.  So, it's
useful, you know, if you're
looking for something that is in
the url, but not quite so useful
if you're looking for something
that isn't in the url.
So, now there is a new Icon in
here,
>> PAUL IRISH: Yeah, control F.
Yeah. >> JASON MILLER: And
that's going
Search sidebar searches through
headers and their values in
addition to all those other
pieces of information.
Let's say I want to search for
cache control headers.  It is
going to tell me whether the
browser going to cache stuff
locally and get an overview of
what we're sending down.  If I
hit enter on this it will show
me an aggregated list of all the
cache control headers that is
sent down.  And, you can click
them in the left.  You can see
the details of those on the
right.  It is very nice.  There
is still the familiar controls
in the header for case sensitive
search, RegX space search.  If
you want to search for
authorization headers to know
which of your requests are
authenticated,
>> PAUL IRISH: If you add
specific domains and looking up
what CSP headers >> JASON
MILLER:  Yeah.  So, we're trying
to show you kind of an at a
glance overview in this
interface, and there is other
Places in DevTools where we have
kind of similar
problems here, like huge lists
of CSS
Raise your hand if you use CSS
variables, custom properties.
Good stuff.  Yeah, I love them,
too.  We use them all the time
on the Chrome Dev Tools
themselves, and we've been
looking at it and they could
probably
>> PAUL IRISH: So, if you have
seen some variables before they
might look a little something
like this. >> PAUL IRISH:
Good.  But then you're like what
was that again?  So, today
you'll see something a little
bit different.  You will just
see a little color swatch place
there.  We recognize that this
is recognizing a color value and
some of the color swatch seems
good.
You can also just hover on that
variable name and it will just,
the tool tip will resolve the
actual value.  Works with
colors, it works with
>> PAUL IRISH: But, with colors
it was one more thing that was
pretty cool.  If you open up the
color picker, down at the bottom
is this kind of color pallet.
And, this is the material design
color pallet.  A lot of nice
tasteful choices of >> PAUL
IRISH:  But there are a few
other pallets available, and a
brand new one is CSS variables.
You click into this and this is
listing the CSS variables that
apply to this element right
here.
So, it's basically the -- while
there may be many, many
variables in the page, these are
only the variables that apply to
this specific element via the
cascade >> JASON MILLER:
Right. Right. >> PAUL
IRISH:  So that is kind of cool.
Right now we're hovering over
text link color if I select
this, the cool
thing is we apply a var text
link color >> JASON MILLER:
Society doesn't use the hex, it
uses the actual variable >>
PAUL IRISH:  What you would
>> JASON MILLER: That is pretty
>> PAUL IRISH: When you choose
colors, it is important you
choose something that looks
good, tasteful, but also
accessible.  You want to make
sure that what you have is an
accessible choice.  So, we've
introduced some features to make
that a little bit easier.  And,
we're going to walk through this
So, I'm looking at this page and
I want to tweak the foreground
color of this text.  So, I bring
up the color picker and it says
contrast ratio right there.  It
says it is not very good right
now.  But as I drag the color
around, the contrast ratio is
going to update.  It's kind of
cool.  And, if you open that
section up, you'll now get this
line in the color pecker.
So, a line a green line is bad
and on the other side is good.
You get ratings beneath on what
the current ratio is and what if
it meets
Now, it is currently trying to
identify what the background
color is, but there is a little
color dropper
there if -- a little eye dropper
if you want to manually select
your background color. >>
JASON MILLER: Cool.
Did I notice that you were
editing your Lighthouse score
with that tool? >> PAUL
IRISH: I was in Lighthouse with
DevTools.
I wasn't editing my score, but
my score could use some
improvement. >> JASON
MILLER: Right. >> JASON
MILLER:  We should probably tell
them about the new
>> JASON MILLER: Seems like a
good
Yeah, last year at Google io we
announced that we were bringing
Lighthouse into DevTools.  This
was huge because it meant
everybody who had Chrome
obviously has DevTools.
Everybody who has DevTools,
which is the Chrome users now
had Lighthouse.  Nothing to
install.  No extensions.  None
of that business.     Now, that
kind of started us thinking, was
there anything else we could do
to kind of make Lighthouse more
helpful to people?  We're always
thinking of that, but moving
into Chrome was sort of a
turning point here.  We want
Lighthouse to act like a real
Lighthouse.  We want it to kind
of keep you away
from the rocks and guide you
towards other meaningful
information that exists
So, this year I'm excited to
announce that we are introducing
some improvements that we hope
will bridge the gap between
Lighthouse and DevTools.  And,
I'm just going to show you my
favorite new feature of all
time, which
View trace to stretch the
analogy to the point of breaking
unless you dig >> JASON
MILLER:  Yeah.
>> JASON MILLER: Lighthouse
records a trace of your
application as it runs.  It
loads your application, reloads
it, grabs a trace, which is
going to be details about
JavaScript network stuff, all
those kind of underlying pieces
of information.  We thought why
not let people dig into the
trace.  We have it.  It is
sitting there.  And, turns out
this is a really nice
way to kind of see why you got a
Lighthouse.
I'm on Paul Irish Irish.com.  My
favorite website.  Just the
performance ought I had for
So, behind the scenes this is
going to be reloading the page,
gathering a trace, analyzing it
and coming up with a
pretty page and a lovely score.
I think there, yeah.
But you see now there is a view
trace button.  Clicking this, it
is actually going to
take me right over into the
performance tab and I can dig
down into the trace that powered
that Lighthouse score, and this
is awesome because that tries
was
run-on an emulated 3G network o
a slow >> JASON MILLER:
And, you can kind of figure out
what exactly those odd ilgts
were derived from.
Let's say you had a critical
request chain for CSS or
something.  You can see that in
the performance tab blocking the
rest of your page rendering with
screen shots.  So, to me this is
huge.
>> PAUL IRISH: I'm looking at
this, and in a way you're
calling me out.  Your oo calling
my sight out at least.  I was
wondering maybe we should spend
a few minutes and see if we can
improve >> JASON MILLER: I
think we can >> PAUL IRISH:
On the site a >> PAUL
IRISH:  We can make it      To
make it faster let's bring back
one of the features we were
talking      Okay.
First up, let's reload the page
to capture a trace of the page
load.  All right.  Now, what we
want to do is measure from the
very beginning of the html load
right there to when the web
fonts finished loading.
>> PAUL IRISH: At the bottom.
Yeah.
Now in the green right there waf
files.  These are my web fonts.
Big gap before they start
loading in.  So, we can fix
this.  This is a bit of code.
Going to usury source code and
API, copy it to the clipboard,
but really I
We're going to come over here
and use local overrides.  We
paste them in.
>> JASON MILLER: Ignore the
multiple mult cursor magic.
>> PAUL IRISH: Reload.
I think that is link pre-load.
Again, 2000 milliseconds before.
Let's reload with the local
overrides changes.  Now we are
pre-loading. >> PAUL IRISH:
Yeah.  Yeah.  The fonts are at
the top T. green.  Yeah.
>> PAUL IRISH: And our total
time is, yeah, 13. >> JASON
MILLER: A 33. >> PAUL
IRISH:  Uh-huh.
>> PAUL IRISH: That is pretty
fast >> JASON MILLER: Very
impress
So, while we're talking about
performance, there is a few
other changes.  So, you might
see something like this if
you're looking at a trace.  You
have the main thread.  You may
have i frames that are using
site isolation and those are
going to be represented on a
separate track.
>> PAUL IRISH: Are positioned
on      The nice thing now is
that as you
select each track, the summary t
bottom up, the cull tree, all
that stuff at the bottom is
going to be updating to >>
JASON MILLER:  Very nice.
>> PAUL IRISH: Kind of cool.
Enables also another feature
that I      Say, for instance,
you're looking at a trace of
your web app.  You see a flame
chart like this.  Now, in the
flame chart there is a lot of
stuff going on.  There is a
function names like complete
work.  Create element.  Mount
class instance.  You're like
yeah, mount class instance
>> JASON MILLER: Good old mount
>> PAUL IRISH: Great.
>> PAUL IRISH: A number of
frameworks also use user timing
to say when things started and
ended.  And, usually this is
very meaningful because it is
talking about your components.
When your components were
mounted and rendered.  So, you
can select the user timing
track and now see that data
summarized
>> PAUL IRISH: This is really
great.  Having this structural
profiling data come in via user
timing saves time, because
otherwise you would be writing
all this start and end, like,
marks yourself.  It is a big
time sync to do all this.  Here
DevTools is doing a lot of the
>> JASON MILLER: Right.
Paul, you mentioned syncs and
lifting. >> JASON MILLER:
Right.  So, one of the things I
wanted to cover is actually
related to that, and
it's a sync
>> JASON MILLER: I think I was
>> JASON MILLER: This is the
last >> JASON MILLER: No.
There is two.  There was two.
>> JASON MILLER: There is a
couple.
>> PAUL IRISH: Is that a
>> JASON MILLER: It is a
>> JASON MILLER: So anyway.
What I was going to say is it is
and it is year of a sync await.
So, a sync a weight is every
part of Java at this point.
We added this in DevTools.
Amazing.  This year we're taking
things a few steps further F.
you're not familiar with Async
await, it kind of looks like
this.
You have a wrapper function,
very important.  With the Async
keyword.  Inside of the body of
this function
you can use the await keyword to
await on the return value on the
promise.
It looks like soo*erng
synchronous code this, is
promesed under the hood but it
is going to run kind of line by
line to you.  This will run
Async row nowsly when it
This is fine.  Certainly fine
for application development, but
one place where this is actually
kind of annoying is down in the
console.
>> JASON MILLER: So, we are
happy to announce that today the
console has
>> JASON MILLER: No wrapper.
No shenanigans.  So, I will
walk-through an example and
In this case, I'm going to await
the response from this fetch
call, which is going to connect
to a GitHub API that I googled
it.  So, we're going to search
for work box.  We're going to
stick that in res, then we're
going to await, no wrapper, no
promises, the value of res did
the json.  This responds.  You
notice it dumps it straight into
the console.
>> JASON MILLER: Exactly. You
have to wait and expand it.  Get
the value.  Clever hats.
Finally I'm going to use a
DevTools
>> JASON MILLER: This is the
previous result from the
console.  So, I can just do
dollar score under sign items
map, map them over the name and
I have the list of the 30 most
So I've been able to step
through
line by line in a dis
discoverable way, an Async flow.
Haven't had to use wrapper,
promises, callbacks, none of
that stuff.  The console
supports this out of the
The interesting thing is we're
bringing this Async mentality to
the debugger.  One of the big e-
changes you'll notice here is
when stepping into Async
functions, until now if you
stepped into an Async function
like a set time out or whatever,
we would pretty much just step
>> JASON MILLER: So, let me
show
In DevTools last year, this is
what step time out looked like.
If I click step into on this set
time out call, step into next
function call,
>> JASON MILLER: Right.
Now in DevTools if I click step
into on step time out I can step
through the rest of the
function.  So, it is kind of an
Async aware step into.  This is
just one type of Async, though.
So, a lot of people right now
are
spreading their work out by by
the main thread or the
alternative is you push your
work off the main thread into a
background thread using a web
order, let's say.
One of the hardest parts of web
worker development is debugging
them.  These are separate
threads. >> PAUL IRISH: It
is a little >> JASON
MILLER:  It's painful.  You're
switching context of the
debugger going from one thread
to the other, the sidebar the is
changing, you have to wait for
post message calls to resolve
and you can really do anything
We thought what about making all
of that a little bit easier?
So, now let's see we have some
worker -- some main thread code,
right, running on the main
thread.  With new Async aware
step into, I can
>> PAUL IRISH: Into the
creation >> JASON MILLER:
-- and it drops me off on the
first line of the worker that I
created. >> JASON MILLER:
Yeah. >> JASON MILLER: So
we can step across a thread
boundary in DevTools now.  So,
this, is really cool.
Another case would be, let's
say,
I've created my worker, I've got
this W variable with the worker
in it, and I've got a break
point there.  I can step into
the post message call to the
worker and it will step across
the thread boundary and into the
worker.  It will drop me off the
first line on
>> PAUL IRISH: What about in
the post message from the worker
back to the >> JASON
MILLER:  It's funny you should
mention that.
>> JASON MILLER: We can step
into the post message call and
get back to the main thread like
there was no thread boundary at
all and it drops us off in the
message handler.  This is super
cool.  You're not debugging
across the worker >> PAUL
IRISH:  That's rad.  All right.
So, before we finish up, I do
want to bring it back to the
console for a >> JASON
MILLER:  Got you.  Got you.
>> PAUL IRISH: There is some
stuff going on in the console.
I console there are functions
that are avail lbl there and
nowhere else.
We call them the au manned line
API.
First up as spotted before, copy
>> JASON MILLER: Right. >>
PAUL IRISH:  Take anything you
want, throw it in the copy
method, it copies it to the clip
poured, it's so nice you pass it
like an element it will give you
an outer html, anything else it
will string au identify it as
Jason and
>> JASON MILLER: I did not know
>> PAUL IRISH: It's been there
>> JASON MILLER: Longer than I
have >> PAUL IRISH: But,
anyways.  Just a familiar,
refamiliarize There are some
other methods in there that have
now just got an upgrade, too.
The debug method has been
around, what you can do is pass
a function it to and it will
essentially pause right inside
of the function that you pass.
But now you can pass in native
function.
So, document dot query select
ter would be an example, and
what happens is it will pause
right as soon as any JavaScript
is about to use that data
>> PAUL IRISH: You can also do
it with alert, too, if you want
to find out
Similar story with monitor.  It
doesn't pause but instead logs
to the console stack trace and
also the arguments that are
being passed in.  This you could
say tell me about all of the
code that is using set time out
>> JASON MILLER: So we would
have seen in my previous example
of a function I pass to you and
all this >> PAUL IRISH:
Exactly. >> PAUL IRISH:
It's really nice.  There is one
more that is actually brand new,
which is query objects.  It is
kind of cool.     So, let's
start this out.  We have a
class.  We create two instances
of the class.  The second one we
just add an extra property so it
is unique.
Now, later on, we're like ah
query objects we pass back into
that class.  And, we're going to
get in the console an array of
all of the instances of the
class.  In this case pretty
straightforward, but the really
powerful thing here is that it
is looking across the entire
JavaScript and reporting back
all the instances that we know
about it.
It is like taking a big heap
memory
snapshot and summarizing it down
to just      Now, this is cool,
because it's not
just what is currently available
to JavaScript scope right now.
It is the entire heap.
You can look at, for instance,
custom element constructors.
Or what are all my canvass
contacts that are somewhere and
get them dumped
Okay.  I think that is it.
To wrap up we covered offering,
accessib, performance and Java
scripts.
>> JASON MILLER: Paul, didn't I
see you literally backstage
before we
>> JASON MILLER: Is there
something you wanted to tell the
people >> PAUL IRISH: Yes,
there was.
>> JASON MILLER: Oh God, are we
>> PAUL IRISH: I think so.
>> JASON MILLER: We're getting a
>> PAUL IRISH: You guys want to
>> PAUL IRISH: I got one more
>> PAUL IRISH: Jason, as you
know, web flat form evolves
quickly.
As it's involves, we as
developers need to feel
comfortable working with these
new APIs, these new objects and
make sure that our code runs
well against all them.
And, the console is our home
base for this exploration.
So, we were thinking that
console
could use some more power here
so we're introducing a brand new
feature that we think
revolutionaries nationes how we
work with the console.
We all call it eager evaluation.
>> PAUL IRISH: No other way to
do it than with a demo.  Let's
switch over to my machine.
We'll just undoc this and go
full >> JASON MILLER: Does
anybody else
>> JASON MILLER: He adds them
as
>> PAUL IRISH: Undoc. >>
PAUL IRISH:  All right.  Here in
the console I have a little line
of code, right.  We have a
regular expression and we're
going do call exec on it and
pass it a string. >> JASON
MILLER: There is a music >>
PAUL IRISH:  All right.  Let's
finish this off.  Thanks.
Now, as I finish this
expression, checkout what
happens.  We get the results of
this evaluation just positioned
right beneath me, and I did not
hit enter or anything. >>
JASON MILLER: What? >> PAUL
IRISH: The cool thing here is,
too, this is going to update as
I type.
So, if I come back and let's say
does
this rgeex work if I have parens
around
>> PAUL IRISH: No, it doesn't.
Regx, a little brittle.  Could
use some improvement.  One thing
I do see as far as >> JASON
MILLER: Yeah. >> PAUL
IRISH:  All right.  We can use a
digit instead.  We do have
multiple of these, so we
could just multiple selection/D
and >> PAUL IRISH: Matches
too work good.     Now one last
thing Jason I wanted
>> JASON MILLER: You're sure
this wasn't just a reason to
show off your
>> PAUL IRISH: While we have
these
multiple cursers here, oh, I
like that, what we're going to
do is add some >> PAUL
IRISH:  All right.  All right.
Yes.  Exactly.
And, so, let's pull out the, is
it 1?  1.  Boom.
So n a few short moments with
not
too much work we manage to
explore the API, find the bug,
make an improvement and get the
result that we wanted.  And this
speed of iteration is really
nice.  No going back in your
history, changing that one
thing.
>> JASON MILLER: We should do a
>> JASON MILLER: You still have
>> PAUL IRISH: Yeah. We're
still connected to the page with
>> JASON MILLER: That guy never
>> PAUL IRISH: All right. How
about -- okay.
>> PAUL IRISH: Let's grab all
of >> JASON MILLER: Like
you're a >> PAUL IRISH:
Yeah, like I'm a
>> PAUL IRISH: Okay. So, what
do we need?
>> JASON MILLER: Query selector
>> PAUL IRISH: All right.
>> PAUL IRISH: Okay.
We have them now, I don't know,
we'll grab the text with
intertext or something.  So,
we'll map over that.  Map.
>> JASON MILLER: It is a node
list. >> PAUL IRISH: Right.
>> PAUL IRISH: How do we change
a
>> JASON MILLER: What is the
newest
>> PAUL IRISH: Audience
particip suggestions?  I like
it.  I like it.  Yes.
>> PAUL IRISH: Array literal
with >> PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
>> JASON MILLER: Did that even
work in Chrome? >> PAUL
IRISH:  I love this one.  Now we
got array.  Maps the thing.
Maps the thing.  All right.
>> PAUL IRISH: So, let's grab
the
>> PAUL IRISH: Let's clean this
up.
>> JASON MILLER: That is a lot
of >> PAUL IRISH: Wow.
Let's get rid of that. >>
JASON MILLER:  Holding uptight
>> PAUL IRISH: The classic one.
>> JASON MILLER: I like it
still >> PAUL IRISH: Trim
that.
Trim.  No.
>> JASON MILLER: Some type --
it
>> PAUL IRISH: Go.
>> PAUL IRISH: All right.
Nice. >> PAUL IRISH: So I
was able to craft that, not mess
up too much, and we
>> JASON MILLER: Who knows what
>> PAUL IRISH: The really
powerful thing here is that eeg
gar evaluation is done in a way
that we can guarantee there are
no side effects.  And we did
this by introducing a new mode
into V8 where we attempt to
evaluate code, but if we know it
is about to cause a side effect
that changes the outside state,
your application, the page,
other parts of the dom, we just
bail and stop doing >>
JASON MILLER:  I tried for like
an hour to break it.  You can't.
I am going to try more, though.
>> PAUL IRISH: The other nice
thing is that eager evaluation
in addition to kind of giving
you this
result right underneath what you
type in the console enables some
new completions in the console.
So, a completion is just a type
of
>> JASON MILLER: CloseClosure
UID.
But, there are some tricky
things here.  Completions
normally as soon as you
introduce, like, some parens you
are
>> PAUL IRISH: Completions
never continue to work.  You
just have to figure it out on
yourself.
But, now we can try your
evaluation on that same string
and power more >> PAUL
IRISH:  So, to give you a show
of how this kind of works, and
>> JASON MILLER: You're going
to show off our thumb war stats.
>> PAUL IRISH: Okay. We've
been playing thumb wears.
>> PAUL IRISH: I've been
keeping >> PAUL IRISH:
Touch.
Going.  All right.  5.
>> PAUL IRISH: A nice thing is,
I'm keeping this here, but we
were thinking it would make more
sense if we >> JASON
MILLER:  Right we're going
>> PAUL IRISH: Thumb wars stats
>> PAUL IRISH: If we pulled
that
>> PAUL IRISH: So let's make
this >> JASON MILLER: That
is a bit >> PAUL IRISH:
Yeah.  And, we need to turn it
back into an object, right guys.
All right.
>> JASON MILLER: My namesake
>> PAUL IRISH: Now take a look.
I'm going to hit dot, and what
is in >> JASON MILLER:
What? >> JASON MILLER: We
have a cameo >> PAUL IRISH:
Check us out.
The cool thing is this is being
evaluated under the hood and it
was day determined to have no
side effects so now the
completions are upgraded. >>
PAUL IRISH:  Really powerful
stuff.  This is just a taste of
some of the things you will be
seeing.
What you can do is grab today's
Chrome Canary, pop into the
console
settings, right up here, turn on
eager evaluation, it will enable
all the stuff      All right,
Jason.  I think that's it.
Let's go back to the slides.
>> JASON MILLER: I think we're
good. >> PAUL IRISH: Thanks
guys.
(Applause)
>> Thank you for joining this
session.  Brand ambassadors will
assist with
directing you through the
designated exists.  We will be
making room for those of you who
have registered for the next
session.  If you have registered
for the next session in this
room, we ask you to please exit
the run and return via the
Thank you.
Easy
#io18
>> All right. Hey folks, my
name is Addy.  This is Ewa.  We
work on Chrome.  And, today
we're going to give you a world
wind tour of trips and
particulars
>> EWA GASPEROWICZ: The
Internet gits heavier and
heavier every year.  If we check
on the State of mobile web we
can see that on the page of
mobile the weight is about 1.
5 Megs with more majority of it
being scaufy crypt and images.
Apart from the sheer size though
there are other reasons why web
page might feel splug I shall
and heavy.
Third party code, network,
latency, CPU, partial blocking
patterns, all of this contribute
to the complicated
We have been pretty busy over
past year trying to figure out
how to fit this rich content of
mobile web into the      In this
talk, Addy and I are going to
show you what we can do in this
regard today, but also we will
take a peek into the future and
give you a highlight of what
might be possible really, really
soon. >> ADDY OSMANI: So,
I'm not the biggest fan of
suitcases.  The last time I was
at the airport waiting at the
baggage carousel for my bags I
looked around for my suitcase
and
all I could find was this.  .
>> ADDY OSMANI: I too, laughed
the first four times this went
around.  I was really happy to
get this back, I
Now, the experience that I had
at a baggage kaur au sell is a
lot like the experience our
users have when they're waiting
for the page to load.  In fact,
most users rate speed as being
at the very top of the UX
hierarchy of their needs and
this isn't too surprising
because you can't really do a
whole lot before a page is
finished loading.  You can't
derive value from the page,
Now, we know that performance
matters, but I can also
sometimes feel
like a secret discovering where
to start optimizing.  So, we've
been working on trying to make
this problem a little easier for
a
while, and today we have an
exciting announcement to share
with you.
We like to call it a Paul Irish
in
>> ADDY OSMANI: Well, >>
EWA GASPEROWICZ:  Well, we're
happy to announce an expanded
performance of audits in
Lighthouse.  Lighthouse is part
of the developer tools that
allow you to make an audit of
your website and also gives you
hints on how to make it better.
It's been around for a while,
right, but as some of you have
heard today in the morning, it's
been also act worked on.  And,
today I'm happy to share with
you
some of the newest audits that
landed in
We'll try to show them to you in
action during the rest of the
talk.
As the Internet thing goes,
fixing
web performance is easy as
drawing a horse, right.  You
just need to follow some steps
carefully.
But, even though, well, there is
some truth in the picture above,
the good
news is you can get pretty far
by following some simple steps.
In order to show you the steps,
addy
So, Ewa and I are really big
fans of Google doodles.  Google
has been doing some since 1988
and we thought it would be fun
to create a app to show you our
favorite interactive doodles
over the year.
Video
(Video
>> ADDY OSMANI: So, we kick it
off and as you can see we can
start browsing through the app
plau taetion and look at doodles
over the year and click through
We're not going to ruin the
surprise.  You can go and play
some during your
So, let's begin our journey into
the wild west of web performance
and it all begins with one tool.
>> EWA GASPEROWICZ: Of course,
Lighthouse.  The individual
performance of our app, as you
can see on this Lighthouse
report, was pretty terrible.
On a 3G network the user needed
to
wait for 15 seconds for the
first meaningful pain or for the
app to get interactive.
Lighthouse highlighted a ton of
issues with our site, and the
overall
performance score of 23 mirrored
exactly that.  The page waited
at about 3.4 megs.
This started our first
performance challenge.
Fun things that we can easily
remove without effecting the
overall
So, what is the easiest thing to
remove?  Usually nothing.  And,
by nothing, I mean things that
do not really contribute to the
code, like white space or
comments.  Lighthouse highlights
this opportunity
in the
manufactured CSS and
manufactured Java crypt audit.
In order to get communicate
identification we simply use the
agi plug in.
Communication is a common task
so you should be able to find a
ready made solution for
whichever build process you
Other useful odd it in that
space is enable text
compression.  There is no reason
to send uncouple pressed files,
and most of the CDN'
We were using Firebase Hosting
to
host our code, and Firebase
actually enables GCP by default.
So, by the sheer vir oo of
hosting our
And, while GCP is a very popular
way of
compressing other mechanisms
that are getting traction as
well.
Broadly enjoys support in most
of of the browsers these days
and you can use binary to
pre-compress your assets
Okay.
In these two ways we made sure
that our code is nice and
compact and ready
Our next task was to not send it
twice, if not necessary.
The in efficient cache policy
audit in Lighthouse helped us
notice that we
could be optimizing our caching
strategies in order to achieve
exactly that.
By setting a max stage
expiration head ner our server,
we made sure that on a
repeated solicit the
repeat user can reuse the
resources as before.
You should aim at caching as
many as possible for the longest
period of time and provide
validation tokens for
All the changes we made so far
were very straightforward,
right.  They required no code
whatsoever.  It was a really low
hanging fruit with very little
risk of breaking anything.
So, remember, always minimize
the code, preferably automate go
it with build tools by using the
right CDNs or
by adding optimization modules
to your own servers.  Always
compress your assets and use
efficient cache policies to open
Tau
Okay.
This way we remove the obvious
parts of the unnecessary down
loads, but what about the less
obvious parts?
As it happens, unused code can
really surprise us.  It may
lininger in the dark corners of
your code base.
Idle and long forgotten, and yet
making it to the users bandwidth
each time the app is loaded.
This has been especially if you
work on your app for a longer
period of time, your team or
your dependencies change,
and sometimes a I will gets left
behind.
At the beginning we were using
material components library to
quickly prototype our app.
In time we moved to a more
custom look and feel and of
course we forgot entirely about
that library.  Fortunately t
code coverage check
You can check your code coverage
stats in DevTools both for the
run time as load time of your
application.
You can see the two big red
stripes in
the bottom screen shots.
We had over 95% of our CSS
unused and
Lighthouse also picked up this
issue in the unused CSS rules
audit.
It showed a potential saving of
over      So, we go back to our
code and kicked out both the
JavaScript and CSS part of that
library.
This brought our CSS bundle 20
fold,
which is pretty good for a tiny
tool two
Of course, it made our
performance score go up and also
the time to
interact got much better;
however, with changes like this,
it's not enough to check your
metrics and scores alone.
Removing actual code is never
risk free.
Remember that our code was
unused in '95%?
Well, there is still this 5%,
right.  One of our components
was still you'd using the slide
from the library, the little
arrows in the slide there.
Because it was so small we could
go and manually incorporate
those slides back into the
buttons.
So, if you remember code, just
make sure you have a proper
testing work flow in place to
help you guard against potential
visual regressions.
So remember, code coverage in
DevTools and in Lighthouse is
your
friend when it comes to spotting
and removing unused code.  Check
regularly throughout the
development of your app to keep
your code base clean and tidy
and to test your changes
thoroughly before Well, so far
so good.  All of those changes
made our app a little bit
lighter.
It was still too slow to Addy,
so he took it a bit farther?
>> ADDY OSMANI: It went so, so
good.  Some light pages are like
heavy suitcases.  You have some
stuff that is important and then
you have crap and even more
We know the large resources can
slow down web page loads that
can cost our users money and
have a big impact on their data
Plan, so it's really
Now, Lighthouse was able to
detect that we had an issue with
some of our network pay loads
using the enormous network
payload audit.
Here we saw that we had over 3
Megs worth of code that was
being shipped down.  Quite a
lot, especially on mobile.  At
the very top of this list,
Lighthouse highlighted that we
had a JavaScript vendor bundle
that was 2 Megs uncouple pressed
code that we were trying to ship
down.  This was also a problem
highlighted by web pack.  What
we say is that the fastest
request is the one that is not
made.
Ideally you should be measuring
the value of every single asset
you're serving down to your
users, measuring the performance
of those assets and making a
call on whether it is worth
shipping down with the initial
experience, because sometimes
these
assets can be deferred or laysly
loaded
In our case, because we're
dealing with a lot of jaufy
script bundles, we were
fortunate, because the jaufy
script
community has a rich set of
JavaScript bundle auditing
tools.  We started off with web
pack bundle analyze esh that
informed use uni code which is
1.
6 megs of parsed Java scripts,
so quite a lot.  We then went
over to our editor and using the
import cost plug in for visual
code we were able to visualize
the cost of every module that we
were importing.  This allowed me
to discover which component was
including code that was
We then switched over to another
tool, bundle phobia.  This is a
tool that allows you to
enter in the name of any NPN
package to modify what G size
isest mayed to be.  We found a
nice you will a, your Honorive
for the slug md usual that only
weighed 2.
This had a big impact on our
performance between this change
and discovering other
opportunities to trim down our
Java crypt bundle size, we saved
2.
We saw 65% improvements overall
once you factor in the G zip and
size of these bundles.  We found
that this is really worth
So, in general, try to eliminate
unnecessary down loads in your
sites and apps.  In the case of
the ood Del theater, an app that
has games and a lot of
interactive multimedia content
it is important for us to keep
the application shell as
lightweight as possible.
In ven [TORG] our
Although large pay loads can
have a big impact, there is
another thing that can have a
really big impact and that is
JavaScript.
We all love JavaScript, but as
we saw earlier, the median page
includes a little bit too much
of it.
JavaScript is your most
expensive asset.  On mobile if
you're send down large bundles
of JavaScript it can delay how
soon your users are able to
interact with user interface
components.  That means they can
be tapping on UI without
anything meaningful actually
happening.  So, it's important
for us to
This is how a browser processes
JavaScript.
We first of all have to download
that script, we have a
JavaScript engine
which then needs to parse that
code, compile it and execute it.
Now these phases are something
that don't take a whole lot of
time on a high end device like a
desktop machine or a laptop.
Maybe even a high end phone.
But on a median mobile phone,
this process can take anywhere
between 5 and 10 times longer.
This is what delays
interactivity.  So, it is
important for us to try
Now, to help you discover these
issues with your app, we
introduce a new JavaScript.  It
told us that we had 1.8 seconds
of time in boot up app.
While this was happening we were
statically importing in all of
our routes and components into
one monolithic JavaScript
bundle.  One technique for work
around this is using code
splitting.  Code splitting is
this notion of instead of giving
your users a whole pizza worth
of JavaScript, what if you only
gave them one slice at a time as
they needed it.  Code splitting
can be applied at a route level
or component level.  It works
great with react and react
load able, UGS, annular,
polymer,
So, we incorporate a code slit
splitting into our application.
We switched over from status
imports
to dynamic allowing to us
synchronously lazy code it in as
we need it.  It was shrinking
down the size of our bundles but
also decreasing our JavaScript
booting time.  Took it down to
0.
87 seconds making the app 50%
faster.
In general f you're building a
jaufy script heavy experience
send code to the user they need.
Take advantage of code
splitting, explore ideas like
trees shaking, and checkout this
repo we have with few ideas of
how you can trim down your
library size if you happen to be
using      Now, as much as
JavaScript can be
an issue, we know unoptimized
images can
So, over to Ewa to talk about
>> EWA GASPEROWICZ: Images,
Internet loves images, and so do
we.  In ood Del app we're using
them in the background,
foreground, and pretty much
everywhere.
Unfortunate Lou, Lighthouse was
listen thoosy as particular
about it than we were.
As a matter of fact we find on
all three images audits.  We
forgot to optimize our images,
not sizing them correctly, and
also get some gain from using
other image formats as
So, we started optimizing our
images for one of open Tau
misszation route you can use
visual tools like image optim or
image convert.
To adds image optimization step
with our build process with
libraries for example imagery.
This way you make sure that also
the
images added in future get
optimized automatically.
For example, Lackamy or third
cloudy
or fastly offer you
comprehensive image solution.
So, to save yourself some time
and headache, you can simply
host your images on those
services.  If you don't want to
do that because of the cost or
latency issues, projects like
thumb bell or image flow offer
Here you can see a single image
optimization outcome.  Our
background P&G was flagged in
web pack as big and rightly so.
After sizing it correctly to the
view port and running in through
image optimum, we went down 200
kilobytes, which is acceptable.
Repeating this for multiple
images on our site allowed to us
bring down the
That was pretty easy for static
images, but what about the
animated content?
As much as we all love gifs,
especially the one [W-S] ones
with the cats in them, they are
expensive.
It was never intended as an
image platform in the first
place, there for switching to
more suitable video format
offers you large saving in terms
of the
In oodle app we were using a gif
you saw earlier.  According to
Lighthouse we could be saving
over 7 megabytes by swaechg to a
Our clip waited about 7.3 megs.
Way too much for any reasonable
website.
So, instead we turned it into a
video element with two source
files, an MP4
Here you can see how we use FFM
tool to convert our animation
jif into the format file.  It
offers larger savings, and for
example image open Tau might the
eye can
We managed to save over 80% of
our
This brought us down to around 1
megabyte.  Still 1 megabyte is a
large resource to push down the
wire, especially for
the user on the restricted band
witch bandwidth.  We could use
effective API to realize they're
on a low bandwidth and give them
a much, much smaller J peg
instead.
This interface uses the
effective round-trip down and
downing values to estimate the
network type the user is using.
It is simply registering 2G, 3G
or 4G.
Depending on this value if the
user is
on below 4G we could replace the
video element with the image.
It does remove a little bit from
the experience, but at least the
site is
Last, but not least there is a
common problem of off screen
images.  Curse or, sliders,
really long pages often load
images even though the user
cannot see them on the page
right away.  Lighthouse reflect
this behavior in the off screen
images audit and you can see it
for yourself in the network
panel for DevTools.  If you see
a lot of images coming while
only few are visible on the
page, it means that maybe you
could consider
Lazy loading is not yet
supported natively in the
browser, so we have to
use JavaScript to add this
capability.
Here you can see how we use lazy
sidees to add lazy loading
behavior to our oodle covers.
Lazy loading is smart because it
does not only track the
visibility changes of
the element but it also
practically perfects elements
that are near the view
It also offers an optional
integration of the intersection
observe e, which gives you very
efficient
As you you can see after this
change, our images are being
fetched on      Okay.  That's a
lot of good stuff about images.
So, just remember, always
optimize images before pushing
them to the user.
Use responsive images techniques
to achieve the right size of the
image.  Use lighter formats
wherever possible,
And, finally, lazy load,
whatever
If you want to dig deeper into
that topic, here is a present
for you.
A very handy and comprehensive
guide written by Addy.
So, you can see it as images.
guide url.
>> ADDY OSMANI: Cool. Let's
talk about resources that are
Now, not every bite that is
shipped down the wire to the
browser has the same degree of
importance, and the browser
knows this.
A lot of browsers have Hugh
wrist sticks to decide what they
should be fetching first.
Sometimes they will fetch CSS
before images or scripts.  Now,
something that could be useful
is
us as authors of the maeth
informing the browser what is
important to us.  Thankfully
over the last couple of years
browser vendors have been add
ago number of features to help
us with this.
Things like link connect or
pre-load or pre-fekt.
These help the browser fetch the
right thing at the right time,
and they can be a little bit
more efficient than some of the
custom loading logic based
approach
So, let's see how Lighthouse
actually guides us towards using
some of
The first thing Lighthouse tells
us to do is avoid multiple
costly round trips to any
origin.  In the case of ood Del
app we're using heavily Google
fonts.  Whenever you drop in a
Google font style sheet into
your page, it is going to
connect up to two sub domains.
The Lighthouse is telling us is
that if we were able to warmup
that
connection, we could could save
up to 3 milliseconds in our
connection time.  Taking
advantage of the pre-connect,
we ak effectively match that
connection latency.  Something
with Google fonts where our
fonlt face CSS is host owed
Google APIs.com and our font
resource rest host owed G
static, this can have a big many
packet.  We applied this
optimization and
The next thing Lighthouse
suggests
is we pre-load key requests.  It
informs the browse their a
resource is needed as part of
the current navigation and it
tries to get the browser
fetching it as soon as possible.
Now, here Lighthouse is telling
us that we should be going and
pre-loading our key web font
resources because we're
Pre-loading in a web font looks
like this.
Specificly Rel equals pre-load
you pass in as with a type of
font and then you specify the
type of font you're trying to
load in such as lof2.  The
impact this can have on your
page is quite stark.  So, nomly
without using [PE] spell load,
if web fonts happen to be
critical to your page, what the
browser has to do
is it first of all has to fetch
your html and parse your CSS and
somewhere much later down the
line it will fetch
Using link well present load as
soon as
the browser has parsed your html
it can fetch it early on.  In
the case of our app this was
able to shave a second off the
time it took for us to render
text using our web
Now, it's not quite that
straightforward if you are going
to try pre-loading fonts using
Google fonts.  There is one got
chau.  The Google font urls that
we specify
in our font faces and style
sheets happen to be something
that the font teams update.
These urls can expire or get
updated so what suggest to do if
you want complete control of
your font loading experience is
to self-host your web fonts.
This can be great because it
gives you things like link rel
pre-load.  We found the toog
Google when helper really useful
in helping us the web
Now, whether you're using web
fonts as part of your critical
resources or it happens to be
JavaScript, try to help the
browser identify your resources
a soon as possible.  If you are
connecting up to mult mull
origins consider use link Rel
reconnect.
Use link well pre-load.  We
happen to have a good pre-load
plug in available for web pack.
If you haven't asse future
navigation, consider using
pre-fetch.  This has good
support now in the
Now, we've got something special
to share with you today.  In
addition to features like
resource
hints, as well as present
pre-load, we have been working
on a brand new
experiment shul feature calling
priority hints.  This is a
feature that allows you to hint
to the browser how important a
resource is.
It expose [AES] new exposes a
new attribute with low, high, or
auto.  This allows us to convey
lowering the priority of less
important resources such as
non-critical styles, images, or
fetch API calls to reduce
contention.  We can also boost
the priority of more
In the case of our oodle app
this led to one practical place
where we could optimize.  So,
before we added lazy loading to
our images, what the browser was
doing is we had this image
carousel with all of our
doodles, and the browser is
fetching all of the images at
the very start of the carousel
with a high priority early on.
Unfortunately, it was the images
in the middle of the carousel
that were most important to the
user.  So, what we did was we
set the importance of those
background images to very low,
the for growbt ones to very
high, and with what this had was
a
two-second impact over 3G and
how quick rewe were able to
fetch and render those images.
So, nice positive experience.
We're hoping to bring this feech
tour
Canary in a few weeks, so keep
an eye      The next thing I
want to talk about the
typography.  It is fundamental
to good design.  If you are
using web fonts you don't want
to block rendering of your text
and you definitely don't want to
show invisible text.  We
highlight this in Lighthouse now
with the avoid p invisible text
while web fonts are loading
audit.
If you load your web fonts using
a font face block you are
allowing the browse tore decide
what to do if it takes a long
time for that web font to fetch.
Some browsers will wait anywhere
up to three seconds for this
before falling back to a system
font and eventually swap it out
to the font once it is download.
We're trying the avoid this
invisible text.  We wouldn't
have been able to see the
classic doodles if the web font
had      Thankfully with a new
feature called font display you
get a lot more control over this
process.
Font display helps you decide
how web fonts will render or
fall back based on how long it
takes for them to swap.
Now, in this case we're using
font display swap.  It gives the
font face a swreer so second
block period and an infinite
swap period.  This is going to
draw your text pretty
immediately with the fall back
font if the font takes a while
to load.  It is going to swap it
once the font face is available.
In the case of our (?
)  It allows us to display text
very early on and transfer it to
the web font      In general f
you happen to be using February
fonts as the large percentage of
the web does have a good web
font loading strategy in place.
There are a lot of web form
features you can use, checkout
Zach whether lance
Next up is Ewa to talk about
render
>> EWA GASPEROWICZ: Displaying
text is very important, but we
can go further than that.  There
are other parts of our
application that we could push
earlier in the download chain to
provide at least some basic user
experience a
Here on the Lighthouse timeline
strip you can see that during
this first few seconds when all
the resources are loading the
user cannot really see any
content.
Downloading and processing
sheets is blocking our ren derpg
process from making any
progress.
Well, we can try to optimize our
critical rendering path by
delivering
some of the slice a bit earlier.
If we extract the slides that
are responsible for this initial
render and align them in our
html, the browser is able to
render them straightaway without
waiting for the external
In our case we used MPN called
critical in html in a build
step.  While this module did
most of the heavy lifting for
us, it was still a little bit
tricky to get this working
The truth is, if you are not
careful or your site structure
is vaelly
complex, it might be really
difficult to introduce this type
of pattern if you
did not Plan for offshore
architecture from the very
beginning.  This is why it is
important to take performance
considerations early on.  If you
don't design for performance
from the start, there is high
chance
In the end, our risk paid off.
We managed to make it working,
and the app started delivering
content much
earlier improving our first
meaningful
So, to sum up, to unblock the
rendering process considering
aligning critical starts in the
document and
For non-critical script,
consider marking the attribute,
or lazy load them
Okay.  So, that's the whole
story of how we drew the horse
and tried to put it in a
>> EWA GASPEROWICZ: Let's take
a
This is how our app loaded on a
medium mobile device on a 3G
network.  Before and after the
optimization.
All of this progress was fueled
by us continuously checking and
following the Lighthouse report.
All of the hinges you have seen
today are LinkedIn Lighthouse
tool so that you can check them
in the context of your own
application.  If you would like
to check out how we technically
implemented all of the
changes, feel free to take a
look at our
The performance score went up
from 23 to 91.  That's pretty
nice, right.  However, our goal
was never to make Lighthouse
happy.  We wanted to make the
user happy.  And, high level
metrics included in
the report, like time
interactive or
perceptual speed index are a
good proxy
Also the snapshots timeline
gives you a nice visual feedback
about how much shorter the
waiting time for our
This is the full story of little
oodel app.  Now let's take a
look at some much
>> ADDY OSMANI: Ewa and I had
the benefit of being able to
think about performance very
early on but how does this apply
at scale to much larger
Let's take a look at NIKKE itch,
they are jaw pans largest media
company.  They have a site that
has 450 million users that are
accessing it and they spend a
lot of time optimizing their old
mobile site turning it into a
new PWA.  The impact of
performance optimizations were
huge.
[WRE] able to get
they were able to see 14 seconds
user and their daily active
users and page views also went
up.
What did they do to optimize
their performance?
You take a look at what NIKKEI
did, they will look familiar
that's because many of these
things we covered today.
NIKKEI optimized bundles, and
shrank them down by 3%.  One big
change they made was use web
pack to optimize their
performance in their first and
third party ones.
They were Al to use link Rel
fetch improving next page
performance loading by 75%.  In
addition to this they also took
a tip that Ewa was just walking
through, critical-path
optimization.  This an on open
Tau muzation where you're
sending down 14 kilobytes
consent, and you're able to xees
in enough styles in there you
can reduce it by quite a lot.
Here they were able to shake off
a second of their first
meaningful pain of
Finally on NIKKE, they took
advantage of the purple pattern.
Purple was a pattern first
discovered
by the polymer team, it stands
for push, render, pre-cache and
lazy load.
What they're doing is pushing
their
resources and they're rendering
their main article content quite
quiekly.
They're pre-cachecaching their
top stories using service
worker.  This gives them off
line access to read art I can
cuss as well, and they're lazy
loading code, and they're also
using skeleton screens to
improve the
So, we talked about how
performance and how businesses
to give users better
experience, but on users we have
one more thing that we think
could help with the future.
>> EWA GASPEROWICZ: Well, as
you are heard during the
keynote, we believe that machine
learning reports an exciting
opportunity for future in many
areas.
So, what if we could take this
two words of machine learning
and web performance and blend
them together?  Maybe it could
lead us to some really,
really interesting solution
solutions.  Today we want to
tell you about our experience
with machine learning and
explain why we think it has a
large
Here is an idea that we hope
will spark more experimentation
in the future
that real data can really guide
the user experiences we're
creating.
Today we make a lot of ash bra
Terry decisions about what the
user might want or need.
And, therefore, what is being
pre-loaded.  If we guess right,
we are able to prioritize a
small amount of resources, but
it is really hard to scale it to
the
At the same time, we have a
wealth of data about typical
user behavior readily available.
>> ADDY OSMANI: So, we actually
have data available to better
inform our optimizations today.
Using the Google analytics
reporting
API we can take a look at the
next top page for any url on our
site.  In fact we have a little
tool for this that anybody can
checkout.  Here it is for
developers.dpoog el.com/web.  As
we can see here a lot of the
users that land on the Chrome
Dev Tools documentation actually
end up going over
to Lighthouse so we could
potentially pre-fetch that page.
And, we could use this data to
improve our page load
performance.  This gives us the
notion of data driven loading
for improving the performance of
websites, but there is one piece
missing here.
Having a good probability model
is important because we don't
want to waste
our users data by aggressively
over (?)  And content.  We can
take advantage of that Google
analytics data and use machine
learning
and models like mark off chains
or neural networks in order to
implement such probability
models.  This is a lot less
subjective and error prone than
man Julie deciding what we
should be pre-fetching or
pre-loading
We can then wire this all up
using link Rel pre-fetch inside
of our sites so as the user
browsees through the site we're
able to fetch and cache things
they need
We can go further than this.
Earlier we talked about code
splitting and lazy loading but
in a single page app we're
dealing with routes, chunks, and
a bund ler.  So, instead of
pre-fetching pages we can go
granular.  What if we could
pre-fetch a number of
Well across all of these ideas
we've been focused on trying to
make some of these a little bit
more low
friction for web developers to
adopt.  Today we're happy to
announce a new initiative called
guess JS.  Guess.
js is a project focused on data
driven user experiences for the
web.  We hope that it is going
to inspire and poil laetion of
using data to improve web
perform skmans be object
objected.  That it is all open
source and available on GitHub
today.  This is built in
collaboration with
the open source kmin it tee by
NIKK Kevin, Carl Matthews from
gat see, Katie
Let's take a look at what guess.
gs out of the box.  The first
thing it is Google analytics
module.  It has a parser for
popular frameworks allowing to
us make map those urls back
We then have a comprehensive web
pack plug in that is able to do
machine learning training on
some of that data to determine
all the probabilities.  We're
able to bundle the JavaScript
for your routes and chunks and
we're then able to wire it all
together for
you so we can pre-fetch fetch
those
junks while the user navigates
through
Now, that is enough talk.  What
about showing you how this works
in practice?
So, here we have a demo of guess
JS in action.  What we're first
going to do is load up a wrap.
We're in the DevTools, we're in
low end mobile I'm ma laetion
over slow 3G.  This app is
rendered very quickly what we
can see in the network pan sell
the number of routes that are
already starting to be
pre-fetched because we have high
confidence there that are going
to be used.  We can toggle on a
visualization of this.  If pink
we voo pages high confidence the
user is going to want.  In green
we have low confidence and in
yellow we have mild confidence.
We can actually start to
navigate through this
application.  Let's say we go to
cheese.
We can visualize this again and
see cheesecake is a page that
users will often navigate to.
As you can see it loaded
instantly because it's already
in the users cache
Contextually we're able to
display to you in this demo all
the visualizations of confidence
levels we have for different
pages as we navigate through the
site.
Even this last page, the custard
loaded really, really quickly
using
Now, pre-fetching is a great
idea in practice, but we want it
to be mindful of the users data
plans.  And, this is where we
use navigate ter.connection.
effective type to make sure this
we're only pre-fetching things
when we think
So, this is our demo of guess.js
using gats bee.  By the way,
this also happens to be a PWA
with a great performance score,
so thank you to both minute
co-and Kyle for      Check ous
guess.
Today we talked about quite a
few things, but at the end of
the day, performance is about
inclusivity, it is about people,
it is about all of us.
We've all experienced slow pays
loads on the go, but we've
gotten an opportunity today to
consider considering to give ous
users more delightful
experiences that load really,
We hope you took something away
from this talk.  Remember
improving performance is a
journey.  On checkout some of
the things we talked about
today, talk to us in the web
Sandbox if you have got any
That's it from us.
(Applause) (Cheers)
Building the Future of
Artificial
Stage 2
Greg core
Dianne green
Die Dr.
Green
Fee
screen)
Realtime
Real-time captioning
Realtime cap
Realtime captioning on this
screen)
yank key
)>> At this time, please find
your seat.  Our session will be
begin soon.
>> DIANNE GREENE: All right.
Hello.
>> DIANNE GREENE: Who is
>> DIANNE GREENE: Me, too. Me
three.
So, I'm the moderator today.
I'm Dianne Greene, and I'm
running
Google Cloud and on the board
and I am
going to briefly introduce our
really amazing guests we have
here.
I also live on the standard
campus so I've known one of our
guests a long time      So, let
me just introduce them.  First
is fay fay, Dr.
fay
FeidFei Li.  He is the Google
scientist for Google Cloud, she
also runs the AI lab at Stanford
University, the vision lab, and
then she also founded sailors,
which is now AI4ALL, which you
will hear a little bit later.
And, is there anything you want
to add
So, then the other -- so now we
have Greg Corrado, and actually,
there is one amazing
coincidence.
Both Fei-Fei and Greg were
undergraduate physics majors at
Princeton together at the same
time.  And, didn't really know
each other
>> FEI-FEI LI: We were studying
>> GREG CORRADO: It was kind of
surprising to go to undergrad
together
and then neither of us in
Computer Science and then rejoin
later only once
>> DIANNE GREENE: Hall pass AI
and neural networks.Anyhow.  So,
Greg is a principal scientist in
the Google brain group.  He
co-founded it.
And, more recently he has been
doing a
lot of amazing work in health
with neuronetworks and machine
learning.  He has a Ph.D.
in neuroscience from Stanford,
and so he came in to AI in a
very interesting
way and maybe he'll talk about
the similarities between the
brain and what
Would you like to add anything
else? >> GREG CORRADO: No.
>> DIANNE GREENE: Okay. So, I
thought since both of them have
been involved in the AI field
for a
while, and it wasn't, you know,
it's recently become a really
big deal, but it would be nice
to get a little
perspective on the history, you
know, yours in vision and yours
in
neuroscience about AI and how it
was so
natural for it to evolve to what
it is
>> FEI-FEI LI: I guess I'll
start.
So, first of all, AI is a very
basic
field in the history of science,
of human civil layzation this,
is a
field of only of 0 60 years of
age.  It is a simple request.
Can machines think.  And, we all
know thinkers and thought
leaders like Allan Touring
challenged humanity with that
question.
So, about 60 years ago a group
of
very pioneering scientists,
computer
scientists like Marvin Menske,
John mark car thee, started
really this field,
John McCarthy who founded
Stanford' AI
So, where do we begin to build
machines that think?
Humanity is best at looking
inward in
ourselves and try to draw
inspiration from who we are, so
we started thinking about
building machines that resemble
human thinking.  And, when you
think about human in
till intelligence, you start
thinking about different aspect,
ability to reason, ability to
see, ability to hear, to
speak, to move around, make
decisions, manipulate.
So, AI started from the very
core foundational dream 60 years
ago, started
to proliferate as a field of
multiple
subfield, which includes
robotics, computer vision,
national language
And, there is a very important
development happened a round the
80's and 90's, which is a sister
field called machine learning
started to blossom.  And, that's
a field combining statistical
learnings, statisit was
noticestatistics with Computer
Science
and combining the quest of
machine intelligence, which is
what AI was borne
out of, with the fools and the
capabilities of machine
learning.  AI as a field went
through an
extremely fruitful productive
blossoming period of time.  In
fact, fast forward to the second
decade of 21st century, the
latest machine learning booming
that we are observing is called
deep learning, which
has a deep root in neuroscience,
which I will let you talk about,
and so
combining deep learning as a
powerful statistical machine
learning tool with
the quest of making machines
more intelligent.  Whether it is
to see or is it to hear
And, lastly I just want to say,
three critical factors converged
around
the
last decade, which is the
2000's, in
the beginning of of 2000 teens,
which are the three computing
factors.
One is the advance of hardware
that
Second is the emergence of Big
Data.
Powerful data that can drive the
statistical learning allege
algorithms.  And I was lucky to
be involved myself
And the third one is advances of
machine learning and deep
learning [A*L] algorithms.  So,
this converging of three major
factors brought us the AI boom
that
we're seeing today, and Google
has been investing in all three
areas.  Honestly earlier than
the curve.
Most of the effort started even
in
early 2000' and as a company
we're doing a lot of AI work
from research to products.
>> GREG CORRADO: And, it's been
really interesting to watch the
divergence and exploration in
various academic fields and then
the reconvergence as we see
ideas that are aligned.
So, it wasn't, as Fei-Fei says,
it wasn't so long ago that
fields like cognitive science,
neuroscience, Artificial
Intelligence, even things that
we don't talk about much more
like
cyber net I cans, we're really
all oo lined in a single
discipline, and they have moved
apart from each other and
explored these ideas
independently for a
And, then, with the Renaissance
in artificial neuronetworks and
deep
learning, we're starting to see
some reconvergence.
So, some of these ideas that
were popular only in a small
community for a couple of
decades are now coming back
into the mainstream of what
Artificial Intelligence is, what
statistical
pattern recognition is has
really been delightful to see.
But, it's not just one idea,
it's actually multiple ideas
that you see
that were maintained for a long
time in field like cognitive
science that are coming back
into the fold.  So, another
example beyond deep learning is
reinforcement learning.  So, for
the longest time if you looked
at a university catalog of
courses and you were looking for
any mention of reinforcement
learning whatsoever, you were
going to find it in a psychology
department or a cognitive
science department.
But, today as we all know, we
look at reinforcement learning
as a new opportunity, as
something that we actually look
at for the future of AI that
might be something that is
important to get machines to
really
learn in completely dynamic
environments, in environments
where they
have to explore entirely new
stimuli.
how this convergence has
happened back
in the direction from those
ideas into
mainstream Computer Science, and
I think there is some hope for
exchange back in the other
direction.
So, neuroscientists and
cognitive scientists today are
starting to ask whether we can
take the kind of computer
vision models that Fei-Fei
helped Pioneer and use those
hypotheses for how it is that
neural systems actually
compute, how our own biological
brains see.  And, I think that
that is a really, it's really
exciting to see this kind of
exchange between disciplines
that have
>> DIANNE GREENE: You know, one
little piece of history.  I
think that is also interesting
is
what you did Fei-Fei with image
net,
which is a nice way of
explaining, you
know, building these neural
networks where you labeled all
these images and
then people could refine their
allege algorithms.  Go ahead and
explain that really >>
FEI-FEI LI:  Sure.  About ten
years ago the whole community of
computer vision, which is the
sub field of AI was working on
the
holy grail problem of object
recognition, which is you open
your eye, you can see the world
full of objects,
like flowers, chairs, people,
you know,
and that's a building block of
visually intelligence and
intelligence in general.  And,
to crack that problem, we were
building as a field different
machine learning models.  We're
making small progress but we're
hitting a lot of walls.
And, when my student and I
started working this problem and
start thinking
deeply about what is missing in
the way we're approaching this
problem, we recognize this
important interplay
between data and statistical
machine learning models.  They
really reinforce each other in
very deep mathematical ways that
we're
That realization was also
inspired by human vision.  If
you look at how children learn,
it's a lot of learning through
Big Data experiences and
exploration.
So, combining that, we decided
to put
together a pretty epic effort of
we wanted to label all the
images we can get on the
Internet, and of course we
Google searched a lot, and we
downloaded billions of images
and used crowd
sourcing technology to label all
the
images, organize them into a
data set of
15 million images, organized in
22,000
categories of objects and put
that
together, and that's the image
project.
And, we de-mock craw ties edit
to the research world and
released the open
And, then we starting 2010 we
held an international challenge
for the whole AI community
called image net challenge.
And, one of the teams from
Toronto,
which is now at Google, won the
image >> DIANNE GREENE:
Yeah. Yeah. >> FEI-FEI LI:
With the deep learning con voe
lootion on the network model,
and that was year 2012.  And, a
lot of people think the
combination of image net and the
deep
learning model in 2012 was the
onset of
>> DIANNE GREENE: A way to
compare >> FEI-FEI LI:
Exactly. >> DIANNE GREENE:
And it was really good.     So,
Greg, you've been doing a lot
of brain inspired research, very
interesting research.  And, I
know you've been doing a lot of
Could you tell us a little bit
about that. >> GREG CORRADO:
Sure.
So, I mean, I think you know,
the image net example actually
sort of sets
a play book for how we can try
to approach a problem.
The kind of machine learning in
AI that is most practical and
most useful today is once where
machines learn through
imitation.  It is an imitation
game where if you
have examples of a task you can
perform correctly, the machine
can learn to imitate this, and
this is called
So, what happened in the image
recognition case is that by
Fei-Fei building an object
recognition data set, we could
all focus on that problem in a
really concrete, attract able
way in order to compare
different methods.  It turned
out that methods like deep
learning and artificial neural
networks were able to do
something really interest
anything that space that
previous machine learning and
artificial Artificial
Intelligence methods had not,
which was that they were able to
go
directly from the data to the
predictions and break the
problem up
knew him smaller steps without
having being told exactly how to
do that.
So, that's what we were doing
before.  That we were trying to
engineer features or queues,
things that we could
see in the stim stimuli that
then we would do statistical
learning on to
With artificial neural networks
and deep learning, we're
learning to do those things all
together.  And, this applies not
only to computer vision, but it
applies to most things that you
could imagine a machine
imitating.  So, the kinds of
things that we've
done, like with Google
SmartReplay and now smart
compose, we're taking that
same approach that if you have a
lot of text data, which it turns
out the Internet is full of,
what you can actually do is you
can look at the sequence of
words so far in a
conversation, or in an email
exchange
and try to guess what comes
next. >> DIANNE GREENE: You
know, I'm going to interrupt
here a little bit and
>> DIANNE GREENE: So, you're
talking about, you know, neural
inspired
machine learning and so forth,
and so,
you know, this Artificial
Intelligence is kind of bringing
into question what
are we humans, and then there is
this thing out there called
artificial general -- AGI.
Artificial general intelligence.
What do you think is going on
here? >> GREG CORRADO: I
really don't
So, there is a variety of
opinions
in the community, but my feeling
is that, okay, we have finally
gotten artificial neural
networks to be able to recognize
photos of cats.  Right.  That's
really great.
>> DIANNE GREENE: Fei-Fei was
that >> FEI-FEI LI: No.
>> GREG CORRADO: So the kind of
thing that is working well right
now is this sort of pattern
recognize, this immediate
response where we're able to
recognize something kind of
reflexly, and we now have, I
believe, machines can do pattern
recognition every bit as well as
humans can, and that's why they
can recognize objects in photo,
that is why they can do speech
recognition and that is why they
can win at a game liking.  That
is only one small sliver, a tiny
sliver of what goes into
something like intelligence.
Notions of memory and planning
and
strategy and contingencies, even
emotional intelligence, these
are things
that have just, we haven't even
scratched the surface.  So, to
me, I feel like it is really a
leap too far to imagine that
having finally cracked pattern
recognition, after some decades
of trying, that we
are therefore on the verge of
cracking all of these other
problems that go into
>> DIANNE GREENE: Although we
have gone way faster than either
of you ever expected us to go, I
believe. >> FEI-FEI LI: Yes
and no.
Humanity has a tendency to over
estimate short-term progress and
underestimate long-term
progress.  So, eventually we
will achieving things that we
cannot dream of, but Dianne and
Greg, I want to just give a
So, the definition of AGI,
again,
is an in
tral spectrum definition of what
humans can do.  I have a
two-year-old daughter who
doesn't like napg.  And, I
thought I'm smart enough to
scheme to put her in a very
complicated sleeping bag that
doesn't get herself
out of the crib, and just a
couple of months ago I was on
the monitor watching this kid,
two years old, where for the
first time she -- I was training
her for napg by herself.  She
was very angry.  So, she looked
around, figured out a weak spot
on the crib where she might be
able to climb out, figured out
how unzip her complicated
sleeping bag that I thought I
schemed to do really, you
know, to prevent that, and
figure out a
way to climb out of the cryp
that is way
taller than who she is and
managed to escape safely
(Laughter) without >>
DIANNE GREENE:  Okay.  Okay.
How about AGI equivalent to my
cat or equivalent to >>
FEI-FEI LI:  If you're shifting
the definition, sure. >>
FEI-FEI LI:  But even cat, I
think there are things that the
cat is
So, I do think that if you look
at an organism like a cat from a
behavioral level, like how cats
behave and how they respond to
their environments, I think that
you could imagine a world where
you have something like a toy
that, you know, is for
entertainment purposes that
approximates a cat in a bunch of
ways in that the sorts of
behaviors that the humans
observe, you're like oh, it
walks
around, it doesn't
bump in things, it meows at me,
I think
But what you can't do, you can't
take that robot and dump it in
the forest and have it figure
out what it needs to do in order
to survive and make >>
FEI-FEI LI:  But it's a goal.
>> DIANNE GREENE: It's a
healthy      And along the way,
like, you both,
at least we all three agree that
AI' capacity to help us solve
all our big problems is going to
outweigh any kind of negative,
and we're pretty excited about
that, I guess.
Like in Cloud you're kind of
doing some cool things with auto
ML and so >> FEI-FEI LI:
Yes.
So, we talk a lot, Dianne, about
the
belief of building be Nevada oh
lant technology of human use.
Our technology reflect our
values.  So, I personally, and I
know Greg'
whole team is working on
bringing AI to people and to the
fields that really
need it to make a positive
difference.
So, at Cloud we're very lucky to
be working with customers and
partners from
all kinds of vertical industries
from healthcare, where we
collaborate, to
agriculture, to sustainability,
to entertainment, to retail, to
commerce, to finance, where our
customers bring
some of the toughest problems
and their pain points and we can
work with them
For example, recently we rolled
out auto ML.
That is the recognition of the
pain of entering machine
learning.  It's still a highly
technical field.  The bar is
still high.
Not enough people are trained
experts in the world of machine
learning, but
yet, our industry already has so
much
need to, you know, tag pictures,
understand imagery image rees as
a vision.
So, we've worked hard and
thought
about the suite product called
auto ML
where the customer, we lower the
entry
barrier by relieving them from
coding machine learning custom
models themselves.
All they have to do is to give
us the
kind of -- provide the kind of
data and concept they need.
Here is an example of a
ramen company in Tokyo that has
many shops of ramens and they
want to build an app that
recognize the ramens from
different ramen stores.  And,
they give us the pictures of
ramens and the consents of their
store, one store, two store,
three, and what we do is to use
a technique, a machine learning
technique that Google and many
others have developed called
learning to
learn, and then build a
customized model
for the customer that recognize
ramens for their different
stores.  And, then the customer
can take that >> DIANNE
GREENE:  You know, I can write a
little C++, maybe some
JavaScript. >> FEI-FEI LI:
Absolutely.  Absolutely.
We're working with teams that
they don't have, not even C++
experience, and
we have a drag and drop
interface, and you can use auto
ML that way. >> GREG
CORRADO:  That is, because I
really believe that, you know,
there are so many problems that
can be solved
using this technique, that it's
critical that we share as much
as possible about how these
things work.  I don't believe
that these technologies should
live in law gardens, but instead
we should develop tools that can
be used by Everyone in the
community, that is why we have a
part of very aggressive open
source stance to our software
packages, particularly if AI.
And, that includes things like
TensorFlow that are available
completely freely and it
includes the kinds of service
these are available on Cloud to
do the kind of compute storage
and model tuning and surveying
that you need to
And, I think it is amazing that
we,
the same tools that my applied
machine learning team uses to
tackle problems that we're
interested in, those same
tools are accessible to all of
you, as well, to try to solve
the same problems in the same
way.
And, I've been really excited
with how
much -- how great the uptake is
and how we're seeing expanding
to other languages, mentioning
JavaScript, quick plug for
TensorFlow.
>> DIANNE GREENE: You should
>> GREG CORRADO: Yes. Exactly.
>> DIANNE GREENE: It does give
a
So, you're doing -- you're
building, I mean, with machine
learning we're bringing into
market in so many ways because
we do -- we have the tools
to build your own models, the
tenants and flow.  We have the
auto ML that brings it to any
programmer.  And, then, what is
going on with all
the APIs and how is that going
to effect every industry and
what do you see going
>> FEI-FEI LI: So, Cloud already
has a suite of APIs for a lot of
our industry partners and
customers from
>> DIANNE GREENE: Which are
based
>> FEI-FEI LI: For example, Bo
x is a major partner with Google
Cloud
where they recognize a
tremendous need
for organizing customers imagery
data to help customers.  So,
they actually use Google' vision
>> DIANNE GREENE: Yeah.
>> FEI-FEI LI: And that's a
model easily delivered to our
customers >> DIANNE GREENE:
Yeah.  It is pretty exciting.
Greg, how do you think that is
going to play out in the health
industry.  I know you have been
thinking about that? >> GREG
CORRADO: Yeah.  So, healthcare
is one of the problems that a
bunch of people are working on
at Google and a lot of people
are working on outside, as well,
because I think there is a huge
opportunity to use these
technologies to expand the
availability and the accuracy of
healthcare.
And, part of that is because
there is -- doctors today are
basically trying to
weather information, hurricane,
in order to provide care.
So, there is -- I think there
are thousands of individual
opportunities to
make doctors work more fluid to
build tools to solve problems
that they want
solved, and to do things that
help >> DIANNE GREENE: I
mean, I think you were telling
me that so many doctors
are so unhappy because they have
so much drudgery to do.
>> GREG CORRADO: Yeah.
Absolutely.  I believe there has
been a great, you know, when you
go to a doctor you're looking
for medical attention, right,
and right now a huge amount of
their attention is not actually
focused on the practice of
medicine, but is focused on a
whole bunch of other work that
they
have to do that doesn't require
the kind
of insights and care and
connection the real practice of
medicine does.
So, I believe that machine
learning in AI is going to come
in to healthcare
through assistive technologies
that help the doctors do what
they want to do
>> DIANNE GREENE: By
understanding
what they do and assist
testimony them.
>> DIANNE GREENE: Speaking of
human.  Fei-Fei, do you want to
talk a little bit about why
you've been so -- you
>> FEI-FEI LI: Yeah. Thank you.
So, if we look at the history of
AI, we've entered Phase II, the
first 60
years is AI as more or less a
niche technical field where
we're still laying down
scientific foundations, but
starting this point on, AI is
one of the biggest drivers
societal changes to come.
So, how do we think about AI in
this next space?  What is the
frame of mind that should be
driving us has been on top of my
mind, and I think deeply about
the need
for human centered AI, which, in
my
opinion, includes three elements
to
The first element is really
advancing AI to the next stage
and here we bring our collective
background from neuroscience,
cognitive science, you know,
whether we're getting to AGI
tomorrow or in 50 years, there
is a need
for AI to be a lot more
flexible,
nuanced, learn faster, in more
unsupervised, semi supervised
one shop learning ways to be
able to understand emotion, to
be able to communicate with
humans.  So, that is the more
human centered
The second part is the human
centered AI technology and
application
is that I love what you're
saying that there is no
substitute for humans.  This
technology, like all technology,
is to enhance humans, to augment
humans, not to replace humans.
We'll replace certain tasks or
replace
humans out of danger or tasks
that we cannot perform, but the
bottom line is we can use AI to
help our doctors, to
help our disaster relief
workers, to
help decision makers.  So, there
is a lot of technology in
robotics, in design, in natural
language practicing that is
centered around human
The third element of human
center
AI is really to combine the
thinking of AIs a technology, as
well as the societal impact.
We are so nice ant in seeing the
impact in this technology, but
already, like Dianne said, that
we are seeing the impact in
different ways, ways that we
might not even predict.  So, I
think that is really important
and it's a responsibility of
Everyone from academia to
industry to government
to bring social scientists,
philosopher,
law scholars, policy makers,
ethicists,
and historians at the table and
to study
more deeply about AI social and
humanistic impact.  That is the
three elements of human
>> DIANNE GREENE: That's pretty
>> DIANNE GREENE: -- I think
we here at Google are working as
hard as we
You know, you mentioned, you
know, what we need to be careful
about out there with AI and
regulatory.
What are some of the barriers
to, you know, I think every
company in the world has a use
for AI in many, many ways.
I mean, it's just exploding in
all the verticals, but there are
some impediments to adoption,
for example in financial, the
financial industry, they need to
have something called
explainable AI.  And, could you
just talk about some of the
different barriers you see to
being
>> FEI-FEI LI: We should start
>> GREG CORRADO: I think there
are a bunch of really important
things to consider.  So, one of
the things is, of course we
want to have machine learning
systems
that are designed to fit the
needs of the folks that are
using them and applying them.
And, that can often include not
just giving you the answer, but
telling me something about how
that was derived.
So, some kind of explain
ability.
So, in the healthcare space for
example we've been working on a
bunch of
things in medical imaging, and
it is not acceptable to tell the
doctor something looks fishy in
this X-ray or this pathology
slide or retinal scan.  You have
to tell them, well, what do you
think is wrong, but more
importantly, you actually have
to show them where in the image
you think the evidence for that
conclusion lies so that they can
then look at it and decide
whether they concur or they
disagree or oh, well, there is a
spec of dust there and that's
what the machine is picking
And the good news is that these
things actually are possible and
I
there has kind of been this
unfortunate mythology that AI
and deep learning, in
particular, is a black box, and
it really isn't.
We didn't study how it worked,
because for a long time it
really didn't work that well.
But now that it is working well,
there are a lot of tools and
techniques that
go into examining how these
systems
work, and I think explain
ability is a big part of it in
terms of making these things
available for a bunch of
applications. >> FEI-FEI LI:
So, in addition to explain
ability, I would add bias.
I think bias is a issue we need
to
address in AI, and I see bias
from where
I sit two major kind of bias we
need to address.
One is the pipeline of AI
development starting from the
bias of the data to the outcome
of the bias.
And, we have heard a lot about
if the machine learning
algorithm is fed with
data, that does not represent
the
problem domain in a fair way we
will
introduce bias, whether it is
missing a
group of people' data or bias
related to a skewed
distribution.
These are things that would have
deep consequences whether you
are in the healthcare domain or
finance or legal decision
making.
So, I think that is a huge
issue, very nicely that Google
is already addressing that.  We
have a whole team at Google
working >> DIANNE GREENE:
Yeah. This is true. >>
FEI-FEI LI: And, another bias I
think is important, is the
people who are developing AI.
>> FEI-FEI LI: And, the lack of
>> DIANNE GREENE: It is so
important, and that kind of
brings me to
maybe some of our -- we're
getting close
to the end, but if, you know,
where is AI going?  I mean, how
prevalent is it going to be?
We look at universities and
these machine learning classes
have 800 people, 900 people.
There is such a demand.  Every
computer Science graduate wants
Where is it going?  I mean, will
every high school
graduating senior be able to
customize AI to their own
purposes?
And, howwhat does it look like
five, ten years from now?
>> FEI-FEI LI: So, from a
technology point of view, I
think that because of the
tremendous investment in
resource, both in the private
sector, as
well in the public sector now
every -- many countries are
waking up to investing AI.
We are going to see a huge
continue
development of AI technology.  I
am mostly excited at Cloud or
seeing what Greg' team doing, AI
being delivered to the
industries that really
matter to people' lives and work
quality
But, Dianne, I think you are
also
asking is how are we educating
more
>> DIANNE GREENE: Both making
it easier to use and educating
them, and what is it going to
look like?
>> FEI-FEI LI: That's a really
tough question, because at the
core of today's AI still
calculus, and that is >>
GREG CORRADO:  So I think that
from the kind of -- from the
tech industry perspective or
from the computer science
education perspective, I think
that we're going to see AI and
ML become as essential as
networking is, right.  Like, no
one really thinks about oh,
well, I'm going to write some
software and it's going to be
stand au lon on a box and it's
not going to be a TCPI
connection, right.  We all know
that you're going to have a TCPI
connection at the end of the day
somewhere and Everyone
understands the basics.
Networking stack, and that is
not just at the engineering, the
level of engineers, that is the
level of
designers of
executives, of product
developers and leaders.  And,
the same thing I think is going
to happen with machine learning
and AI which is that designers
is going to start to understand
how can I make a completely
revolutionary kind of product
that folds in machine learning
the same way that we fold in
networking and Internet
technologies into something
everything we built.
I think we are going to see
tremendous upkeep and it become
be Annie vase I have background
of the technologies.  I think in
that process the ways we are
using AI are going to evolve.  I
think right now you're seeing a
lot of things where AI and
machine learning
adds some spice, some extra
little coolness on a feature,
and I think that what you're
going to see over the next
decade is you're going see more
integration into what it means
for the product to actually
work.  And, I think that one of
the great opportunities there is
actually going to
be the development of artificial
emotional intelligence that
allows products to actually have
much more natural and much more
fluid human interaction.  We're
good beginning to see that in
the assistant now with speech
recognition, speech synthesis,
understanding dialogues and
which exchanges, .  I think this
is still in its infancy.  We're
going to get to a point where
the products that they build
interact with humans in the ways
most humans find
>> FEI-FEI LI: I spend a a lot
of time with high xol lers.  I
really believe in the future.
We always talk about AI changing
the world, and I always say the
question is who is changing AI.
And, to me, bringing more human
mission ond thinking into
technology development and
thought leadership is really
important.  Not only for the
future of our
technology and the value we
instill in our technology, but
also in bringing the diverse
group of students and future
leaders into the development of
AI.
So, you know, at Google we all
work a
lot on this issue, and
personally I'm very involved
with AI4ALL, which is a
non-profit that educates high
schoolers around the country
from diverse
background, whether they're (?
)  Or students of unrepresented
minority groups, and we bring
them on to AI,
university campus, and work with
them on
>> DIANNE GREENE: And, at
Google
we're just completely committed
to bringing all our best
technologies to everybody in the
world, and we're doing that
through the Cloud, and we're
bringing these tools, we're
bringing these APIs, and the
training and the
partnering and the processors,
and we're pretty excited to see
what all you guys
(Applause)
Design Actions for the Google
Assistant
:  Beyond smart speakers
, to
phones and Smart Displays
Thank you for joining.  Our
session will be begin soon.
Design Actions for the Google
Assistant
(Realtime viewing screen)
>> Hi husband and I have been in
a somewhat long distance
relationship for a few years
now.
We talk on the phone and message
a lot.  But, perhaps what is
most enjoyable for me is when I
visit him, I leave little notes
all over his apartment.  And,
sometimes when I'm home alone,
he'll start changing the color
of the smart lights in my living
room to let me
Our human conversations take a
lot of different forms.  We
don't just talk verbally,
depending on where we are and
what we're trying to
say, we might write, hold hands,
or even
This is human conversations that
have inspired us to create
conversations with technology.
It's no surprise, then, that
we're starting to incorporate
more modalities
But, with this increased number
of devices and complexity of
interactions,
it might feel overwhelming to
design for the Google Assistant.
If you look at the Google
Assistant
today, I can talk to it not just
through the speaker in my living
room, but also through my car or
my headphones.
I can tap on my phone or my
watch.  But how do we design for
an increased
I'm Saba Zaidi and I'm an
interaction design other the
Google assist tantd team.  I
will be talking about how you
can design actions across
services and give
you some frameworks and some
tips
gear and I can tell you using
the design
Before we get started talking
about how to design services
across services we need to get a
better experience of
Let's start with a journey
through a user' day.  You wake
up in the morning to the sound
of an alarm ringing on your
Google Home without even getting
out of your blanket you can say,
hey, Google, stop.
You get up, get ready, and as
you're about to head out you
want to make sure you don't need
an umbrella, so you turn to the
Smart Display in your hallway
and you ask, hey Google, what is
the weather today?
You're able to hear a summary
and also
As you're walking to your car,
you take out your phone and tap
on it to ask the Google
Assistant to order your favorite
from Starbucks.  It is able to
connect to you Starbucks
As you're driving, you want to
listen to your favorite pod cast
or the
news, and you can ask Google
Assistant for help in a hands
freeway and it can connect you,
for example, to NPR news update.
You go about your day and when
you come back home it's time to
make dinner for your family.
You turn to the Smart Display in
your
kitchen and you ask, for
example, Tasty for help with a
recipe, like in this place,
pizza bons.  Tasty comes back
and you can hear and see on the
screen step-by-step
After dinner, it's time to
unwind with your family in the
living room, you decide to play
a buzz feed personality quiz,
and it's a great way for your
family to get together around a
shared
And then you head to bed.  You
say, hey Google, good night.
It's able to start your custom
bedtime routine, which includes
for example,
setting your aur alarms or
telling you
As you can see users were able
to interact with a Google
Assistant similar to human
interactions in that there were
And a although there were a lot
of different devices, there are
some overarching principals.
First, the experience was
familiar whether it was morning,
evening orca mute, users can
access their favorite Google
Assistant actions whenever,
The system was available in
different contexts.  You saw it
being used on the go and at
home, up close and from a
distance, and
So, as you're thinking about
your actions, think about all
the different
And lastly, different devices
lend themselves to different
modes of interaction.
Some are voice only, some are
visual and some are a mix of
both.  And, we'll talk a bit
more about the strengths of and
weaknesses of each of
First, let's take a deeper look
at a couple of those devices and
see how these principles apply.
You have already heard about
Smart Displays now.  They were
announced early this year, and
even though it was a new device
users can expect it to feel
familiar.  It is essentially
like a Google Home with a
screen.
It is designed to be used at
home from a distance, and as a
shared device.
And, as you can see in this
queue inspiration action
example, even though will is a
screen, users still interact
with the device through voice.
They don't have to tap through
complex app navigation.  Instead
the visuals are designed to be
seen at a distance.  And, of
course, the user can walk up to
the screen and touch it if they
want.
Next, let's take a quick look at
phones.  One thing to note here
is that we're making phones more
visually assistive,
as well, similar to smart die
replies, allowing for a greater
focus on the content.  These
devices, as you know, are great
for use cases, on the go, up
close, and in a private
environment.  And, users can
interact with the Google
Assistant on the phone through
So, hopefully that gave au
better sense of what the
experiences on Google
Now, in order to divine for so
many devices, it helps to have a
vocabulary to help categorize
them.
At Google we use this divine
framework
called the multi modal spectrum.
It helps us categorize devices
based on their interaction
types.  On one end you have
voice only devices
like the Google Home and other
smart
On the other end you have visual
only devices, like a phone or a
Chromebook that is on mute, and
most watches.  So, you have to
look at these devices      And,
in the middle, you have what we
call multi modal devices, in
that
Cars and smart displays that
rely primarily on voice but have
optional visuals are known as
voice forward      Phones and
Chrome books with the audio on,
which can use mix of both voice
and visuals are known as enter
So, now we have a vocabulary for
categorizing these devices, but
before
we can start designing for them
it helps to understand the
zr*ents and weaknesses
Let's talk about voice first.
Voice is great for natural
input.
We've been using it for melony
au, whether you're a kid, a
scene your, someone who is not
tech savvy, it is still really
intuitive.  It is great for
hands free far afield use cases.
Like, setting a timer in the
kitchen
And it helps reduce task
navigation.  So, for example, if
you were out on a
run, you could ask your favorite
Google action that is about
fitness and ask it about your
work outs.  Instead of having to
pull out your phone, navigate to
that app and search
Similarly, could you ask the
Google Assistant to play the
next song without having to mess
with any controls.
So, voice has a lot of benefits.
It's great.  But, it does have
some limitations.
Think about the last time you
were at a cafe.  You probably
walked past all the pace strees,
looked at the menu and made eye
contact with the cashier.  Think
about how difficult that
interaction would be if it was
just through voice.
Have a listen at what the menu
would
>> Espresso, latte, vanilla
latte, Kappa theen oh, moek kau,
American oh, flat white, hot
chocolate, black cough pee and
tea.
>> That feels pretty
overwhelming, right, it is like
waismg all the options go by and
catching the right one.  It is
like looking at a particularrer
voice isy ferm moral and linear
and that makes it very difficult
to hold a lot of
By contrast, the menu is a lot
easier to scan if it looks like
this.
You can imagine that the problem
gets compounded if you also
today compare price xes
calories.  So, visuals are great
for scanning and      We aum so
use them a lot to reference
objects in the world.  So, I can
look at all the baked goods and
then point to the one that I
want.  Instead of, for example,
having to hear or say out loud
something like sma
small sugar cookie with a
chocolate tciz
So, voice and visuals both have
their benefits, and it often is
useful to use both.
So, in this example, we usually
prefer to look at the menu but
then talk to the
Similar benefits to using both
voice and visuals exist in the
real world, as well.  Or in the
digital world, as well.  And,
that is what makes multi modal
devices, like phones and smart
displays
such a unique opportunity by
leveraging the best of both
voice and visuals,
they're able to provide really
rich interactions.
One thing to keep in mind, au
again is to start with a human
conversation.  You might have an
Apple ready, but avoid the
temptation to duplicate it.
Instead, try to open serve a
relevant conversation in the
real world or role play it with
a colleague.  And, write down
that dialogue.  You'll realize
that not everything that is in
your app does well as
conversation or vice versa.
Instead think of a reaction that
is a companion to your app.  I
won't go into detail into how to
write good dialogue or create
per Sony, but I highly recommend
you checkout our brand new
conversation design website at
that link there.  It goes into
great detail into how to get
started.
So we've learned that we need to
create spoken dialogue and add
visuals      So, let's take a
look at an example of how to do
that and how that helps us
So, if you haven't already, I
would
encourage you to checkout the
Google
io 2018 action to help you learn
more about this event.  We
started by writing a spoken
dialogue as for a voice only
device like a Google Home, and
it includes terms like this one,
a user can say browse sessions
and we respond with a spoken
response like here are some of
the topics left for today.  And,
so on.
Now, in order to take this
dialogue and scale it, we need
to take every turn like this,
and think about all the ways we
can incorporate visual
components to it.  This would
include, for example, display
prompts, cards, and suggestions.
In our example we can accompany
that spoken protht with a
display prompt like which topic
are you interested in?  This
helps carry the written
conversation on a screen.  We
can add a list of sessions as a
card, a user could tap on that
for example, and we could have a
suggestion chip like none of
these.  And, this helps a user
know how to
Once we've constructed our
response
to have spoken and visual
elements, we can then map that
response to the multi modal
spectrum from earlier.  So,
depending on whether the device
has visual or audio capabilities
or how important voice is, we
can choose the
You already saw what our
response would look like on a
Google Home.
We would simply have the spoken
prompt.  Let's take a look at
what the response
A Smart Display is a voice
forward device, so we still need
to show all the spoken prompt
and make it carry the whole
conversation.
We don't really need a display
prompt anymore, especially if
we're going to have better
visuals, like the list and the
chips.  A phone on the other
hand, is enter modal device, and
we need to have both the voice
and the visuals carry the
conversation.  In this case, you
might notice that we shortened
the spoken prompt because we can
direct the use tore look at the
screen for more details.
And, Ulas will talk more about
how you can do that.  And, of
course the rest of the visual
And finally, if your phone was
on silent, we would simply
ignore the
spoken prompt and the visual
components are able to carry the
complete      So now we've
learned that in order
to scale our dialogue, we need
to write spoken prompts and add
visuals to them
But, how do we know what kinds
of visuals to add?
I would like to leave you with
five
tips for how how can incorporate
visuals into your dialogue.  For
that let's take up this made up
assistive action called National
Anthem player on a Smart
Display.  As the name suggests
the user can ask for a country
and it will come back with the
National Anthem for that
country.  When you invoke this
action, it gives you a welcome
message that sounds like
(Audio clip:  Welcome to
National Anthem player.  I can
play the National Anthems from
20 different countries,
including United States, Canada,
and the you nighted kingdom.
Which would you like to hear?
>> Saba Zaidi: As you can see
the device is currently writing
on the screen what it is saying
out loud.  This is a missed
opportunity especially by now
we've learned that visuals have
some strength over voice and
that smart displays are great
for
So, tip No. 1 is to consider
cards rather than just display
prompts.
In this case, we've swapped out
the words for a carousel.  Users
can quickly browse through the
list and select the country that
they want.
You'll notice this is kind of
similar to the menu example we
looked at in the cafe where
visuals are helping someone
Additionally, things like maps,
charts, and images are also
great on visual devices, because
they're difficult to describe
through voice, similar to the
Second, consider varying your
spoken and your display prompts.
This is particularly useful for
devices that are enter modal
that might have a display prompt
next to a card.  And, some of
that information might be
redundant.  So, in this case,
we're stripping out the examples
for the countries in the display
prompt because the card already
Third, consider visuals for
suggestions.
Here we know that the user is a
repeat user, so we're
reorderering the list so that
they're most frequently visited
countries show up first.  We're
also using suggestion chips to
allude to the user how they can
follow up or pivot a
conversation.  This kind of
discovery can be quite
Next, you can use visuals to
increase your brand expression.
We used to allow you to change
your voice and choose a logo,
but now we're also going to be
allowing you to choose
a font and the background image,
and Ulas will talk more about
how you dock that.  As you can
see here, the experience looks a
lot more custom and immerse I
Lastly, visual devices are great
for carrying conversations that
started on a voice only device.
So, for example, if I use this
National Anthem action on a
Google Home
and I wanted to see the lyrics,
the action can send a
notification after a few steps
to my phone and I can take out
my phone and read them there.
So, hopefully those five tips
will help you in incorporating
more visuals
Let's summarize what we've
learned
so far on how to design actions
for the assistant.  First, users
interact with the Google
Assistant in a variety of
different ways and contexts, so
this could include i home or on
the go, up close or at a
In order to design across so
many modalities, it helps to
keep in mind the multi modal
spectrum and think of your
responses of having visual
components as
And lastly, learn and leverage
the strengths of each of these
modalities.  We learned for
example that visuals
are great at scanning, brand
expression and discovery.  So,
instead of just showing on the
screen what you're saying out
loud, try to use cards instead.
All right.  Now I'm going to
hand it over to my colleague
Ulas, who is going to talk about
how you can develop these
actions.
>> Thank you, [SAB]
>> Ulas Kirazci: As we said
this
type runs on many assistants and
in the future will run-on many
others.  It will run well on all
these devices today, as well as
all the devices dmt future.
To walk you through this, I'm
going to use a test action I
created called
California surf report that
gives wave
height and weather information
information in beaches in
California for surfers.  So,
currently I only have spoken
responses.  No visuals yet.  So,
let's see what the sounds like
on
(Audio clip:  What is the air
for most of today, waves will be
from two to three feet in the
morning to three to four feet in
the afternoon.
Expect waist swell in the
morning with northwest winds.
Shoulder high surf in the
afternoon
>> Ulas Kirazci: Great. Pretty
informative.  Now let's take a
look at what this sounds like
and looks like on a voice
forward device, like Smart
Display.  Switch the demo,
please.
Okay, Google, talk the
California surf report.
(Google:  Okay.  Let's get the
test version of
Welcome to California surf
report.
>> Tell me the surf report for
(Google:  Surf insanity fau
crews beach looks fair for most
of today.  Waves will be from
two to three feet in the morning
to three to four feet in the
afternoon.) .
>> Ulas Kirazci: I cut it short
As you can see spoken responses
are a good way to get started
and working
well on many devices, but, when
we have
is a screen we can make it a lot
better.     One of the best
visuals we can add and the
easiest once to add is a basic
card.
And, here is an example from the
note JS client library of how to
add a basic card to your
responses.  So, we start with
the spoken prompt,
as usual, and the second
statement of ask as a basic
card.  A basic card can have a
title, subtitle, body text and
optional image.  .  So, let's
see what this looks like on our
Smart Display again.  Let's
switch to the demo, please.
Okay, Google.
(Google:  Surf in Santa Cruz
beach looks fair for most of
today.  Waves will be from two
to three feet in the morning to
three to four feet in the
afternoon.
Expect waist swell in the
morning with northwest winds.
Shoulder high surf in the
afternoon with southwest winds.
>> Ulas Kirazci: Okay. Great.
Now it looks much better.  We
have a nice visual for it rather
And, here is some other kinds of
cards you can use.  There is a
carousel list card that allows
you to display a set of things
that the user can choose from.
There is also a newly introduced
table card.
Another great way to add visuals
to your action is to use
suggestion chips.  Suggestion
chips allow the user to
understand what they can do in
this turn in the conversation.
And, also they simplify user
input.  You can use more about
responses at
And, by the way, all of this,
like I promised, works equally
well on enter modal device, like
a phone.
As you can see we formatted the
font sizes and layout to fit the
enter modal      Okay.  Great.
So, next maybe what we want to
do is shorten the spoken
response a bit, because it's a
bit repetitive with the
information that is already on
the card.  Users can just look
at the display for these.
So, how do we do this?  We have
a feature in the API called
capabilities.
So, instead of thinking if
Google Home
do this, L Smart Display do
that, think
about what capabilities the
surface that the user is
interacting with you on had.
Does it have a screen?  Can it
output audio?
The capabilities of the device
are reported to you in every web
protocol so you get to, though,
what this is on every
conversation term.  And, here is
a sample list of capabilities
that we support, and there is a
-- you can learn more at the
link.
So, in our use case what we're
looking for is the screen output
capability.
This indicates that the user
device has a screen so we can
show them a card.  By the way,
if you don't want your responses
to differentiate between ones
with displace and once that are
(?)  Only you can always add a
card and we will strip it out
for you lently.  So, this makes
it easy for you to
And, here is, again t no JS
client library snippet that
shows how to use this.
In the first if statement
determined that the user device
did not have a screen.  So, we
have the full content in the
spoken response.
In the else clause we know that
there is a screen so we shorten
the spoken response and end it
with a phrase like here is the
report to lead the user to the
screen, and then we append the
basic
So, let's see how this looks
like
Okay, Google, show me the
shortened
(Google:  Surf in Santa Cruz
beach looks fair for most of
today with two to three foot
waves in the morning and three
to four foot waves in the
afternoon.  Here is the report.
>> Ulas Kirazci: So that sounds
a
Another way you can use
capabilities is to require that
your action only run-on devices
that have the capabilities.
This is what we call static
capabilities.  And, you can
configure these through the
actions on Google console as you
can see here.
But, only use this if your
action absolutely makes no sense
without that capability.
So, for example, the National
Anthem
player action that Saba talked
about would not make sense on a
device without audio.  So, this
would be a good place to use
that.
However, for the surf report
app, it equally works well on
voice only and display only
devices.  So, it wouldn't be a
good place to use this.  You can
configure all of this using
Another high quality and easy
way
to target multiple surfaces is
to use Google libraries we call
helpers.
So, I've been asking California
surf report, the surf report
with the beach
name, but if I don't say the
beach
name, I get a prompt, which
beach?  Now, this doesn't tell
me what I can say.  It doesn't
tell me which beach this action
actually supports, so we can fix
that with a helper called ask
for carousel.
What ask with carousel does is
it presents the user with a list
of options
to pick from, and associates
visuals with each item.
In addition, when the user
utters the query to select an
item, Google does the
matching of the query to the
item so we can deal with
variations in how people
So, let's make our prompt better
with the ask with carousel
helper.
And, again, the note JS library
snippet here.  We start with the
spoken response with the prompt,
and we add a carousel to it.
And, carousel is made up of
items, and each item has a list
of phrases that you think the
user might say to match this
item.  And, visuals associated
with each item so the user can
understand what they're
So, let's switch to the demo and
see what this looks like.
Okay, Google, show me the surf
(Google:  Which beach do you
want to see the report for?  ?
>> Ulas Kirazci: So this is the
example where I'm a little
confused as
Okay, Google, show me the beach
(Google:  Which beach would you
like to know about?
)
>> Ulas Kirazci: Now it is
great.  It lets me know what the
possible options are and even
tap on one if I
And, we always continuously
improve
the experience with these
helpers, so this is one of the
advantagees of helper is that we
continue to modify them and
Now, since we launched the card
at
API last year we've since come
up with smart displays.  aus
noticed on smart displays, each
conversation turn takes up the
entire screen.  So, given this
fact, maybe we can make our
visuals more branded and give
them a little bit more flare.
So, we're introducing styling
options this year.
So, here is how it works.  Let's
switch to the demo, please.
So, here is a new tab in the
actions on Google console called
team customization.  You can
modify the background color,
primary color, so that's like
the font color of the text, and
the typography and even set a
background image.
Let's say we want to make this
cursive, and let's add a
background image.
What do we got here?
So, this is the landscape pass
image, and then we want to add a
portrait image, as well.
All right.
Now all we have to do is save
and then we click test right
here to
update our test version
.  All right.  Now let's see
what this looks like on the
demo.
Okay, Google, show me the surf
(Google:  Surf in Santa Cruz
beach looks fair for most of
today with two to three foot
waives in the morning and three
to four foot waves in the
afternoon.
>> Ulas Kirazci: I think now
that looks really beautiful.
Smart displays are coming out
later this year; however, you
can start building your action
against these vish yums today
using the updated simulator.
So, we've added a new simulator
device type for smart displays,
as you can see here.
And, we've also added a display
tab which shows you the full
screen version of what you would
get on a Smart Display.
And o the left side, as usual,
you have the spoken responses,
as well as
One last thing.  We said the
assistant is in many Places.
So, if the users interacting
with your action using a voice
only device, maybe they also
have a device that has a display
on it.  For example, a phone.
So, what if in your current turn
in the conversation you really
want to have your response
display something.
So, for example, in the surf
report action, the user might
ask us for the full report, and
we want to return the hour by
hour wave height graph.  So, how
do we do that?
There is a feature in the API
called multi-surface
conversations, and here is how
it works.
In each API web book we report
not
only the capabilities of the
device that
the use user is currently using,
but the union of the
capabilities of the all the
devices the user owns.  In this
example what you see is that
the current user device only has
a voice app capability and has
no screen.  But in available
surfaces we can see the screen
output capability.  So, the user
seems to have another device
with a screen on it.  So, how do
we use this?
We, again in the client library,
we have a function to help you
to inspect
if the user has a certain
capability
Now we determine that the user
has a device with this
capability.  How do we transfer
the user to the other device?
We have a function, ask for new
surface that does this.  And,
you can give it a notification
that will appear on the target
device.  In addition to the list
of capabilities that you're
require for continuing your
conversation.
I'm not going to demo this, but
here is what it looks like.  So,
let's say the user said show me
the full report and they're
talking to you on a Google Home.
So, you would call the ask new
surface
function that I showed you
earlier and
we ask the user permission to
send the conversation over to
the users phone.
And if the user accepts, then
there is a notification sent to
the new device, the conversation
ends on the current
device and when the user taps
the notification, then they
resume the conversation from
where you left off.  Like this.
Note that this is not just for
single responses.
This works equally well when you
want to continue the
conversation.  So, we bring the
full context over so
So, to sum up, we've built a lot
of features in the API for you
to add visuals to your
responses.  So, please use them.
And, we make it such that we
take your responses and optimize
them as best as possible to all
these surfaces, and surfaces in
the future without extra
And, if you wanted to customize
your responses, always think of
capabilities and not individual
device types.
This way we can run your action
on new devices without any extra
work from you.
>> Saba: Thank you. So, I
would just like to end with an
invitation for you.
Next time you order coffee at a
cafe or do a presentation like
this one,
start to notice all the
different modes of interactions
you use every day, and let the
richness of those human
conversations inspire how you
design
actions for users and help us
evolve what it means to have
conversations with
Here are some links to resources
we mentioned, and how to give
feedback.  So, also come just
talk to us.  We will be with our
team at the assistant office
hours and Sandboxes ready to
answer your questions and
showing off some of the devices.
(
>>
(Applause)
...
Introduce
IntroducingIntroducing
Introducing AIY.
Do-it-yourself Artificial
Intelligence
IntroduceIntroducing AIY
Do-it-yourself
Artificial Intelligence
>> At this time, please find
your seat.  Our session will
begin soon.
>> You can see, right?
>> Good afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to the AIY session.
How is everybody for I/O so far?
Everybody had a good lunch
today?  Yes?  Okay.  As you can
see on the screen, the name
of the session is introduction
to AIY.  What is AIY?  AIY is a
line of a product Google
makes for developers like you,
makers all around the world, to
make applications for Artificial
Intelligence by yourself.
That's the name of AIY, where
that came from.
Today joining me my colleagues
in
development relations, my name
is Bill Luan.
Sebastian is joining me and
Dushyantsinh joining me.
Before we begin, I will
introduce my colleagues.
>> DUSHYANTSINH JADEJA: Hello,
everybody.  My name is
Dushyantsinh.
I am excited to show demos on
the AIY.  Before we start, I
would like Sebastian is give you
a quick overview of what is AIY.
And to set the context for the
talk.
>> SEBASTIAN TRZCINSKI-CLEMENT:
Thank
you, I'm Sebastian, with this
very complicated last name.
A joined Google recently, just
about 11 years ago.  With my
teams, what we do around the
world, especially in major
markets is
help developers and startups
build better mobile and weapon
applications.
Today, I want to talk about AIY.
Before that let's talk about
DIY, do-it-yourself.  Do you
know what this is?  It is not a
UFO.
It is actually a musical
instrument which makes nice
sounds.  But no, it was not
invented in prehistoric times.
It was actually created in the
year 2000 in Switzerland.
Schweitzer is land is the
country where I am officially
based, which is
not one of the other UFOs,
planes, because I travel quite a
bit to see my team.
This is also a window into DIY
culture.  I will take you
through a brief
history of humankind's appetite
for DIY.
If you read the book, the
history of humankind, you will
know what I am talking about.
Our human ancestors were
building tools as part of
weapons, instruments, using
stone, wood.  If we skip a few
generations of humans, we're
still using wood to create
things.
This is one of my brothers,
mattias
and sister Lidia 30 years ago.
I'm sure you and your siblings
just tinkered with stuff,
whatever you can lay your hands
on.
Let's fast forward to the
electronics age.
Do you remember in it the '90s,
desktops -- not even laptops --
desktops were so expensive.
Show of hands, who built
computers.  I'm the only one who
is too old for this?
This animated image, you can see
how I
used an overhead projector and
dismantled LCD screen to build a
cheap homemade projector.  My
mom was annoyed everything was
all over the living room.  She
said go outside, fresh air.
That is my outside reusing
garbage bags.
$1 for a garb  -- garage bags to
build a balloon.  Almost strong
enough to lift me up.
My other brother, Lauren started
tinkering with 3D printers.
My other brother -- the one on
the right.  The left is a Forto
in a museum.
As I said DIY is in our D.N.A.
from early on.  It is also in
Google's D.N.A.
Four years ago, you remember the
engineer from the Paris office
-- I am actually French.
This engineer came here at I/O
to show
the VR platform he had built
using
cardboard, during his 20%
innovation time.  This is the
Daydream at VR platform.
Here's what's interesting.
One hand, it is objects and
culture.
This DIY and hack it culture.
You may have megaspaces around
you.  If there are none in your
city, then you should start a
megaspace.  The great thing
about the megaculture is that
you learn through doing with
your hands.
You make mistakes, so what!  It
doesn't matter.
It is a good way to learn, try
new things, learn from each
other.  Figure out new
applications that you can create
with that technology.
It doesn't matter what your
background is.
In fact, it is better when you
can mix and match different
domains to find new
applications, other technology.
Let's take a look at what has
happened in the past few years.
You now have macrocontrollers,-
microcontrollers like ras  berry
pie.
-- Raspberry pie.
And did you know that costs has
decreased for lithium batteries.
And the Cloud and Artificial
Intelligence.  All of this
sounds complicated.
It doesn't have to be.  This is
with AIY.  Do-it-yourself
Artificial Intelligence that we
introduced last year, you can
have fun.  The idea of this
megaculture is before anything
else, to have fun.
Using in this case, Artificial
Intelligence.
We want to put AI in your hands
so you can solve real problems.
The AIY kits are open source,
have hardware and software and
integrate directly on the device
themselves.  The essence, as I
mentioned previously, is to keep
it low cost, using readily
available components you
can find almost anywhere on the
planet.
The kits are able to assemble.
Dushyantsinh how long does it
take to assemble?
>> DUSHYANTSINH JADEJA: 15 to 20
minutes.
>> SEBASTIAN TRZCINSKI-CLEMENT:
I will say not more than an hour
to assemble a kit.
Dushyantsinh and Bill will demo
the kits.
So stay with us, the voice and
vision kit.  Stay with us, in
the coming months
there will be more to announce
in that space.
Let's take a look -- I will
finish up with this -- at what
some of you have created.
I will show you in a few
seconds, a 16-year-old with no
programming experience has come
up with the following use case.
Play the video for about 20
seconds.
>> Shop for New York Yankee
baseball hats.  What is actually
happening now?
>> Done.
>> She said done?
>> Yeah. What happened is when
it said done, it sent links to
my e-mail after finding it on
eBay.  It will find results
online, send links in an e-mail
to me, I will receive
those so I can quickly click and
buy something.
>> SEBASTIAN TRZCINSKI-CLEMENT:
What happened here with Lawrence
and the high school kid was
shopping for a product.
I don't know if you heard that
at the beginning.  I'm shopping
for baseball caps.
Searching on eBay and e-mailed
when the device was done.  Let
me take you through the code.
Just a few lines of code.
Not a hundred or thousand lines
of code.  Just 20 or 30 lines.
I want to show you, even if you
are not an experienced
programmer, you can learn from
that.
I will keep it simple.  The
first line you can see here is
this action triggered when the
user presses the button on top
of the device.  Let's examine
what happens next.  We take the
words, store them in the local
variable at the keyword at the
bottom.  What happens next?
Import a range of libraries.
You can be like me, you don't
have to understand the
libraries, copy, paste
it, it works, you try to
understand afterward what
library does what.  It is by
learning about example.
When I said learning by doing,
this is what I mean.  Copy and
paste the libraries you need,
the few lines here.
After, that we will call the
eBay API this is the line in the
middle.  With that line, we get
results back from eBay.
We will read the results as you
see on the bottom.
Finally, what we do, you may
remember in the video, all the
results are sent to the e-mail.
Here's the code.  We will go
through the result, the first
three lines of code up there,
format all of this in an e-mail.
You can recognize, even if you
are not an experienced
programmer, from, to, subject
line.
That's it.  Nothing more.  The
last thing we do is connect to
the
server, the e-mail server and
send the
e-mail and get the device to say
"done."
That's it, nothing more.
You can literally copy and paste
that code.  It will work.
It is your turn to do things
with AIY.
If you are not inspired enough,
I have Dushyantsinh now to come
on stage and do a demo with the
voice kit.  Thank you for
listening.
Welcome, Dushyantsinh, back on
stage.
(Applause) .
>> DUSHYANTSINH JADEJA: Thank
you, Sebastian.
My name is Dushyantsinh Jadeja
development team at Google.
Like everybody, we all are
excited about
the possibility of AI in front
of us, correct?
This only becomes more
meaningful and
more impactful when all of us
have access to this wonderful
platform.
At Google, we have been sharing
our work and advancement in the
field of Artificial Intelligence
by building products, sharing
through research
papers and now with the AIY
kits, we are taking to even more
people in a more playful way.
Yet, it is strong enough for you
to solve some really good
problems.
Let's see how we can kind of
solve some of those things.
When we're thinking about this
kit together, we are thinking,
you know, what makes sense?
What would be a right way of
putting this in front of people
woman and of course, voice was
one of the things that was very
evident.
Correct, we all like talking?
Imagine, we have a power of
playing
around with the voice, how fun
it would be.
It was mentioned in the keynote
yesterday, the wave net.  You
can create different voices.
So in this demo, I'm just going
to talk
about the capabilities of
AIY kit, and Google Assistant,
but of course, there is much
more than this.
Voice kit was launched sometime
last year, I believe.
It got a lot of attention.
The voice kit has a combination
of few software and some of the
hardware there.
It was marketed along with the
(?
) Foundation to see what are the
feedback we can get from the
existing community and try to
improve our offering.
We launch the second version of
voice
kit in January, to get and
incorporate
the feedbacks and make it all in
one box component kit.  This is
what you get today, if you go to
AIY website and look at voice
kit,
this is what you will probably
find there.  But what does the
kit contain?
From a hardware point of view,
it has,
you know, ras Perry pie --
Raspberry pie zero.
And the processing for you.
The voice bonnet, it has a mic,
microcontroller, general input,
output, and to basically give
you visual indication of what is
happening with
your voice kit at any point in
time.
And from a software point of
view, it
basically runs
on ras bianilinebianiline --
razz Berrian Linux.
This is just scratching the
surface of the voice kit.
How to get started.  Step one,
in terms of assembling the kit.
Step two, setting up the device.
Step three, now you set up
everything,
you can build some solution by
yourself.
So if you open the kit, this is
what is looks like.
First thing, ensure you have all
the
right components, you have
cardboard, all the different
hardwares mentioned on the
website, just verify that you
have all of the components ready
with you before you start
assembling together.  Once you
verify, the next step for you
to do is build an engine, think
of it as building a car.
Building an engine, putting
Raspberry pie and the engine
together.
Now you are building the
chassis.
You know, a structure for your
car or for the voice kit.
You take it, cardboard and give
it a structure of a speaker.
Once you build the cardboard,
you put the engine inside it.
You put the Raspberry pie, voice
bonnet in it.  That's it.
Super easy, super fun.  For me,
when I tried first time, it
somewhere around 15 to 20
minutes, I'm sure you are much,
much advanced than me and you
can probably do it even faster.
The key is not fast, but do it
in a nice, fun way out of it.
Yeah, that's it.
You can assemble your voice
kit.
Step two, set up your device.
Now I have the device, the voice
kit is in a nice shape and form,
let me give a voice to it.  See
if it is working fine.  I have
an already built voice kit here.
I will switch back to my voice
kit and see if everything is
working fine there.
Can we switch to demo?
Give it a second.  Should be ...
yes?  Oh, ... sorry for the
glitch.
I think I am booting up my
machine here.
Yes.  And it's live.  So before
you start, you want to kind of
know -- ensure that you have
everything running for you.  So
things like let's say you are
connected to network.  This
could be either a wired network
or wireless network or tething
to your phone.  To have a
connection.
Voice kit needs to be connected
to Internet.
It is using the Google Assistant
and
speech API for recognition
purpose.
So let's see if my -- sorry.
This is my Wi-Fi, but I'm not
using Wi-Fi.
Let me see if I am online.
And ...
Good, it looks like I'm all set
from an Internet point of view.
I will see if the speakers, if
the audio is working fine.
The kit audio is working fine.
>> Front, center.
>> SEBASTIAN TRZCINSKI-CLEMENT:
Seems okay.
I will see if it rec --
>> DUSHYANTSINH JADEJA: Let me
see if it recognizes my voice.
Testing, one, two, three.
>> Testing, one, two, three.
>> DUSHYANTSINH JADEJA: Seems to
be okay.
I am almost set.  The good
thing, voice kit comes with some
of the prebuilt demos as well.
It is good to kind of know --
see if those are also working
fine before you kind of start
building yourself.
So if you go to the Pi directory
and look at voice examples.
Which is
here and I'm just going to try
this
library
demo.
Ok Google, what's time right
now?  Okay?
Okay.  Let me try one more time.
Or let me try
with this one.
Hey Google, what's time right
now?
>> SEBASTIAN TRZCINSKI-CLEMENT:
Just a bit shy.
>> DUSHYANTSINH JADEJA: Okay.
We'll try one more time,
otherwise, I'll
walk you through what it does at
this point in time.
Whenever I say something --
okay.
Hey Google, what's the time
right now?
>>
>> Google: It's 1:50.
>> DUSHYANTSINH JADEJA: Thank
you.  So you can try bunch of
things.  What I was doing, I was
just testing if it things are
working fine.
Now, of course, at this point in
time, you can ask a bunch of
other questions, like, you know,
hey Google, what's the distance
to moon?
Okay.  But at this point in
time, what it would have done is
it would have you know, looked
at some of the services
available online, try to FEFRN
an answer for you and display to
you.
-- fetch an answer for you and
display to you.  Things are
seeming to be okay.
Let me see if it could -- if it
can build something.
I will go back to presentation.
Can we go back to slides?
Yeah, the device -- it is always
good
to see if -- if device is
working fine, before you kind of
start building by yourself.
I have built a typical shopping
experience.  Hopefully it should
work fine.  But let's see.
Given my setup was not optimal.
But let's give it one more shot.
Can we switch to demo?
The Google was showing mostly
about,
you giving a come up to Google
Assistant saying shop for
something.  It was trying to
identify a text,
calling the API from eBay, I
believe,
and search the result and send
it as an e-mail.  I tried to
mimic similar behavior.
And let's see if I can -- if
demo gods are with me ...
I will ask for maybe shop
something.  Mother's Day is
coming up, I won't be in town, I
want to send something to my
mom.  I was thinking what is an
interesting thing?  The
smartwatch is a big thing.  I
thought maybe I will give her a
smartwatch.  Let's see if I can
find a smartwatch using my voice
kit.
Hey Google, shop for smartwatch.
Cool.
>> Google: Done.
.
>> DUSHYANTSINH JADEJA: If you
look at what it did, it
recognized my voice or
my command and kind of connected
to the particular service and
displayed some of
the smartwatches available for
me to purchase.  At this point
in time, I could take this
output, send an e-mail like what
Sebastian was mentioned or if I
have a smart display device, I
could basically,
you know, post it there or give
a nice visual, list, okay, these
are some of
the things or engage it more in
relation
to
that.  Can we move back to
slides?
I was trying to emphasize, there
is a lot of things possible with
the voice, that you can play
around with it.
You can also not just look at
the software as a one side of
it, but also experiment with
some of the things on the
hardware.
Let's say, we have seen people
now
taking old toys and putting the
voice
kits or other AI kits and revive
the bodies or bring life to the
toys.
We have seen people
customize voice kits, there are
people
gimmicks, giving voice to a
rumba vacuum.  Tell them don't
go to this side of the house,
but go to different house
section.
Or can completely custom voice
actions.  Tons of things are
possible.  If you want to know
more about what is
there, you can follow us on
Instagram or
Twitter or follow the discussion
on reddit.
With that, I will invite Bill to
know more about what is
happening on vision kit.
(Applause) .
>> Bill: Thank you.
I will continue on with the
second part, that is the vision
kit.
The vision kit is a new product.
It is being released end of last
year, we had a new version
update the first quarter of this
year.
The latest version is 1.1.  It
launches in December of last
year.
It has the latest Raspberry Pi
0.  And it is on the board.
It doesn't have the early
version to solve yourself.  It
is much easier.
It comes with the Raspberry Pi
version 2
and the Google made visson
bonnet.
That is where it is all put in
the product.
Most of the unique things of the
particular product, it doesn't
require you to connect to
Internet.  You can work with the
vision recognition software in
the box by itself alone.  Before
we start, go through the list
of materials that Dushyantsinh
did with the voice kit.  Similar
thing.
It has the Raspberry Pi zero.
And Google has this vision
bonnet, it
contains the Intel vision
recognition processor, which has
the power to help you do the
vision recognition.
In addition to that, the camera
support
and the connections to the
Raspberry Pi cable connector,
and has the general
purpose input, output, GPIO
connector to allow you to do
more things, which I will cover
shortly.
And also, it has the cryptochip
to help you encrypt and add more
securities in it terms of the
application.
There on -- it also has the
button and
the cardboard form to allow you
to fold the device.
On the software side, the
operating
system the same, it runs on the
Linux ras bian system.
It includes the flow, with the
inception, and mobile net
software.
It is on the device which allow
you to
build AI models to work with the
device to do applications in AI.
It has the built in software for
facial recognition and the
general object recognition.
All of the software is on the
device ready to use.
And in terms of its component,
let me
get into more detail, because
this is a relatively new
product.  On the hardware level,
at the bottom,
the Raspberry Pi zero.
As I said, it has the built in
Wi-Fi and Bluetooth support.
So you can connect to the
Internet if
you want, without a cable, with
Wi-Fi connection to the
Internet.
It has GPIO connection which
allows it
to
connect directly with the flex
cable to
the Google vision bonnet vision
bowl.
That connects to the camera and
the accessories like L.E.D.
and push button and the buzzer.
There is a piece of buzzer on
the device that as your
application necessary you can
have it generate sound.
On the software side, it runs on
the
same ras bian Linux system.
It has the Python interpreter on
top of that.
In Google, the software we put
together contain three different
modules, if you will, in terms
of the vision process.
The first is the TensorFlow
module,
that does the inception and then
the
software and then the object
recognition software.  With the
software and hardware, you
have the application interface
with the components.  This is
how everything put together.
Okay?
Then let me go through the same
process Dushyantsinh mentioned
with the voice kit.
First you assemble it.  In terms
of assembly, very similar.
You have the box, it has parts,
cardboard, whatever.  As you can
see on the screen, in terms
of processprocess building, it
is easy.
You hook up the Raspberry Pi,
with the vision cable, hook them
together, stick
them together, fold the
cardboard box.
Almost like in the engine in a
car, hook up the button, this is
it.
First time I build, 40-something
minutes.  Second time, only 20
minutes.  Very simple.  I have a
product for myself.  I made a
video tutorial for how to
assemble it on YouTube.  For
those that don't want to read
the instruction, you can watch
the video.  But it is very
simple, very easy.  Okay?
So to assemble that, you can
have in less than an hour build
a device like that.
Okay.
In terms of setup, this is very
simple.  As I said, this does
not necessarily need to hook up
to Internet.  So the connection
is all you need is a power
supply.  Have a power supply
connect to it, and you are ready
to go.
And because of the facial
recognition software built into
the device, after
you power it up, it will
automatically
run the facial detection
software.  Right now, on the
desk, I have this vision bonnet
with me.
And as you can see, the top
L.E.D.
blue light, the button is
lighted up.
If I point this to my face, as
you can see, the blue light
indicating the camera is
capturing my face.
If I show to the camera with a
smiley face, the happy face, the
light color of the L.E.D.
will change to yellow.
And if I am showing a frowning
face, it will go back to blue.
Let me demonstrate this.
Can everybody see?  It changes
the color.  Let me say.  This is
not some kind of magic.  It is
AI and working.
What happen, it is a software
inside
with the AI TensorFlow model
with the facial recognition that
I will get to in
a minute, to make a facial
recognition software just like
that.  It doesn't have much of a
set up.  Just power it on, hook
up the power, you can do the
facial recognition.  This demo
is called joy detection.
It is part of a project thatthat
-- part of a product we ship
with the device.
Set up is easy, how to make your
own solutions.  There is a lot
of software you can do.  Let me
do another demo.  Please switch
the screen to the output of my
other device.  Do we have
output?
We lost the signal.  Don't power
down.
I'm plugged in if.
All right.  I apologize for the
connection glitch.
As you can see now, I am running
the Raspbian software system, it
is a window showing the
software.  Let me, by starting a
simple demo,
which is
the object classification.  What
you can see is the right-hand
side, the camera, video image
coming captured by the camera.
And on the table, I have the
apple, banana and Coke can.
Random object I put together.
You can see on the left side of
the screen, the output stream
out, starting put on the screen,
which is by the object
classification software that we
put on the device.
I'm going to explain all of that
in a minute.  First let me do a
demo.  I will point this to
banana.
You should see on the left-hand
of the
screen, it will say -- it detect
this object, a banana, I hope.
Right?
Now, if I point this to apple,
not
only it will recognize it's an
apple, in
fact, it should say granny
Smith, it
actually recognize the type of
the apple.  And I tried it
earlier.
I point it toward the Coca-Cola
can.
If it is a punching bag, it is
red color.
It looks like this.  Let me stop
the application, make this
window bigger.
And as you can see on the left
side, the first number, it is
object recognize, it says
banana.
The number after that is the
confidence score.
How confident the AI think this
is
banana or similarly an apple,
which is granny Smith apple.
This confidence level tells you
the recognition part, it is
truly the object it detects.
These numbers, this feedback
from the software, you can use
to make a lot of applications.
Okay?
Let's switch back to the slides.
So this image on the screen, you
can see very similar.
It recognized the object along
with a confidence score.  You
can use this number to help you
design your applications.
So exactly what can you do with
a vision kit?  Number one, you
can see it already does the
object detection.
And it has the facial detection,
it is all software built into
it.
So through API you can leverage
these.
It takes photo, and send the
output.
It has the ability to tell
difference
between apple, banana and bunch
of other stuff.  Most
importantly, as demonstrate, you
can run your own AI machine
learning software in this
device, by building
your own customized TensorFlow
model.  Some may think, how do I
do that?  It is a bit of
confusion with the TensorFlow
model, powerful stuff, how do
you do that?
Let me introduce to you the
process of how do you do your
customized model.  First of all,
the first, number one, every
machine learning model you build
in TensorFlow, you are building
a model to train.
Specify and train your own model
is the first step.  The second,
just like any other TensorFlow
model, you get the end
results, you do an export model
to a
so-called GrecianGrecian --
frozen graph.
There is there own format.
That is not understood by the
vision bonnet hardware.  Okay?
So somehow we need to make a
match.
That next step is the so-called
compiler.
Google provide this Google model
You take the frozen graph,
binary code
run it through the compartment
you generate called your own
customized computer graph.
The artifact is the end result
is going through the three steps
you have a binary file.
That file defines your machine
learning model.
On the hardware side we have
Raspberry Pi and vision bonnet,
there is the
vision program, you use the API,
send the graph to the vision
bonnet, next step, write code,
you can look at our tutorials
and example models, coding a
model function, basically, send
this computer graph into the
vision bonnet.  In this case,
the computer graph and vision
bonnet match, they understood
what is going on.
Then you have a camera coming in
the stream of the inputs.
The inputs are coming as a
binary number.  Because of the
computer graph, we
arrange these inputs into
whatever the machine learning
test is.
Which is basically a bunch of
multidimensional arrays.
So next step is you need to
match this
tensor, a bunch of arrays, to
the image with your model.
This is what we call the
computing.  Basically, the step
is you are writing
a program, you have this vision
bonnet
hardware and it does the
calculation and will send the
signal to the output.
Here's the code.
How do you define your face
object, as you can see?  The
face object is defined with the
bonnet box, the score.
You write the argument code.
You send it as a structure and
say, in my model, I need this
four.  This four number matches
the machine.  And finding the
application code, you say let me
get results from this tensor,
where is the score, the face
score, whatever, you take that
to your end result.
You can make a decision, you can
say the score is based on some
number, above some number,
change my color light.
This is exactly what you do, in
terms of
using your own model with the
vision kit.
All right.
So with that, talk about
extending your project.  We talk
about software, how about
hardware?
On the AIY board, there is the
area, with the additional pings.
With the pings you can control
output,
turn on lights, turn on fans,
something is making noise,
whatever you can do.  With these
things you can expand your
project and with the controller
on board, you can do those
things.
So hardwarehardware-wise, we can
do those things.
We go through these, talk about
how to assemble, set up and do
your own things.  Most
importantly, I want to say to
use AIY, the power really is
connected to many of the
services Google provide,
like Google Assistant,
TensorFlow, leverage the power
of the service behind you.
AIY, part of global open source
community.
We publish this, Github,
Raspberry Pi,
work with others, immerse
yourself with online communities
around the world.  This is part
of the fun of the building
makers.  I want to take this
opportunity to tell everybody,
the audience, those of you from
the U.S., you can join a contest
going on right now.
Organized by texter with the
administration of China, the
young U.S. China makers contest.
The winners get an all-expense
paid trip to China.  Those of
you in the room, you are
American makers, please join
this contest.
And more details on hackster
website.
All right.  The key take away
from our talk today with
Sebastian, Dushyantsinh
mentioned in their part of the
talk and mine.
Key take away is
resource-wise, it is this
address.  The kits can be
purchased at target store in the
U.S.
And also, next weekend, in the
Bay Area, there is a makers
fair.  Those of you in the area,
join in the makers fair, you can
get the kits from the makers
fair.
Learning, using Raspberry Pi and
Python programming is part of
the thing you need to get
yourself involved to expand your
applications.
And using TensorFlow learning
model to learn the power of AI
into the application.  That is
the power of AIY.
Finally, to summary -- I will
say call to action, things you
can do.  Everyone can do.
Get a kit and start building,
having fun, of course.
And learning many Google
services.
At Google I/O, we have sessions
on
Google Cloud, Google Assistant,
and TensorFlow, learn those
knowledge and skills.
Get different sensors, controls,
hook up to the ports on the
devices.  You can build a lot of
applications,
in the leverage of the AI
capabilities.
Lastly, joining online
communities.
We will develop a global
exchange, and put your device on
that, so with that, along with
Sebastian and Dushyantsinh, we
want to thank you for coming,
joining
our session today, start your
AIY journey today.
Thank you very much.
(Applause) (Session concluded)
.
>> Thank you for joining this
session, brand ambassadors will
assist with
directing you through the
designated exits.
We'll be making room for those
that registered for the next
session.
If you registered for this
section in
this room -- for the next
session in this room, we ask
that you exit and return to the
lines outside.  Thank you.
.
Android Jetpack.  What's new in
Android Support Library.
>> Good afternoon, everyone.
Thank you for joining us at
Android I/O.
You are looking at what's new in
the Android library.  If you
were looking for sandwiches, you
didn't go far enough.  And
everyone is still here.
I'm Alan Viverette.
>> AURIMAS LIUTIKAS: I'm
AurimasAurimas.
>> KATHY KAM: And I'm Kathy Kam.
>> ALAN VIVERETTE: We'll talk
about what you can look forward
to in the future.  On this
beautiful day, we will talk
about spring cleaning and talk
about technical debt building up
in the Support Library.
We're on Twitter, stock
overflow, on reddit, maybe on
reddit a little too much.  We
noticed basic aspects of the
Support Library that were a
little bit messy.  So we reached
out, spoken with developers,
tried to find out ways to
improve the basics of Support
Library and lay a strong
foundation for future work.  We
got a lot of good feedback.
Some high level, some very
specific, we know about the
issues with the
showing and hiding the I, me.
We drilled down to the basics.
We have got feedback on the
maven packaging.  The artifact
package names.  The Java
packages have become confusing
as Support Library has aged.
In general, we built up a lot of
technical debt.  So like last
year, we will talk about what is
old in the Android Support
Library first.
We 20ed on 2011 with -- started
in 2011 with support before.
We provided backward support for
SD4, the first version.
We grew.
We had watch components, car
components, testing, for SDK13,
4, 11.
We have a lot more than just
backwards compatibility now.
But we still got the artifact
names.  So we have support V4.
Everyone is familiar with that
V13.
Who knows what is in support
V13?  Literally less than 10
people.  Aurimas knows.
So support V13 at this moment
contains nothing.
Because the minimum SDK for
everything is 14.  It redirects
to V4 and that redirects to
other components.  These are
umbrella artifacts on maven.
Why do we have all the weird
versioning names in the maven
artifacts and package names?
They're kind of hard to change,
but these are confusing.  It is
not a great place to start if
you are new to Android
development.  We also have a lot
of versions of all of the
libraries.
Recommendation is something that
was
added in 2003 and hasn't
changed.
We have 30 versions of the
basically exact same library.
What does the versioning scheme
mean here?
Well, 24, means it was released
when SDK 24 came out.
We had an Alpha one
corresponding with the first
public release.
Alpha 2, beta 1, DP3.
It doesn't make sense to
correspond to just the I/O
releases.  Wouldn't it be great
to have Alpha and
beta releases for each and
wouldn't it be great to not have
to do that for
every library, even if it didn't
change?
You may have seen a 24.00, that
didn't have beta testing.  Maybe
you found bugs that should have
been in Alpha.  We have been
better with testing,
wouldn't it be great if the
dot-zero releases wouldn't still
Alpha quality?
Today we will focus on fixing
how we structure our libraries,
how we handle changes to them,
and how we shift them to
developers.  We use this to form
the foundation for
Jetpack, and we're calling it
Android
extension libraries, or Android
X for short.
Welcome to what's new in
AndroidX, we'll talk about
foundational changes, new
features, what to expect from us
in the future.
First, I would like to talk
about the relationship between
Jetpack, which everyone may
remember from the keynote and
AndroidX.
So Jetpack is a set of guidance,
recommended libraries, tools and
this is going to teach you how
to create good apps.  This may
include libraries that are in
AndroidX.
This may eventually include
libraries not in AndroidX.  As
guidance changes and evolves you
may see some things in AndroidX
are deprecated and no longer
part of the Jetpack
recommendations.  Also it has
this cute logo.
AndroidX on the other hand is
the libraries themselves.
These are guaranties about
versioning, API, dependency
structure, we do not have a cute
logo.  Let's dive into details.
What is going to be changing?
We'll have logical, smaller,
more scoped artifacts.  If you
are looking for view pager, it
will be in the view pager
artifact rather than support V4.
You may remember the split last
year, where we split to core UI
and a number of other artifacts.
We have done that again this
year, we have smaller artifacts,
if you need view pager, just
pull in view pager, not a bunch
of other widgets you may not
need.
This is nonbreaking, like the
split we did last year.
If you pull in support VV4, you
get the core view libraries, and
UI, you get everything else.
But you have the option of
pulling in just exactly what you
need.
Here's a split of the libraries.
This is just a sample.
You see that support compat is
broken down into selections.
This is a pure Java library.
This is a jar instead of AAR.
No resources, you can use it
with host tests.  Because it
doesn't have any dependencies on
the Android package.
Core is the backwards
compatibility that you are used
to from support V4.  You will
see less of the compat
moniker in the future, as
AndroidX is becoming the primary
development surface for a lot of
framework API.
So here you can see, if you need
swipe
refresh layout, you pull in
exactly that, you don't get
anything you didn't need.
We also move to versioning that
makes more sense.
Instead of monolithic releases
tied to
Google I/O, we will reset from
28 to 1.0.  And the major
version number now actually
means something.
So previously, we would break
binary compatibility on any
minor version bump.  If you are
using a library that depends on
a specific version of Support
Library, this can be really
problematic.  You may not find
out until run time that some
method signature that a
library depends on has changed
or move
to strict semantic versioning,
means you can expect the version
number to indicate binary
compatibility.
Anything in a 1.4 version of the
library -- anything with the 1.4
dependency on a library, for
example,
would be compatible to 1.
5 up to 2.0.
Instead of monolithic release,
if we
have a bug fix for recycler.
You only pull in one new
artifact, and if you don't need
it you don't have to pull it in.
It will be low effort on the
part of the developer.
All right.  We want to make it
easy to know what is inside each
artifact.
As I mention, the maven
artifacts are
finer scoped, correspond to
features, rather than broad
swaths of -- for
example, all of support V4.
We have consistent scheme of
AndroidX feature, package and
class according to layer and
functionality.
The maven naming scheme reflects
this.
Group I.D.
is the corresponding to the Java
package.
If there is a subfeature, for
example, recycler view
selection.
There is the recycler view,
colon, recycler view, dash,
selection.
We moved all the V7, V4 explicit
backwards compatible or
explicit combile SDK compiles.
And we make the heavy use of the
requires API annotation.  There
may be a return new object.  May
see something that returns
compat and something with the
actual object and you can recall
that if you are on a newer
platform.
All right.  So let's dive into
an example of that.
Here's an example of some
libraries that you may already
be using.
Unifying UFRG on the AndroidX
top level package.  Everything
that is under that support
is in the droid extension
library.
Everything is that is in
support, is in the Android
extension library.
Android afternoon persistence
room is just room.  When you are
looking for room, you can find
it quickly.
Dig down on support compat and
cardboard specifically.
Build compat is moved from an
explicit V4 support to Android
core OS build compat.
In the future you will see less
of the compat suffix on classes.
Card V7 is card viewed widget,
you will see other supporting
classes in card view dot utill,
expect.  So hopefully this isn't
too shocking.
I think this is a very long
awaited refactoring we have been
wanting to do for a long time.
You might wonder, how do we get
that?  We will hand over to
Aurimas, he'll walk you through
what it looks like to migrate
your application.
>> AURIMAS LIUTIKAS: Hello
there.  Thanks, Alan.  I will
walk you through the migration
story and how to get to the
AndroidX library usage.
First things first, if you are
using Android Studio, we will
provide an automated tool for
migrating over.
This tool is available starting
with 3.2, canary 14 that shipped
yesterday.
The automated tool -- well ...
this automated tool will be in
the
existing refactory menu that you
probably, hopefully love, what
we added is a new option called
refactored to AndroidX.
This single click will go and
identify all the usages of
Android Support Library, old
classes and pull them up in
the review pane, where you can
see what has changed, what we're
about to migrate for you.
After review, you click do
refactor and we will refactor.
What this will handle, it will
handle
your source code, encoding the
classes, handle simple build
scripts, unless you have
something more complex, in which
case we will publish maps of old
artifact to the new artifact,
you can do migration in a more
manual way.  Migration will
handle resources such as layout
files.
And finally, but not least, what
you
will have is we will handle
migration of
binary dependances, AR and JARs.
Many of you use third party
libraries that department on
support, glide and many other
libraries.  To help you with
that, we wrote a tool called
jetifier.
This tool performs binary
translation using ASM, which
jumps into the jar,
goes and rewrites the uses of
the old Support Library to
become the new Support Library.
This handles code inside of the
jar,
it handles XML and proprogard
files and
we will publish a stand alone
jar to run manually, if you
would like checked in versions
of the prebuilds that you depend
on.  Now let's jump to the
laptop, where I will give you a
demo of how this tool works.
Hopefully the demo works
beautifully.
Here we go.  Jump to the laptop.
Right.
Here, you're looking at Topeka
Android app.
It is available on the Google
samples Github page.  Nothing
super amazing, it is using
standard components and showing
examples of how it works.  I am
running this app.
It works, you can click on
things.  Now, what we will do,
we will jump
into the refactory menu, hit the
refactor to AndroidX.
What it will do is jump in and
find
uses of the old support classes
and all the other places we
migrate.  After it is done
searching, it will present all
the things that it will suggest
for you to migrate.  In this
case, I am looking at the
specific sign-in fragment class,
you can see uses of Support
Library.  What will happen when
I do refactor.
It will rewrite all of these,
including build script files,
everything.
Of course, Gradle will need to
sync again because we have the
dependences
and the clasp apps will be
loaded.
Twiddle your things, wait for
studio notes to do its thing.
Now we have new stuff.  When I
hit build and install, hopefully
in a few seconds, at home you
would grab a coffee, here we
can't do that on the stage, it
will install it on the emulator.
It will install later by saying
other words.  Ta-da!
Now you see this is the same
app,
usationion -- using a brand-new
AndroidX library.
And the migration was fairly
painless.  Let's jump back to
the slides.
(Applause) .
All right, some of you are not
usingusing Android Studio.
For those we will provide a
giant file for the mapping from
the old class to the new class.
That with the jetifier tool, you
should be able to hook up in the
build
system and IDE to do the
migration manually if you are
using studio.  In summary, we're
providing the tools
in Android Studio 3.2, canary
14, and jetifier is already in
Google maven.
However, this is coming in
really hot.  Even the demo that
I was using is actually not
using canary 14, it is using
canary 15, shipping next week,
because we found bugs when
trying to do the demo.  So
please wait until canary 15 to
start using this.  But when you
do, in canary 15, please
take a look at it, try to
migrate your projects.  If you
find issues, file bugs.  We want
to make this as easy as possible
and want you to migrate and
start using all the new stuff.
However, you know migration
takes time.
We will still ship Android
Support Library 28.0, alongside
AndroidX.
However, note, this is the last
feature release.  This is kind
of like a little bit of a
time line for you to kind of
move forward.
If you want to know more about
how this works behind the scenes
inside of Android Studio, there
will be a talk
about Android build system at
6:30 in this room.  Hopefully
you can take a look at that.
So it is not all about
refactoring, we added new
features.  I will talk you --
walk you through some of these.
The first feature I want to talk
about is the ricycler view
selection.  This is a library
that will allow you to handle
item selection easier.
It will help you handle motion
and touch events and convert
them into selection in the
recycler view.  This is a
flexible library where it allows
for custom layout managers and
custom actions to do.  Let's
jump through and see how you use
it.
As you can imagine, you have new
dependency to the build dot
Gradle file.  The important
thing is we are using the
AndroidX artifact.
This is the same stuff that Alan
was talking about.  So for the
set up, what you need to
do, you want to create a new
layout and new adaptor.
The adaptor, important thing is
use stable I.D.
We are using a stock grid layout
manager.
We set both of these are on the
recycler view.  No selection
code yet, we're doing the basic
recycler set up.
The adaptor, as I said, nothing
super exciting.
The important thing is doing
stable I.D.
This allows consistent mapping
from the I.D. to the item.
Next, when we jump back to the
activity,
we set up selections library key
provider.  This, in conjunction
with the stable I.D., will allow
for a quick mapping between the
I.D. and the items that will
handle the selection by the
selection library.  And now,
what we need to set up is the
selection tracker, which
actually is the actual machinery
behind the scenes.
And we pass in recycler view,
the key provider, both of these
we created and my details look
up.
This my details look up is a
simple class.  Override one
method.
On the side of that one, you
return item details.  That
returns the position and the
selection key for the item that
is for the given motion event.
Finally, recycler view has no
default selection mechanism.
What you have to do is handle it
on bind.
There you might want to change
the background of the view or
use it by setting activated
state.  To get activated state
working, you use background for
the view.  And the background is
a selectable drawable that has
activated state, which will
allow to indicate to user that
the item has been selected.  So
this is the basics.  This
library has a lot more.
You can set up band selection,
you can add custom selection
areas.
You can have items that are not
square.
You can have circular handling,
stuff like that.
There is a lot you can do with
this library.  The important
part of this slide, that is my
dog Jack.
All right.  Another thing we
added to recycler view is list
adapter.  What this does for you
is helps you to work the
recycler views that change the
content over time.  What you
need to do, all you need to do
is submit the new list.
We run the dif utill tools in
the background and run the
animation based on how the list
is changed.
This is handled simply via VI.
I will walk you through.
You have the dif call back.
It has to implement two methods.
First, make sure the items are
the same where you compare the
item I.D.
On the second one, check that
the content is the same, where
you do a deeper comparison.
Essentially equals in Java.
And in there, if there is a
change, we'll know how to
process your item from one to
the next.  And then the adapter,
what you need to do is call get
item, and you do your regular
binding.
And that is all you need to do
to get the animation working.
And then, a highly complex code
in the activity.  Call submit
list.  The list.  That is it,
you are done.  Note, this works
really well, the live
data and RX Java observables.
So if you need to do slightly
more
advanced dapter, we have a base
adapter called list adapter.  Go
into that.  If you want to know
about list dapter and similar
utilities, see managing
lists, the recycler page talk on
Thursday at 2:30.
Another thing we added is
AndroidX web kit library.
What it allows you to do is get
the API that we added in web
view on the older versions in
the backwards compatible way.
This library works on API and
newer.
Take an example of safe
browsing, that we added this API
27.
This prevents loading of
malicious URL in the web view.
Previously could only use it on
API 27 and newer.  Now you can
use it on older devices.
So similarly, we will add a
Gradle dependency to get it
working.  Again, looking at
AndroidX artifacts.  Hopefully
you got this by now.  Then we
will check if the feature is
available.
If it is, we will start safe
browsing.  As simple as that.
You get the experience of safe
browsing.
Similarly, many other APIs we
have added
will become backwards applicable
available to the application.
You will hopefully check this
out.
Another library we real estate
-- renamed is custom tabs.  This
will work with browsers that
implement this, Chrome, Firefox,
Samsung, all of them use this.
If you use it, it will continue
to work.
The cool thing, we added a
feature
inside of the library, called
browser actions.  It allows you
to hook into the context menu of
the browser.
For example, now your reddit app
can
finally open links in a cog
nitto tab, which can be handy.
It works in Chrome with 66 and
other browsers when they adopt
it.  To use this, it is fairly
simple.
You set up intents.
Pending intents for browser
action items.  This is optional,
if you don't need
extra ones in the dig --
dialogue, you can skip this
part.  Another option to set up
is browser action tracking.  So
what this allows you to do is
see what user ended up selecting
inside of the dialogue.
And finally, you just fire up
the browser action dialogue.
And you end up with something
like this.
And you can do, you know,
additional actions for yourself,
or hook into the
browser, whereas previously, you
weren't able to do this via
simple attempts
because the
browsers weren't interested in
the functionality.
This is HEIF writers.
We introduced this in Android P.
We are launching this
library.  It is allowing the
writing to the file.  It is not
super useful, but we're working
on a back port to allow you to
use it on older versions.
Again, usage is simple.
Fire up the builder to create a
new HEIF writer.
You can set up options, image
size,
quality, hit built, and once you
have it, write into it.  You put
in bit maps, you write it out to
disk.  You call stop, the
time-out can be 0, if you want
an indefinite wait.  The
important part here is you want
to
do this work off the UI frame
because you do a disk.  To tell
you more about other features in
AndroidX, I invite Kathy.
Thanks.
(Applause) .
>> KATHY KAM: Thanks, Aurimas.
So the next feature I want to
talk about
that we added in AndroidX is
slices.
Slices is a feature to allow you
to display content outside of
the app.
The goal here is to have one
reuse able API that the system
and other apps can request
content from your app.
Today, we have already
integrated a search.
I will look in integration with
--
even home screen in the future.
This content is templated and
interactive.  It is templated so
when you have kind
of live content, you can display
it in a rich and flexible
layout.  The content is
interactive, because we
allow you to add existing
controls like
sliders, toggles, scroll viewer.
And you can have live data or
deep
links into your app.
You can choose to integrate your
slices with search.
So a user can see -- display app
content by searching the app
name or even general terms that
you register.  This is a win-win
for users and the
apps because users can get rich
live data immediately.
And for your app to reach
millions of users.  Because it
is implemented in AndroidX,
it is usable immediately up to
API 19.  Let's look at how you
can use it.
So as you would expect, we have
to first import the libraries.
Three libraries to import.  Here
we import from AndroidX.  The
first is the slice builders,
includes methods to build
content in a templated format.
The next library is the slice
view.
This contents methods to present
the content.
The last library to import is
slices core, that contains
methods for permissions.  To
build a slice, define a slice,
implement the slice, handle the
slice action.  Let's look at how
we can do it.
The first thing to do is let the
plot system or other apps know
you have slices to provide.
You do that by implementing your
slice provider.
You register your slice provider
in
the Android dot manifest file.
Next, extend from the slice
provider and implement your
slice provider.
You can have multiple slices for
your app.  This is where the
business logic happens.
When a platform or other app
wants to
get your slices you get a call
on unbind slice.
There, you get a call with the
URI of the slice being requested
and you have to return your
slice immediately.  So any
content that needs to be loaded
should be kicked off.  You will
return it in build slice.  So
let's take a deeper look.
We will construct the slice
here.
And we are able to construct it
with
several builder classes,
including rope builder, red rope
builder and list builder.  Take
a look.
Here we'll use a list builder
for a simple header.
You will see it adds the header.
To build on top of it, we will
see the grid row builder.
First the latest weather
information and we can loop
through it, adding a cell to
the grid row builder, by calling
add grid row at the bottom, with
the rest of the slice to the
header.
What you get here is that based
on screen real estate, if it is
small, it will show a shortcut
slice.
With the shortcut slice pick up
an image from the slice.
Because you have a weather image
it will pick it up, if you
didn't, it will show the app
icon.
If it is only a small slice,
that is the head shown, finally,
with enough space, it will show
the full slice.  To learn more
about the slices, there was a
topic this morning that you can
review.  But I only covered very
basic of it, you can learn more
about templates, permission,
integrating search in the other
talk.
You can also meet the team at
the office
hour tent tomorrow morning at
10:30.  The next topic I want to
talk about is material
components.
We launchlaunched material
components
for Android in library 28.00
Alpha in March and launched for
AndroidX yesterday.
So as you know, material theming
is designed for great user
experience and made a lot of
improvements since 0.  One of
the first things we have done
as part of the AndroidX
refactoring is stead of just an
Android dot support
design, it is moved to Google
material.  We have done a lot of
extensive
usability studies on how to make
the widgets helpful.  We have
updated styling, so you can
better express your brand and
include a new UI component.
Let's take a look.
Here's an overview of the
theming capability.
On the right, a very brand
agnostic baseline.
On the left, the Google
brandedbranded.  All the
components pull from the theme
to have the super easy app white
theming.  Let's walk through
some of the code.  As you
expect, we have to import the
library.
Here, note that it is coming
from Google material.
And to use a baseline theme, you
define kind of set the theme to
be material components dot
light.
This is for brand agnostic theme
to start with.  Then we provide
a bunch of attributes
that you can override so all the
widgets within the app can pick
up.
Here, we're define primary
color, text in theme dot XML.
On top of that define attributes
for different text styles.  With
some that comes out of box but
you can also define your own.
Although custom widgets, if you
have those that use the
attributes, it can also pick up
the theme.
Look at the components updated.
First up is text field.  We
improve the search and use the
touch target making it easier
for input and more usable and
accessible.
And add more states, focus,
error and text counter.  We have
kind of think through all of it
from the start to make your life
easier.
Next up is button.  You can
tell, you can use button the way
you use today by setting the
material component light theme,
it will inflate this to the
material button, to understand
themes and pick up the
attributes you set previously in
the theme file.
You can use custom attributes
with these and we provide two
updated bars for you.  The first
is the bottom app bar.
The bottom app bar allows
actions into your app.  What we
have done here is allowed you
to -- we have done research and
saw the phones are bigger.  We
want you to allow you to
position your apps anywhere you
want on the app bar.  Here is a
fab that is centered and can be
animated to be right aligned.
The other bottom bar we have
updated is the bottom navigation
bar.  So just to clarify that.
Bottom app bar for action and
bottom navigation bar is for
different section in the app.
We don't recommend mixing the
metaphors, we provide both to
choose from to build your app.
Pulling all of this together is
the material card view that is a
wrapper on the existing card
view in the Support
Library or AndroidX.
Simplified how it is built.
Less elevation, and shadow and
pulls from the theme and color.
So here, you can see all the
elements coming together with
the text button and
all of that in the material card
view.  With this component, you
have to
define the user material card
view explicitly, looking to see
where we can integrate it as
well.  With that, you can learn
more about
this in stage 8 at 4:30 at how
to incur what's new with
material design in your code
base.
And AndroidX is only one part of
Jetpack.
Jetpack is a set of components,
tools,
guidance to help you build great
Android apps quickly and easily.
So we're at this talk, but we
have four more talks to learn
more about Jetpack.  With that,
thank you.
Alan, Aurimas and I will hang
out at the Android tent over
there.
Hope to see and talk to all of
you.  Thank you.
(Applause)
>> Thank you for joining this
session.  Brand ambassadors will
assist with directing you
through the designated exits.
We'll be making room for those
who registered for the next
session.  If you registered for
the next session in this room,
we ask that you please
clear the room and return via
the registration line outside.
Thank you.
(Session concluded)
.
ML kit, machine learning SDK for
mobile developers.
>> At this time, please find
your seat.  Our session will
begin soon.
>> BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKHI: Good
afternoon, everyone.  My name is
Brahim Elbouchikhi.
We, as a team are very excited
to tell you about ML kit.  You
have heard about it from Dave at
the main keynote and probably
looked at our documentation.  In
this session, we'll tell you
more, some of the behind the
scenes stuff we have been
working on.
So let me get started.
I think it is important to look
back a couple years, look at
machine learning, what has been
happening, the context.
And I try to quantify this the
best way I could.
One way is to look at goggle
-- Google trends, the most
reliable source of data.
You can see there is a 50X
increase in deep learning.  That
is not a new technology.  That
has been around since the 70s.
What has changed is we can
deliver on the promise of deep
learning.  We have enough
compute, memory and power on the
devices to actually run the
models that have been developed
for some
time.
I want to give you, as a product
manager, a simplified view of
product management.
Essentially deep learning uses
layers and tries to mimic how
the brain functions, tries to
activate different neurons,
based on the specific input it
is getting so they can
ultimately arrive at the answer
of whether this should a dog,
cat or hot dog or not.
And in this case, if you can see
on the image, the output of the
particular outcome is dog.  What
we have before the source of
algorithms was
rule-basedrule-based engines,
you had to configure the rules,
if, this and this, and this,
that's a dog.  Which does not
scale.
So because of that deep learning
has
allowed us to get into so many
more use
cases and solve so many more
problems
that we could before purely with
rules engines.
That's cool.
In particular, over the past
seven years or so, our ability
and the machine's ability to
perceive the world around it has
gotten good.
In this case, 2011, a 26% error
rate in identifying that animal
as a cheetah.
On the right, as of now,
essentially, the error rate is
less than 3%.
Which is better than what a
human can do.  That is pretty
awesome.
The fact that an algorithm, a
machine, can now perceive the
world in that way, opens up lots
of new use cases.
But of course, as a team, our
mission is about bringing
machine learning to mobile
devices and mobile apps.  So
when we start researching this
product, we went out there, we
talked to
many developers, both internally
at Google and externally to try
to understand what are you doing
with machine learning on
devices?  And how does it work
today?  So I'm going to tell you
a bit about that.
The first thing, one of the
first we talked about is Google
Translate.  Of course, you hear
a lot about Google Translate
because it is a delightful
experience, and incredibly
useful.  But what I like the
most about Google Translate is
the fact that it strings
together multiple types of deep
learning, machine learning
models and technologies to
deliver this experience.
So it does the on-screen
character recognition to extract
the text it is looking at.  It
does the actual translation
itself and ultimately, it could
do text to speech so it can
speak the results back to the
user.
And we think that when you can
string these things together,
when you can use machine
learning in multiple ways within
a single experience, where
relevant, obviously, really cool
stuff happens.
That is one example.
The other one is the app called
you CICIAN.
It allows you to play an analog
instrument, it listens while you
play and tries to interpret how
well you are doing.  It left
hands of to the notes you are
playing, it is listening to how
well you
are playing them, timestamping
them.
Echo cancellation and noise
cancellation and finally,
personalize in the learning
experience.
All of this is done with an
on-device machine model, with
this team, they
built their own C++ run time to
do the inference on the device
as efficiently as possible.
This predated TensorFlow light
and other things we have now
that could have helped with that
particular process.
The other folks we have talked
about, among the few others are
ever note.  So ever note
launched a feature called ever
note collect.  The insight
behind ever note collect is the
fact that we collect so much of
our information in a visual
manner.
We're taking screen shots of
things we care about.
Pictures of receipts, of
whiteboards
after the meeting, askingasking
someone to transcribe them.
Ever note tries to avoid that.
It tries to extract the text,
tag that, and make it more
useful.  That is super cool.
The overall theme that we heard
through many conversation was
that it is doable.  On-device
machine learning is doable, but
it is really hard.
It is hard for three specific
reasons.  The first is acquiring
sufficient data in both the
quantity and quality that you
need.  Think about it.
Say you are training an OCR
model, you can label the data
for your own language.
You can get an actual training
set, say I'm going to label what
this data says myself because I
understand that language.  But
in a global audience, when you
have users all over the world,
how do you create an OCR model
that actually works for all
those languages?  That's really
hard.
Even harder, if you are a music
music-learning app, you need to
hire world-class musicians to
record the perfect note so you
can train against it.
That is expensive.  The other
aspect is developing models that
are optimized for mobile
inference.  This has many
dimensions.  This could be in
terms of battery
life, in terms of compute, and
in terms of size of the
model.  And what I have learned
in machine
learning is that these are
always constant tradeoffs.
You can improve in one and
decrease in the other one.  It
is a really hard challenge to
solve.
And finally, the deploying an
ongoing experimentation is
essential to machine learning.
You can't do one without the
other.  So, however, there
aren't very many tools today to
help you do
that.  So we set out ML kit to
try to address all of these
issues.
Of course, it is the beginning
of a long road and journey, but
we think there is some exciting
stuff for you today.
I want to first talk about our
machine learning SDK.  Our
machine learning stack.
At this case, the very bottom is
the
Android neuronetworks, API and
iOS is metal.
On the neural network it is
lunched
with ML1 and an hardware
Internet extension case.
We build drivers for the neural
networks API.  I'm excited to
show you results.  With the P20
series device, we're
seeing 10X improvement in
latency, inference with
incention V3.  What is cool, if
you don't know inception V3, it
is a large model.  It wasn't
built for mobile devices at all.
It will built for server side
inference.
The fact that we can run that
kind of model at 10X performance
and run it efficiently on a
mobile device that is not
connected to a power plant is
actually super exciting.
This means we have more headroom
to do more with machine learning
on a device
top of course, there is another
model of this where we have
models that are built for
mobile, from the ground up, and
built to be highly efficient,
all of that.  So that work
continues.  When you pair these
up together, we think there will
be a lot of cool stuff happening
here.
We're continuing to invest on
Android neural networks API and
relying on metal on the iOS
side.
The next aspect here is
TensorFlow lite.  It was
announced last year, shipped
around November.
It is a machine learning set of
tools and library.
It works on both mobile devices
and embedded devices and built
from the
ground up, as it says to be
lightweight.  Now, I'm not going
to steal any of the team's
thunder.
They have a session fully
dedicated to TensorFlow lite
tomorrow, so I highly recommend
to go see it if you are at all
interested in on-device machine
learning.
Which I assume you would be , if
you are here.  Then we get at
the application layer.
This is where we looked around,
we said
there isn't really an easy way
to access machine learning
technologies at that layer.
You have to either go interface
directly with the run time and
build your own models or you
really had to build your own
step.
So that is where ML kit comes
into the picture.  ML kit is in
beta, as of yesterday.  So you
obviously all can go use it
today.
And it is essentially Google's
machine learning SDK.
Our aim is to bring Google's
15-plus years in machine
learning, all of the technology
we developed, bring it to mobile
developers through this SDK.
So let me tell you more about
it.
Well, first, let me show you the
stack again with some.
L kit on the top.
This is our on device machine
learning stack.
Now, I hope I get to tell you
about it.  Okay.  So the first
thing that is really important
is that ML kit is both on iOS
and Android.
This was really important to us
because when we talk to
developers, we don't think about
Android machine learning and iOS
machine learning.  We think
about machine learning.
We want to deploy similar models
to users on both platforms.
There is not a fork there.
Say it was important that we
have a consistent SDK for both.
And in fact, every one of our
features
is available on both Android and
iOS.
We offer two types of rough
buckets of features.
One is what we call base API.
These are backed by Google
models.
As far as we're concerned as a
developer, there is no machine
learning involved.  The other is
a set of features that
help you use your own
custom-trained models.
I will tell you more about that
in a bit.
ML kit offers on-device and
Cloud-based API.  Again, this is
important.
On-device API give you the
real-time and offline abilities.
But they have limited accuracy
in comparison to Cloud.
However, on-device API are free
of charge.
But we also wanted to give you a
consistent interface for the
Cloud API.
But in many cases you do need
that level of precision and that
level of scope.  We will talk
about the distinctions between
the two in a little bit.
And finally, ML kit is deeply
integrated into Firebase.  This
is another important point for
us.  We aim to make machine
learning to make it
nonexceptional.  We don't want
it to be special.
We want it to be yet another
tool, just
like you use analytics or crash
lytics,
or performance monitoring, Cloud
storage, like you use any parts
of the Firebase, we want machine
learning to be right there,
right then.  What this also does
is works well with other
features on Firebase.
Again, we'll tell you more
detail about that in a few
minutes.
So that's the high level about
ML kit.
So what base API support today?
First, text recognition.
This is available both on Cloud
and on device.
The second is Malaysian
labeling,s in
is bar code scanning, face
detection and landmark
recognition.  The four API on
the left are available on
device.  Meaning you can use
them for free and in real-time
and offline.
We also have two super-cool
features coming up soon.
One is a high-density face
contour feature.  This is over
100 points in real-time.  And
the other is a smart reply API.
This is what we like to talk
about at Google we work together
really well.
It is part of Android P, there
is a
feature to now insert response
suggestions within the
notification shade directly.
ML kits with the smart reply API
is something helpful in
populating the chips.
This is same in iOS and not API.
This is in where OS, Android
messages, so that is cool.
Sometimes you simply need to
build a custom model.  If you
are trying to detect that
particular type of flower, you
can -- it is hard to build a
generic model.  You can build
one, but it will be super large.
As you detect every flower,
every dog, every species of
everything.
You have base custom models,
sometimes.  We wanted to help
with that as well.  The first
feature we have here is dynamic
model downloads.
What this means is you can
upload your model to the
Firebase console, and have it be
served to your users
dynamically.
You don't have to bundle the
model into the APK.  This has a
bunch of benefits.
First, it reduces the APK size.
You don't have to put that 5 or
10 megabyte model into APK,
meaning you have to take a hit
when the user is trying to
install the app.  The other
important insight for us was
we decouple the process, the ML,
the release process from the
software kind of traditional app
release processes.  We learned
that the teams are typically
slightly different teams.
Your machine learning team is
probably a different set of
people than the ones building
your core software experience.
This gives you the flexibility
to deploy each at different
times.
Now, I really cool benefit of
this also is you can now do AB
testing on different models with
literally a single line of code.
This is the coolest part for me.
If you were to do this today,
maybe before ML kit launched you
have to bundle two models into
your app, you are stuck with the
two same models for the duration
of the app's life cycle and you
have to upload all the metrics
back, do all of that work.  This
makes it trivial.  And given how
important it is to experiment as
part of the machine
learning, this is we think, a
real game-changer for the
ability to use machine learning
models.
And finally, we talked about the
optimization challenge of
building models that are made
for model.  We're excited that
we'll have a feature that is
coming soon that will
allow you to convert and
compress full
TensorFlow models into
lightweightlightweight
TensorFlow lite models.  We will
talk about the magic -- we
call it also technology --
behind the compression flow.
That is ML kit.  Google's
machine learning SDK
available on Android and iOS.
I want to take a moment, as
always to thank our partners.
We've worked with every one of
these partners and many more to
launch ML kit.  They worked
through so many bugs, so many
challenges, given us so much
feedback and the product
wouldn't be where it is today
without their help.  I want to
thank them a lot.  And in
particular, I want to highlight
a couple of things.
I worked with pics art and they
deploy a
custom model to deploy the magic
effect.
What is cool is they use ML kit
on Android and iOS.  We also
work with intuit.  If you know
U.S.
tax dates, tax day is around
April, so it is really pressed
for time to get the feature out.
So we worked with them to
integrate ML kit in record time.
That was super-awesome as well.
All right.
So before I hand it over to
Sachin to tell you more about ML
kit, I wanted to make a
commitment to you.  We're going
to go out there and we're going
to knock on Google's research
teams' doors, every one of them.
We're going to go out there and
ask them to bring their
technologies to you to be part
of ML kit.
We will focus on vision, speech,
text models.
And we're also continue to make
use of custom models as easy as
possible.  So that's it.
I will invite Sachin to come up
here
and tell you more about how ML
kit works.
>> SACHIN KOTWANI: Thanks,
Brahim.
Hello everyone, my name is
Sachin Kotwani.  I work on
Firebase.
I was practicing at home with my
three EERLD.  Every time we
finish she would say again, I'm
not sure if she was telling
me to practice more or if she
enjoyed the content.
We'll find out.
When we set out to build ML kit,
we had
two main objectives, the first
was to build something powerful
and useful, Brahim talked about
about that.
And if it is fun, I will tell
you
about that if you use Firebase,
you are
familiar with storage, remote
config,
crash lytics, analytics, AV
testing, more.
Now, there is a new addition to
the family.  Starting with week
with our launch, if you head to
the Firebase console, you will
see the ML kit.
Clicking on that will take you
to the
main screen, with the Firebase
API you will introduced to.
Mostly they're vision focused if
territory now, we will tend to
add to it in the future.
Let's look at one specific use
case.
Say I'm building an app.  It
needs to determine what is the
content of an image.  What the
theme is, what things are in it,
how would you use the image
labeling API.  As you can see
there are two icons here, this
indicates the API is
available to run on device and
in the Cloud.  On device is
free.
It is low latency, no network
required because everything runs
on the phone.
It supports roughly 400-plus
labels.  If you need something
more powerful,
something to give you more high
accuracy results, you would use
the Cloud-based API.
That is free for the first 1,000
API calls per month and paid
after that, but it supports over
10,000 labels.  Let's look at an
example.
If you were to feed this image
to the
on-device API, you get labels
like fun, infrastructure, neon,
person, sky, if you feed it to
the Cloud one, you get Ferris
while, amusement park, night,
you can see it is more accurate.
Right?  Okay.
Remember, I told you it is not
just fun, it is easy to use.
You have to hold me to it.
Say I want to implement this API
on iOS.  I would just include
these three libraries in my pod
file, similarly, if I do
Android, I would put the three
libraries in the build dot
Gradle file.
Next, if you am doing iOS
on-device
image labeling, I would
insatiate, and get it back and
handle and handle the extracted
entities.
On Android, the pattern is very
similar.
You instantiate the detector,
detector detect an image.  Pay
attention to the highlighted
boxes in gray over there.  This
is on device.
If I want to do the same thing
but call the Cloud API instead.
Not much changes.  It is just a
few class names.  The pattern is
very similar.
The
detector, detect an image,
handle, extract an image.  Demo
time.
I was warned not to do a demo.
But my wife says I don't listen.
So here's me not listening.
Let's see if this works.
I will show you the image
labeling API.  This is typically
used for things like tagging
photos, if you want to know what
is in the content of a picture,
still picture, usually.  I
thought it would be cool to show
a
live dome --
demo with a live stream.
It says toy, car, vehicle, tire,
bumper, is it picking out all
the pieces there.  Okay.
Oh, it says crowd, too, event, I
didn't get to test this.
Because when I was practicing,
it was no crowd, it was just
empty chairs.  Okay.  Face
detection.  Switch to this.
Okay.  So there is a box around
my face, as you can see.  There
is left eye, right eye.
The numbers next to the left and
right eye are how open they are.
So you can tell that I am awake.
Happiness is detected for the
smile.  So look at how that
changes.
And this works with multiple
people, actually.  So just, you
know, again, you shouldn't trust
me, you should ask me to prove
it to you.
So I need a few volunteers here.
Okay.  Multiple faces detected.
Eyes for everyone.
Smiles for everyone.  Huh?
Pretty cool?  Right.
(Applause) .  Okay.
I have a couple more things.
Lose it as mentioned is one of
our partners.  They worked on
this really cool feature.  I
will enter here.
Say I am logging what I had for
breakfast.
And, you know, normally, you can
select foods that are already in
the application, you can enter
it manually.
Say you want to enter a new
food.  Apparently this is not
considered food so I don't think
it is in the application.  I
will try it.
So like I said, you can enter it
manually, let's -- ooh, it
detected it faster than what I
expected.  Let me try that one
more time.  There you go,
nutrition label found, here's
all the information, the
calories, fats, saturated fats.
All right.  You want one more?
Okay.  This is stuff that is not
available yet.  But I think it
is pretty cool.
This is our face contours demo.
It detects over 100 points,
processes
them in 60 frames per second,
you can see my lips, my eyes,
the entire face contour.  This
will be coming soon.  A sign-up
link, if you are interested.
You know, we look forward to
having it in your hands so you
can play with it.
All right.
(Applause) .
Thank you.  That was pretty
cool.
Hopefully you find the base APIs
useful.  There are use cases
that you might have that are
very specific to your
application.  What if you wanted
to detect different
types of flowers or like you
youSCICIA inspect you might want
your own custom model.
M L kit helps with that as well.
The first is the ML kit provides
a layerer to interact with the
TensorFlow model.
You can get inputs and outputs.
Second, upload the tensor lite
model to the Firebase console.
First, Brahim alluded to this
earlier, you can bundle your
model with your application if
you choose.  If it is big and
you want to reduce the install
size, actually just leave it in
the Cloud and download it
dynamically.  The initial
install size is smaller.  The
third one, because it lives in
the Cloud, you can dynamically
switch the model.
You don't have to switch a new
APK or bundle to the app store
or Play Store.  Here is a quick
snippet on how to load that
model, how you refer to it.
Let's say I called my model V1.
I would put this snippet and it
would retrieve it from the
Cloud.  Let's take a step back.
When I started, remember, I
mentioned that there are a lot
of the Firebase products that
are very useful.
And one of them, the favorite
one is remote config.
It allows you to dynamically
switch values inside of your
app.  Typically used for
switching the color, background,
you can also use it to switch
call to action strings.
You know, it is really useful
for that sort of thing.
It turns out it is also useful
for ML kit.
I went to the Firebase console
created my model.  I created
three different target
populations.  One, for people
who speak English, another for
people that speak Spanish and a
default value.  What I am trying
to do is targeting a different
model to the different
populations.
And once you do that, instead of
hard
coding a model name, like here,
you just
change that static string for a
call to remote config and every
device, depending on the
population they belong to, they
will get the respective model.
This is just a very simple
example.
You can, you know, think of
using AV
testing in analytics, you can
test out models, pick the one
that performs best and choose
that.  Experimentation, as
Brahim said earlier, is
important in machine learning.
All right.
Before
I wrap up and hand it over to
Wei, I want to talk about the
models.
You need a TensorFlow lite model
to run on a device.  We have a
feature for that.  It is coming
soon.  You upload the TensorFlow
model, with the data, once it is
done processing, you will get a
bunch of TensorFlow lite models
to choose from.  You can see,
these are compressed.
They have tradeoff, different
accuracy, different inference
latency and different sizes,
depending on what you are most
sensitive to, you can pick your
needs.  This flow is only for
image classification models, but
we look forward to adding more
in the future.
You pick the model that works
best for you.  You publish it,
it is available like any other
custom model that you would
upload on your own.
I know I make this seem super
easy with beautiful UI and three
steps, but this is actually
really hard to do.
It is an active area research.
It is almost like magic, and to
tell you
more about that magic, I would
like to introduce our resident
wizard.
Wei, please come up on stage.
>> WEI CHAI: Thank you, Sachin.
Hi, my name is Wei Chai.
My team has mix motion learning
experts and mobile developers.
It is a lot of fun to be part of
it and build something we all
believe can
be useful, for example, model
compression.  Now, I would like
to go deeper into the technology
behind the magic.
First of all, let me explain why
we want you to support model
compression.
Running machine learning on the
Cloud
versus on mobile, one big
difference is
mobile environment has very
limited computational resource.
This makes the model size and
performance speed critical per
for
today's hardware limit, most
mobile applications require very
small models, ideally less than
a couple megabytes.
So for like -- so like -- um ...
In hand, if we look at the
model architectures, for
limitation, to attain higher
accuracy the machine
learning models can go deeper
and larger.
Sometimes hundreds of megabytes
for certain applications.
After talking to a lot of the
mobile developers, we realize
that how to make machine
learning models small and
efficient enough to fit our
mobile phones is one of the big
pinpoints.
With ML kit, we would like to
address this issue by providing
model
compression, tooling, and
support.
So a model compression service
or tool
takes a large model as input and
automatically generate models
that are smaller in size, more
memory efficient,
more power efficient, faster in
inference speed with minimal
loss in accuracy.  As Sachin
just mentioned, this is
still an active mission learning
research area.  Our compression
service is based on learn to
compression technology developed
by Google research.
And it combines various
state-of-the-art model
compression techniques.
For example, one method called
pruning
reduces the model size by
removing the
last contributing ways and
operations in the model.
We found that for certain
on-device compositional models,
pruning can
further reduce the model size by
up to 2X.
Without too much drop in
accuracy.
So another method is trying to
reduce
number of bids used for model
weights and activation.
For example, using eight-bit
fixed point for model weights
and activation inside the flow,
can make the model inference run
much faster, use lower
power, and reduce the model size
by 4X.
Specifically, with TensorFlow
lite,
switching from mobile net to
content
mobile net can speed up
inference by 2X or more on Pixel
phones.
The third model is a student
model with distilled knowledge
from large model.  A teacher
model.
So the student does not only
learn from
the ground labels, but from the
teacher.
Typically, the student models
are very small in size, with
much less waste in the model,
and use more efficient
operations for the benefit of
inference speed.
For example, for image
classification, the student
models can be chosen from
mobile net, squeeze net or any
other
state-of-the-art model
architectures
compact enough for mobile
applications.
We can further extend this
distillation idea to
simultaneously
train the teacher model, and
multiple
models with different sizes in a
single shot.
One thing to mention is that
very
often, for all of these
techniques, we need a
fine-tuning step for the best
accuracy.  So in this case, we
do not only need the original
model for the compression
process, but also your training
data.
So for ML kit, we'll provide a
Cloud service for model
compression.
For now, we only support image
classification use cases, but
will soon expand them to more.
So the reason that we support
model compression as a Cloud
service, as I just mentioned,
model compression is still an
active research area with new
technologies and new model
architectures, specifically for
mobile applications invented
very fast.
For example, from mobile net V1
to V2, it took less than one
year to invent.
So our compression service will
automatically incorporate the
latest advances in technology
for you.
Another reason, the compression
process typically takes quite
some computational resource.
It can grammatical hours on GPU.
We will run our Cloud service on
Google Cloud to use the
computation
power there.
So what we need from the
developers
include a pretrained TRENSor
flow model in safe model or
checkpoint format.  And your
training data in TensorFlow
example for that, for the fine
tuning step I just mentioned.
What we generate will be a set
of
models with different size and
accuracy tradeoffs for you to
choose from.
Since ML kit is running on top
of TensorFlow lite, all the
generated
models will already be in
TensorFlow
lite format for you to download
or
serve through our model hosting
service.
So with ML kit model compression
service, we're aiming to
compress a
model up to 100 times smaller,
depending
on your use case and original
model to
give you a real developer use
case as example.
Fish brain is a local fishing
app.  They already have their
model to identify fish species
and the model is currently
running on the Cloud.
With our model compression
service, the original model
provided by the
developer with 80 megabytes and
92% accuracy can be compressed
to
much smaller models with
different size and accuracy
shown here.
As you can see, in this
particular
case, the accuracies of the
generated models were even
higher than the original model.
Which is not always the case,
but is
possible, and it is great.
To summarize, with ML kit, we
would like to make mission
learning accessible
to all mobile developers to
achieve
that we would like to help with
every
step in the mission learn ing
work flow on how to build the
model but to build
and optimize your model.
Now, I would like to conclude
the talk with a summary of what
we'll provide.
We're launching in beta the base
APIs for both iOS and Android.
Including text recognition,
image labeling, bar code
scanning, face detection, and
landmark recognition.
We're also supporting custom
APIs with TensorFlow lite model
serving.
Please checkout these features
at the Firebase website.
Meanwhile, we'll have a set of
new features coming out soon,
including high-density face
contour API, smart
reply API and model compression
conversion service.  We'll soon
start to white list developers
to try them out.
If you are interested, please
use this link here to sign up.
We're super-excited about ML kit
and how it potentially can help
developers build cool machine
learning features.
Look forward to your feedback
and we're
committed to making it great.
Thanks for coming.  And if you
have questions, we'll be
available right after this talk
at the
fair Sandbox Q&A area and we're
having relevant sessions and
talks for you to checkout.
Finally, please leave your
feedback
about this session for us to
improve for the future.  Thank
you.
(Applause) .
>> Thank you for joining this
session.  Brand ambassadors will
assist with directing you
through the designated exits.
We'll be making room for those
who registered for the next
session.  If you have registered
for the next session in this
room, we ask that you please
clear the room and return via
the registration line outside.
Thank you.
(Session concluded)
.
..
use Lighthouse and Chrome UX
report to optimize web app
performance.
..
>> At this time, please find
your seat.  Our session will
begin soon.
>> VINAMRATA SINGAL: Good
afternoon, everyone.
I've hellohello.
>> VINAMRATA SINGAL: My name is
Vinamrata Singal, I work on
Lighthouse
and other initiatives at Google
I've my name is Rick Viscomi and
I work on transparency tools and
the courtroom
experience reportreport.
>> VINAMRATA SINGAL: Rick and
are here to tell you how to use
Lighthouse and others for the
application.  I wanted to tell
you about myself before we get
started so you know who you are
talking to.
Fun fact about me, when I was
growing up, I have grown-up in
four different countries, India,
Saudi Arabia, New Zealand, and
United States.
What was interesting, as I was
growing up across the countries
is having access to information
was really challenging.  Either
because it was restricted for me
and my family or because no one
around us had that information.
That really changed when I
started learning how to use the
web.
It made it so much easier to
have access to that information.
That is why I care about making
sure the web is available for
everyone and is a great
experience for all.
But even as I was learning how
to use
the web, there were pain points
with that experience.  This is a
picture of me as a kid in Saudi
Arabia, on DSL Internet, if you
remember those days, learning
how to use the Internet.
It was really, really, really
slow.
What is interesting is the
slowness and performance pain
hasn't go away for a lot of
users.  At Google, we have seen
it has real implications for
businesses as well.  So we have
been collecting a bunch of
data to show the impact
performance can have for
businesses.  You might have seen
the study we did with double
click, for sites that load in
less than five seconds, they
receive a bounce rate that is
53% lower compared
to sites that load in more than
five seconds.
Shoppers that have trouble with
site performance, 79% don't come
back.  Additionally for every
second there is a delay in page
load time, there is a 7% drop in
conversion rate.  I want to
emphasize that again.
For every extra second our site
is slower, you can lose 7% of
your users.
This is all to say that if you
are a business that is online,
you should care about
performance.
You might say to me,
Vinamrata, I get it, what are
the guidance, tools, and metric?
For that, I say you have come to
the right place.
We hope to answer these
questions and more.
To give an overview, we will
start off giving information
into performance metrics and
kind of walk you through the
overall tooling and guidance
landscape, Rick will take over,
tell you about the Chrome user
experience support and I will
wrap us up with Lighthouse.
Let's get started with
performance metrics.
When we talk about performance
metrics, what we're talking
about is collecting data.
There is two sources you want to
collect.
The
first is lab data known as
metrics from the lab.  This is
from a controlled environment.
It is useful for getting
granular
information from your site.  The
second type is field data,
metrics
from the dial or RUM, ownership
-- or real user metrics.  This
is how real users experience the
performance of your site.
This is helpful in understanding
the ground truth of the
performance of your site.
You might look
at this image and think do I use
one or the other?
In reality, you use them
together.
You use field data to understand
the users, understand the
baseline performance of the
site, where users are
coming from, what devices are
they on?  What networks are they
on?  That helps you calibrate
the lab environment.  Once you
understand the baseline and
whatever business or key
performance indicators you are
trying to optimize for, then you
can set goals around, you know,
the targets for whatever you
want the performance to be.
After you understand that, you
want to
start looking at the lab data,
calibrated from what you saw in
the field to drill down,
understand what parts of the
performance you need to improve,
as well as implement the
optimization to make the site
faster.  Once you make
improvements in the lab, go back
to the field to make sure you
see the improvements in the lab,
in the wild and monitor the
performance of the site for
regressions.
Now that we have spent time
talking about where the
performance data comes
from, you might be asking, what
data do I collect?  When we
think about the performance of a
site, we quantify how does the
real user experience the
performance of the site?
There are two buckets of user
experience.  The first bucket is
what we call visual metrics.
This is measuring how fast is
stuff getting painted on the
screen?
And there is the second bucket,
which is interactivity metrics,
that is essentially measures,
how quickly does your site
become usable for users?
Under the bucks, we have
specific metrics.
We have metrics like
first speed and pain index and
time to interactive.
To really understand what the
metrics
mean, I think it is important to
visualize them in a time line.
We are trying to see how real
users experience this.  In this
left, you have the first
consent.
This means when the first piece
of context appears on the
screen, text, image, SVG.
This is pivotal in the user
experience.  This is where the
user is like okay, the site is
using, doing something.  Very
end is timed interactive.  For
the user, that means everything
is loaded, they can interact
with any part of the page and it
just is responsive, it works.
And everywhere in the middle,
you have what we call speed
index.
Which is essentially measuring
how quickly does the rest of the
page load?  Speed index will
reward pages that load a lot of
stuff earlier, because that is
when the user feels very fast.
We have actually seen a lot of
developers have success with the
tool kit of metrics.
I want to share an anecdote of
users.  A lot of you heard of
Pinterest.
We helped them upgrade the
mobile web experience to
progressive web app and they
wanted to improve the overall
interactivity of the experience.
They improved the time from 26
to 5.6 seconds.
As a result of this, they saw a
whole set of improvements across
the business metrics.  So they
saw an overall 40% increase in
the number of users who spend
more than five minutes on the
site.
They saw 44% increase in the
amount of user generated ad
revenue.
They saw 50% increase in the ad
click-through rate and 60%
increase in core engagement.
All in all, this is awesome
work.  But what is interesting
is I think we can still do
better to help developers
understand interactivity
experience.  Specifically, I
think the place to make a lot of
impact is right now, time to
interactive is only a lab
metric.
I think we can do a better job
of helping developers understand
interactivity in the wild.
How are users first starting to
understand the interactivity
experience, especially when they
come to your app for the first
time.
I think in order to make this
more concrete, I want to tell
you a story.
Imagine for a second you are not
a developer, you are a user.
So pretend you just heard about
this new
site, say it is Vinamrata cool
store, you go to it on your
phone.
It is loading, you are
interacting with it, you click
on the button, nothing happens,
you keep clicking on the button,
nothing is happening.  Raise
your hand if you ever had that
happen to you.  Yes, like
everyone.
KEER  -- keep your hands up.
Keep your hand up if you felt
frustrated by that experience.
It is like everyone, for those
on the live stream.  Again, it
is a frustrating experience.
Putting our user hat down,
again, putting a developer hat
back on, we can probably
understand why something like
this would happen.
One explanation for this is the
browser
is done rendering, all the HTML,
SS,
because of the Javascript, you
browser
is take time to input the
browser script.  When the new
interaction is coming through,
it doesn't have time to interact
because of the Javascript it
has.  This is the user
experience we want to minimize
with the metric called first
input delay, which we are
introducing today.  First input
delay is measuring the latency
with the user's first
interaction with the page.  This
means that from the time the
user interacts with your page,
the time when that happens to
the time when the code that you
wrote to respond to that
interaction actually runs.
And we think really focusing on
the first user experience is
really critical.  As you saw a
couple of slides ago, a lot of
users leave if the first
experience is terrible.
You want to optimize business
metrics like bounce rate and
conversion rate, you want the
first experience to be solid.
We're working on the definition
of the metric and
messagemessaging.  We encourage
you to give us feedback.
There is a link to docks and
Javascript polyfill to use and
put on the website.  Check it
out, please give us feedback on
the polyfill repo.
Now that we spent a bunch of
time talking about metrics,
let's transition to talking
about the overall tooling and
guidance.  So this is an
overview of all the tools
published on Google about site
performance.  One of the most
common questions we
get is like, Google you put all
the tools how, how do I navigate
this?  How do I use this?
What tool should I be using?
Great question.
Ironically, we built a tool to
help you understand this.
Not ironically, it is awesome.
This is the e-tools -- speed
tools overview.  It helps you
understand, for if I want to
build a business case for
performance
so my company invests in it, to
oh,
like, I want to get nitty-gritty
into performance or all the use
cases in between help you
understand what tool to use.
I encourage you to check it out,
you know, give us feedback about
things you think are missing.
We're looking forward to hearing
more from you.
So now that we have covered a
little bit about tooling,
metrics, we thought it would be
really helpful to do a deep-dive
into tools in particular.  I
will hand it off to Rick now,
who will tell you about the
Chrome user experience report.
>> RICK VISCOMI: Thank you.
So when we talk about metrics
from the field, most people
think of traditional
real user measurement or RUM,
where you measure things like
performance, page road, page
views, conversion.  This is
great for understanding the
user experience on your own
site, but how do we understand
the user experience on the web
as a whole?
How do we know if it is getting
faster or usable?  How do we
know if the use is normal?
For that, we need a different
set that represent the web at
large.
The Chrome UX report, known as
crux helps us understand the
web.
It is data from real Chrome
users.  Let's see how it works.
When you have a data set that
covers the web at large, it
enables analyses that were never
before possible.  You can
compare real user performance
across particular sites and see
how you stack up against
competitors.  In this example,
we can see that competitor B is
slightly faster than my website.
This is a really good motivator
for me to care about web
performance.  It is one thing to
know how fast my site is, but it
is another to see how much
faster or slower it is compared
to the competition.
Additionally, the Chrome UX
report is updated monthly.
You can track your performance
benchmarks over time.  As I
optimize the performance of my
site, I can see the gains in
each iteration of the report.
Alternatively, I can see my
competitor is investing in
performance and I need to catch
up approximate.
So what exactly does the Chrome
UX report measure?
It includes visual metrics
Vinamrata mentioned earlier.
First first and first content
pink.
And visual like on content and
download.
My download is first content and
paint.  It reflects the real
user experience of feeling like
the page is loading.
It includes useful dimensions
for slicing the data.
Like the form factor of the
users
device, desktop, phone, tablet,
and the
effective connection time,
3G, 2G, 4G, this is the
effective speed, not advertised
network.  A user on slow Wi-Fi
would be considered 2G.  Another
dimension that early users
requested is the ability to
slice by country.
With it, you can see how the
user experience varies by
geography.  It can help you
understand how much slower the
user experience is in places
farther away from the web
service.
There are two ways the data is
aggregated, by URL and by
origin.  How does the origin
differ from the URL?
It starts with the protocol,
either it is secure or not
secure.
The subdomain, for example, WWW,
mail, no subdomain at all.  And
of course, the domain, Google.
com or example.
com which includes suffixes like
dot com, what it doesn't include
is the path after the domain.
Index,
productslash one, two, three.
All of those are developed at
the origin level.
This has grown 400X since it was
first announced at the Chrome
dev center.  It is your website
that may or may not be included,
depending on popularity.
Okay, you are probably wondering
how do you start using it?
The raw data is available on
Google Vickary.
You can write queries for
information
about specific origins or web as
a whole.
The first content full paint is
less than one second.
It is broken down by two
hypothetical competitors.
Developers and
Chrome.Google.com.  The results
are informative, but hard to
understand by looking at it.
What we're trying to understand
is which origin is faster?  How
are they trending?
To help answer that, let's
visualize the data.
We can integrate with two tools,
sheets and data studio.
You will notice on the BigQuery
results, there is a button to
sheets.  That will create a new
sheet, populate it with a table
of data.  From there it is easy
to create a simple chart to
visualize the performance data.
It is clear from this chart that
developers at Google.
com, there is the first density
of
content full paint.  It
fluctuates.  Why?  Not just
because it is faster or slower.
It could be the user population.
The users on faster or slower
connections could be changing.
You can integrate with with
Google studio.  And you can
build interactive
dashboards, get data from the
BigQuery.  This shows one way to
monitor the distribution of
performance metrics over time.
What if you don't want to work
to get this data, you just want
high-level results now?
There are a few Google tools
built on the Chrome UX report to
give you insights quickly.
The first is page insights, used
to include the performance data.
Alongside the performance
population recommendations.
The insights are built on the
URL
aggregated dat app approximate
-- data.
This is more than you can get on
BigQuery.  Here is the UIL.
This is the first down full
paint and metrics and indicator
in how fast or slow it is in
relation to the rest of the web.
It
turns out the IO web page is
considered slow.  You can get a
sense for how skewed user
experiences really are.
In this case, we see most
content full paints are fast.
But 82% of down content loaded
experiences are considered slow.
Another Google tool built on the
Chrome UX report is the speed
scorecard.
This tool allows you to enter
multiple websites and stack rank
their
performance and enables you to
target specific geographic
regions to see how performance
varies.
It has something I love, a way
to correlate performance metrics
with business metrics like
revenue.
It estimates how much more
revenue can
be earned if nothing else
changed but site performance.
You use the slider for the
performance and predicted effect
on revenue.
This is another great motivator
to invest in performance not
just for developers, but
especially business leaders who
think in dollars.
Last, I wanted to share a case
study of how the Chrome UX
report is used outside of
Google.  Impulse is a real user
measurement
product from ACMI.
It is using the Chrome UX report
to care about real user
measurement.  For example, some
companies don't have
any RUM tools and may be relying
on lab testing like web page
test which only gives them a
narrow view of their
performance.
ACMI can show the companies the
real user performance in the
Chrome UX report which may be
vastly different from the
performance in the lab.
Just image the surprise to learn
that users experience your site
many times slower than your lab
tests indicate.
ACMI is looking to integrate
this data with the M pulse
product.
Recall with metrics from the web
as a whole, it is possible to
see performance of competitors.
With M pulse, you can see the
real user and competitor
performance alongside their own.
Site owners can understand how
they stack up in specific
markets.
The charts shown here indicate
how different sites perform,
especially on mobile.
This is exactly the kind of
thing that makes the Chrome UX
report so powerful.
Understanding how your site's
performance fits in the larger
picture of the performance on
the web as a whole.  This is a
small taste of the power of
the Chrome UX pore  power
setting.
We had the April data set
released
this week, looking to add more
user inpit, like first input.
We're working with others to get
this integrated into more third
party tools.  I will hand it
back to Vinamrata to
tell you about Lighthouse.
>> VINAMRATA SINGAL: Thank you,
Rick.  You guys can clap.
(Applause) (Applause) .
Awesome.  More audience
participation here.  Can you
raise your hand if you ever used
Lighthouse before?
Oh, awesomeawesome yay!  Those
that haven't, Lighthouse is a
developer tool you can run today
on your website.  It basically
gives you personalized advice
about what you are doing well
and what you can do better
across five different
categories.
Performance, progressive web
apps, accessibility, best
practices, search engine
optimization or SEO.  You can
run it through four different
ways.
You can run it as a stand-lone
Lighthouse extension, in the
audit panel, Chrome developer
tools, MPM module and the
command to install it, if you
choose to.
And you can run it on web page
test.
Now, I want to take a step back
and tell you a little bit about
the journey we have taken on the
product side to give you a
little bit of context of where
we're going.
This is a screen shot of Paul
Irish a
tech lead announcing Lighthouse
at developer summit.  We
understand there is information
sent to developers on things to
do to create good web
experiences.
We want it to be the one-stop
shop to go to, to get all the
advice in one place.  We have
been hard at work on making this
tool as comprehensive as
possible.  We have launched over
100 audits into the report.
Including a whole new section,
focused
on search engine optimization
this year.
You have seen a lot of doings in
the community.
Specifically in 2018 alone, you
have
seen over 500,000 users running
over two million-plus audits,
which is great.
We hear stories from developers
about success they're having on
house.  I want to share a
favorite.
This is Milan.
This is a fashion e-Commerce
retailer,
based out of China they used
Lighthouse to make performance
improvements and progressive
app.
They improved the Lighthouse PWA
score by 57 points to 100.  They
improved the Lighthouse
performance score by 35 points
to a 65.
As a result of just making the
two improvements, they were able
to see a 10% increase in the
mobile conversion
rates as well as a 65% decrease
in their ad bounce rate.  So
pretty awesome stuff.  We also
know that on the Lighthouse
team, there is a lot to do to
make the product even better for
y'all to use.  So I will
summarize this as the top user
request.  So the first user
request we get especially from
people who are looking at the
Lighthouse report for the first
time is hey, like, can you make
this report easier to
understand?  Because it is kind
of cluttered, kind of confusing.
So that is one request we get.
The other request we get is I
love Lighthouse, but the
performance metrics and scores
change from run to run, even if
I am running in the same way.
Can you make Lighthouse more
stable?  And the third is I love
Lighthouse, it is awesome.  But
I don't want to run it on one
site.  I want to run it on
hundreds of thousands of sites.
Can I conduct a bolt analysis
using Lighthouse?
Today I will walk you through
how to do all three of those
with stuff we're working on.  Go
to the first one, to make the
report easier to understand.
We take this concern seriously
and we did an entire usability
study earlier part of this year.
Taking results from the study,
we came up with the new UI,
which you can see today.  You
can see this in the mobile web
Sandbox, if you try using
Lighthouse there.
The personal favorite did which
you
can't see from the screen shot,
when you
hover over the metrics, a tool
comes up,
if you don't see first CPU idle,
you can get a better
understanding of what it is.
This is launches with 3.0, which
we are planning on releasing
this week.
You can get 3.0 today, through
MPM, with Lighthouse at next.
It is the default way to run
Lighthouse on the Chrome
extension, which we are
releasing later this week and
coming to dev tools in Chrome
68.  If you want more
information about
everything else coming in 3.0,
checkout that doc over there.  I
will run through more updates,
but that has all the
information.
Let's move on to talking about
the second concern folks have
with Lighthouse which is around
the performance score.
These are scores that I got for
a website that I will not name.
For their performance score of
their site.  This was just
consecutive runs one after the
other.  This is a problem we
have known for a very long time.
And there is -- we had a
concerted
effort since last year to work
on it, it is called project
lantern.
It has the best logo ought of
all the logos created.  To
understand what it does, I want
to tell you how Lighthouse
computes metrics today.  When
Lighthouse is computing the
performance metrics of the site,
it is throttling your page,
trying to emulate it as if it
were a user on a mobile
device on a 3G  network and
computing it.
Landern changes this, it tries
to estimate based on the inputs
you give it based on what
network and device the user is
on to compute the performance
metrics itself.
Using this approach, we have
seen a 50% reduction in the
amount of variability in the
Lighthouse
performance score while
maintaining
accuracy with the dev tools
throttling.  It reduce the
amount of time to warm
up and run Lighthouse by 50%,
which is annoying to some
people.
You might ask, how does lantern
do this stuff?  I will give you
a high, broad level walk through
of how it does what it does.
The first thing lantern does is
gets a static list of the assets
that are necessary in order to
render your page.  In this
extremely contrived example,
it is the index in HTML, along
with the blocking, Java script,
it knows the weight, it takes
into act the RTT, the time to
transport one packet based -- in
this case 150 milliseconds.
This number is estimated based
on two variables on the right,
which it is the
network throughput and CPU
throttling.
Using the RTT and knowing the
size of the assets required to
be transferred in
order to render the site,
lantern can predict the
performance metrics.  You can
see the things to occur in
order to open the network are
taken into account.
It gives a high level of how
lantern works.  It is the
default for Lighthouse starting
with 3.0.
If you want to get started on
understanding lantern and using
it, get 3.0, the way I showed
you earlier.
I want to move on to talking
about scale.  Specifically
scaling Lighthouse.  And today,
I'm happy to announce that we've
been working on an API, the
Lighthouse API, an API to get
results from any URL.  I am
excited.  I think it unlocks use
cases people have been talking
to us about.
The first is it allows you to
build dashboards, contract your
home page, landing page and site
pages you might have.
Second, you can build tools on
top of Lighthouse and integrate
Lighthouse into whatever
continuous integration test feed
that you might have.
Finally, conduct large-scale
data analysis using Lighthouse
itself.  This is an overview of
what the API currently looks
like, for those of you who use
Lighthouse on the command line,
you can see it is pretty similar
to what the command line would
give you, except
we made it more ergonomic for
people's use.
The current status of the API is
it is in private beta.  We are
working with a couple of
partners to iterate on the
definition.  If you are
interested in intrigued by the
API I will have more information
later on in the talk on for the
access.
We're planning to launch it as a
free public Google service very
soon.
I want to take a little bit of
time why I am personally excited
about I API.  One of the things
I was mentioning earlier, we
have all the tools and we're
trying to align our tooling
story together, but one of the
problems we've
had in that is we don't have a
common
infrastructure that all the
tools can rely upon in order to
align the tools.  I think that
Lighthouse API gets us one step
closer, because it kind of
creates a pipeline that a bunch
of other tools can use in order
to align all the tools together.
I'm sure you will see more
tooling alignment initiatives in
the future.
So now you might be wondering,
as an external developer, who
can Lighthouse do for me?  I
want to tell you what two
partners
did with the Lighthouse API.
The first is mobify.
That is a platform to build
customer first shopping
experiences through apps and
mobile pages.
Some include can comb, car
parts.
As part of the lan comb, and the
analytics dashboard for business
leaders and retailers to monitor
performance and customer
engagement.
In order to make this process
easier in monitoring customer
performance they
integrated API into the dash
board, this is what it looks
like.  This helps the business
leaders to get an understanding
of the metrics reported to what
they might care about.
This is a live example of how
one of
mobify's clients, a letting
British retailer actually uses
the data provided by the API to
correlate the scores with bounce
rate, a metric they care about.
I'm excited for this use case
because I think it helps
business leaders understand the
return of investment that
they're getting for putting work
into
performance and makes it that
much more obvious.
So the second partner that I
want to
talk about is duda.
They're currently over 12
million sites built using duda.
Duda wants to make sure whatever
sites are being built that
they're fast.  Especially as
they add new functionality to
the platform.  They're actually
using Lighthouse to add
progressive web app functional
to the platform.
Now with API this is easy
because they integrate
Lighthouse into the continuous
integration pipeline.
Duda uses check ins to do the
continuous integration test.
They added Lighthouse as a
component.
They're able to set threshold
for the developer, if it doesn't
meet the threshold, they fail to
build, in this case, a build is
failed and they dig into the
report to understand what audits
are passing, what are failing.
Again, this unlocks a use case
we heard from a lot of
developers with Lighthouse,
which is once you do all the
work, to make your site fast and
how do you keep it that way?
I think API makes it easy,
because you
can integrate it into whatever
continuous integration system
you have, duda planned once it
is launched to
release the plug in to the
checkins it is that much easier
to get started from Lighthouse.
I want to thank duda and mobify
for all the work to pull the
demos together.  They're
awesome.
I'm even more excited to see
what you do with the API.
If you are intrigued to the
demos and you want early access
to the API, sign up on the
interest form over here.
A member of the team will be in
touch with you very, very
shortly.
I wait until the phones go down.
Oh, okay.
Still going.  Awesome.
Okay.  So I'm going to wrap up
the talk.  Rick and I talked
about a lot of stuff.
I want to wrap it up with some
key take aways, of which there
is only one.  But the main take
away that I hope you get is that
there are two kinds of
performance data that we care
about.  There is lab data and
field data.  Lab data is
essentially data that you
collect in a control lab-like
environment, helpful for
drilling down into specific
performance information
and getting granular and
nitty-gritty.  Field data is
useful if you want to understand
the source of truth about the
performance of the site.  It is
essentially data you collect to
understand how real users are
experiencing the performance of
the site.
Lighthouse is a tool that can
give you
lab data and the Chrome user
experience report Rick talked
about can give you field data.
A talk by a project manager
wouldn't be complete without
action items.
I will list four.  Take out your
phone, take pictures, I will go
through this quickly.
The first action item is about
input
delay, the main activity input
in the wild.
If you are interested in how
real users are dealing with the
interactivity of the website,
check first input delay.
Here is a link to the dock and
the polyfill.  Give us feedback.
The second is around speed tools
interview.
This is a tool to help you
understand what tool to use when
you think about the performance
of your site.
Finally, the Chrome user
experience report Rick talked
about.  If you want to
understand how to baseline your
performance statistics, do
competitor analyses and all the
really
cool use cases, checkout Chrome
experience report.  And always
making it better.
Finally, Lighthouse, you can run
it on
the browse if you use Chrome.
Here's the early interest form.
And that's it.  So thank you so
much, everyone, for coming.  I
know it is like 5:00 p.m. on a
Wednesday.  So really appreciate
all your time.
We are going to stick around for
a little bit if you have
additional questions, but you
can find us at Sandbox G.
We'll be there most of tomorrow.
Come say I had.
I'm Vinamrata, have a great rest
of your I/O.  Thank you so much.
>> RICK VISCOMI: Thank you.
(Applause) .
>> Thank you for joining this
session.  Brand ambassadors will
assist with
directing you through the
designated exits.
We'll make room for those who
registered for the next session.
If you registered for the next
session in this room, we ask
that you please clear the room
and return via the registration
line outside.
Thank you.
(Session concluded)
.
Droid Jetpack easy background
processing with Work Manager.
>> At this time, please find
your seat.  Our session will
begin soon.
>> SUMIR KATARIA: Hi, everyone.
My name is Sumir Kataria and
work on the Android team.  I
work with Architecture
Components
and I want to talk about
WorkManager and background
processing in general on
Android.
Let's talk about background
processing in 2018.  What are we
trying to do these days.
This morning, I was trying to
send a picture of my lovely wife
and beautiful son to the rest of
my family.  That is an example.
We're syncing logs, processing
data, syncing data.
That is work being done in the
background.  In Android, there
are a lot of different ways to
do this work.  Here's a lot of
them.
You can do things on threads,
executors, using job scheduler,
async tasks, et cetera.  What
should you use, when should you
use it?
There is a lot of Android
battery optimizations we used
over the last couple of years.
We introduced doze mode and
Marshmallow.
We have had app stand by
buckets.  In Oreo we restricted
background services.  All of
these have to be taken care of
as a developer.
Finally, we always have to worry
about backwards compatibility.
If you want to reach 90% of
Android
devices you need to have at
least Kit Kat.  Given all of
this, what tools do you use,
when do you use them?  And the
trick behind this is that you
have to look at the types of
background
work you are doing.
I like to split this up in two
axes.  The vertical is the
timing of the work.  Does the
work need to be done right when
specified or can it wait for a
little bit so if your device
enters doze mode, you can still
do it after that.
Also, on the horizontal axis
here, how important is the work?
Does the work only need to be
done while your apps in the
foreground, or does it
absolutely need to be done at
some point?
So for example, if you're taking
a bit map and you decide you
want to extract a
color from it and update your UI
with it, that is an example of
foreground only work.  You don't
care once the user hits home
or back, the work is irrelevant.
If you are sending logs, you
always want that to happen, that
is an example of guaranteed
execution.  So for things that
are best effort, you really want
to use things like
thread pools, RX Java, core
routines.
For things that require exact
timing and guaranteed execution,
you want to use a foreground
service.  So an example of this
would be that the user hits a
button and you want to
process a transaction and update
the UI and the state of the app
based on that.  That needs a
foreground service.  That cannot
be killed by the system while
that's happening.
This fourth category is very
interesting.  You want
guaranteed execution, but you're
okay if it happens later.  Doze
mode can kick in.
There is a variety of ways to
solve it.
On your API you will use job
scheduler.
If you want to go farther back,
use Firebase job descriptor.
You will probably use alarm
managers and broadcast
receivers.
If you want to target all of
those things you will use a mix
of those things and that is a
lot of API.  A lot of work to be
done.
WorkManager falls here.
It is guaranteed execution
that's deferrable.
So WorkManager let's talk about
its features.  I mentioned
guaranteed execution is also
constrained aware.
So if I want to upload that
photo I talked about, I want to
do it only when I have a
network.
That is the constraint.  It is
also respectful of the system
background restrictions.
If your app is in doze mode, it
won't execute.  It won't wake up
the phone just to do this work.
It is backwards compatible, with
or without Google Play services.
The API is per able.  If you
have queued some work, you can
check what is the state?  Is it
running?  Has it succeeded or
failed?  These are things you
can find out with WorkManager.
It is also chainable.
You can create graphs of work.
You can have work A depending on
work
A and
C, which depends on work D.
It is opportunistic, it will
execute the work in the process
when the constraints are met
without needing job scheduler to
intervene or call you and wake
you up.  It doesn't work for job
scheduler to batch your work if
your process is up and running
already.  Let's talk about the
basics and talk through the
code.
So I just described the example
I want to upload that photo.  So
how would I do that using
WorkManager?  Let's talk about
the core classes.  There is the
worker class.  This is the class
that does the work.
This is where you will write
most of the business logic and
there is a work
request class, which comes in
two flavors one-time work
request or things that need to
be done once and periodic
work request for recurring work.
These will both take a worker.
I will show you now.
So here's the upload photo
worker.  It extends the worker
class.  It overrides the do work
method.  This is a method that
will run in the background.
We'll take care of that on the
background thread, you don't
need to put it in the background
thread.
See, simply do your work, this
is done photo synchronously.
In this case, let's say we
succeeded.
The worker has three values,
success,
failure, fairly obvious and
retry says I encountered a
transient error.
The device lost network connect
so retry me in a little bit.
Now that I have this, I can
create a one-time work request
using the upload
photo worker and then I can
queue it using WorkManager in
get instance in queue.  Soon
after it is queued, it is
running, you will upload your
photo.
I just talked about this.
What if you lose connectivity
before this, or whatever if you
never had connectivity, you want
to use constraints in this case.
An example of the constraint
here you want to use is make a
constraints builder and you say
set required network to be
connected.  You need a connected
network.
Connection, you build, it you
also set the constraints on the
request that you just built.
By simply doing this and queuing
it, you make sure it runs only
when your network is connected.
So let's say we want to absorb
the work now that we have done
it.  I want to show a spinner
while this work is executing and
I want to hide the spinner when
it is done.  How would I do
that?
As I said, I will enqueue this
request.
Then I can say get status by
I.D.
on WorkManager using the request
Each request has an I.D.
This is a live data of the work
status.  If you Architecture
Components, live
data is a life cycle aware
observable.  Now you can hook
into the observable.  You can
say when the work is finished,
hide the progress bar.
So what is the work status
object you were looking at, at
the live data?  It has an I.D.
The same as a request.  And it
has a state.
The state is the current state
of execution.
There are six values here in
queue, running, succeeded,
failed, locked, canceled.
We'll talk about the last two
later.  So let's move a step up
in concept here.  Let's talk
about chaining work.  I promise
that you can actually make
directed graphs of work.
How would you do that?  Let's
say this is the problem.  I'm
uploading a video.  It is a huge
video.
I want to compress it and upload
it.
These are time-intensive things.
Say I have two workers compress
photo worker, upload photo
worker, both defined to the do
the things I said.  You can make
work requests from them, you can
say WorkManager, begin with
compressed work, then upload
work and enqueue it.  It ensures
the compressed work executes
first.  Once it is successful,
then upload work goes.
If you were to write this out,
because that was a very fluent
way of writing it, what happens
behind the scenes here
is that begin with returns of
work continuation.  And work
continuation has a method called
then, that also returns a work
continuation, a different one.
So you're using that to create
the fluent API.  You can use the
work continuation and pass them
around, if you want, et cetera.
So let's say I'm uploading
multiple photos.
No one takes only one photo of
their child.
How would I upload all of these
in parallel?
Well, say I've got work request
for all of them.
I can literally say dot enqueue
and upload all of them.  These
are all eligible for running in
parallel.
They may not actually run in
parallel
and the executor being used, all
of that, but they could be.
Let's choose a more complex
example.  You want to filter
your photo.  You want to apply
some gray scale filter or some
filter to them, you want to
compress them, then upload them.
How do you do this?
WorkManager makes it simple.
First you say do all the filter
works in parallel.
After those have all completed
successfully, then do the
compression work.
After those have completed, and
that completed successfully,
then you do the upload work and
don't forget to enqueue at the
end.
So we have talked about all of
that, but there is a key concept
I want to cover that is very
much related to chaining.
This is inputs and outputs.  So
let's talk about this problem
that I have here.
It is a map reduce.
It is really a good way of
explaining a map reduce is to
give an example.  I love
reading.
I have loved reading Sherlock
Holmes novels since I was a kid.
I was thinking the other day,
there is a specific way of
writing.  What are the top 10
words he uses in his books?  How
would I figure that out.
I would go through each book,
count the occurrence of each
word, combine the data, sort it
to find the top 10 of those.
This is a distributed problem
that we can call a map reduce.
And for inputs and outputs, the
common unit of operation here is
a data.  The data is a simple
class that is a key value map
under the hood.
The keys are strings, the values
are primitives and strings and
the array versions of each.
This is a bundle or parsable,
but it's its own thing.
It is limited to 10 kilobytes in
size.  We'll go more into that
part later.
How do we create a data?
In cogland, you can make a map.
You map the -- that is the novel
I will look at.  I will convert
it to a work data.
This is a data object.  Once a
create the work request builder,
I can set the input data on it.
This is the input data on that
map.
Inside the worker, I can
retrieve this by getting the
input method, and I can
get the string for the file
names, now I have the file name.
I can say count all the word
occurrences in this file name,
that is a method I have written
somewhere else.  I can return my
success.  You don't want to do
just that, you actually want to
have outputs, right?
You have done all this work.
It should do something.  It
should be an output for it.
Say that method that we have
returns a map of words to their
occurrences.
We can convert that map to a
work data and we can call a
method called set output data
that sets this data.
So get input data, set output
data.
The key observation to know here
is the worker output is the
output for its children.
What happens is the five top 10
words
worker, which goes next, its
input data is coming from the
previous worker.
So in this case, you can pass
the data
all the way through, find the
top 10 words and return out.
The data flow for one book
becomes like this.  Count all
the word occurrences in that
book.  I will pass it to the
find top 10 words worker.
Its input data will be whatever
I pass through and it will do
the sorting or whatever it needs
to do.  But here's a really
tricky thing.
What happens when you have
multiple books?
What is the input for find top
10 words worker?
You are passing multiple pieces
of data, but I have only been
able to get one input data.
What happens to the rest of
them?  How do they combine?
For that, you want to look at
input mergers.
Input merger is a class that
combines data for multiple
sources into one data object.
And we provide two
implementations out of the box,
overriding input merger, which
is the default and array
creating input merger.  You can
also create your own.
Let's talk about these two.
First, overriding input mergers.
We have two data objects here.
Each with their own keys and
values.  And what does
overriding input merger do?  It
first takes the first piece of
data
and just puts everything in a
new data object.  It is an exact
copy of this.  It takes a second
piece of data and copies it
over.  So overriding anything
that is the same key.
So in this case, the name Alice
becomes Bob and the age of 30
becomes three days.  Not that
the date changed type.  The
number became a string here.
The scores key was new, it just
got added.  Note if we did this
in reverse, instead of Bob, you
would have Alice as the final
output.  So this is something a
little tricky.
You want to make sure overriding
input merger is the right tool
for the job, but it is very
simple.  What about array
creating input merger?
This is the one that takes care
of the collision case.
So in this case, let's go
through this key by key.
The name becomes an array of
Alice and
Bob, color becomes Singleton
array of blue because it is only
defined in one of them.
Scores, notice that there is one
integer and one array of
integers, these combine and
order is not specified, all the
values come through.  What
happens for age?
There is an integer and there is
a spring.  -- string.
This is an exception, we expect
it to be the same basic value
type.
So let's go back to that example
I was telling you about Sherlock
Holmes.
Implicitly, there is an input
merger before this stage.  We
combine all of that data.
Which input merger do we want to
use.  We don't want to throw
away the calculation we have
done.  We want to use an array
creating merger to preserve all
of the data and get it through.
How do we do that?  We say set
input merger on the request
builder off the find top 10
words and it creates the array
data input merger.  You say
begin with account words worker,
do the top 10 words worker and
then enqueue.
For example, if the first book
had 10
instances of the word Sherlock,
five Watson, 30 of elementary,
you will get arrays like this.
10, 12, Sherlock, elementary,
30, 5.
You would sum that up, sort
them, find the top 10.
That is the output.  I just said
that is your output.
You can actually observe the
output in the work status using
the live data.  You can get that
output data.
That is super useful because you
can put it in the UI.  How do
you cancel work?  I decided to
send up a picture, I am like
wait this is not the picture I
meant to send up.
How do you cancel that upload?
Very simple.  You say cancel
work by I.D. but do note
cancellation is best effort.
The work may have already
finished.
These are all asynchronous
things that may be happening in
the background before you have
the chance to do the cancel work
it may be already running or
finished.
It is best effort.
Okay.  Let's talk more about
tags.
Tags are solving this problem.
I.D.
s are auto generated not human
readable.
They're under the hood.  You
can't understand them.
They're not useful for
debugging.  What work is
running, I don't know a big
number.  I don't know what that
is.  Tags solve this issue.
Tags are readable ways to
identify your work.  Tags are
strings identified by you.
Each request can have zero or
more tags.  You can query or
cancel work by tag.
Look at an example.
So I used to work on the G plus
team here.
The G plus apps are multilog in.
Each user could do several kinds
of background work.  You can get
favors, preferences.
So if you have three users
logged in on your phone, they're
doing two kinds of work, you
have six things happening, how
do you identify what you are
looking at, at any given time?
You can use tags.
So for example, in this work
request builder, you can add
tags to say this is
user one, this is the get
favorites operation.
You can actually identify that
work.
If you want to look at the
status, you can say give me the
work for user one.
This will return a list of work
statuses as a live data.
Each tag will correspond to more
than one work request.
This is a list of work statuses.
Similarly, you can also cancel
all work by tag.
Cancellation is best effort,
again.  Cancel all of one
particular kind of
work in this case.
Tags are also useful for a
couple of other reasons.
Tags, name space your type of
work, like I told you.  You can
have tags for the kinds of
operations you're doing, get
favorites, get preferences, et
cetera.
But they also name space
libraries and modules.
A library owner or module owner,
you
should tag your work so you can
get it later.
So you have a library and you
move to a new library in the
app.  Maybe you can cancel all
the work you had, you can cancel
all the work by your tag.
Always use tags when using a
library.  Work status also has
tags available.
So if you are looking at a work
status you can get the tags for
that work and see what you
yourself called it in the past
when you enqueued it.
One more thing I wanted to talk
about is unique work.
Unique work solves a few
different problems.
One problem apps have is
syncing.
You want to sync 12 to 24 hours
and sync when the language
changes.
Maybe you have a version of your
data in a different language.
You want to sync at that point,
too.  You are doing all the
syncing, but you
want one sync active at a time.
You don't want four running.
Which one wins?  You don't know.
You just want one.  Unique work
can solve this.  It is a chain
of work that can be given a
unique name.  You can enqueue
query, cancel using that name
and there can only be one chain
of work with that name.
Take a look at sync example.
If I say begin you
-- unique work, with my name,
say sync in this case.  The next
argument is the existing work
policy.
If there is work with this name,
"sync" what should I do with it?
In this case, I say keep it.  I
want to keep the existing work,
ignore what I am doing now.  The
next argument is actually the
work request, in this case a
sync go.  You enqueue it.  If
you there is work with the name
sync already in flight, it will
keep that.  If there isn't, it
will enqueue this and execute
it.
This is how you do your syncs.
Here at Google, we love chat
apps.
Maybe you are updating your chat
status.  You say I am bored.
And 10 seconds later, I'm
watching TV.  I'm bored again,
I'm going to sleep.
You are in a bad network
connection state.  You have bad
Wi-Fi, maybe the first thing
hasn't gone through.
The second one should win and
the third one should win over
that.  You want to make sure the
last one wins.  How do you solve
this?
This is a simple function, you
don't need to read the rest of
it.  It is the last line you
care about.  It is begin unique
work.  It is your name is update
status and you choose the
replace option.
Replace cancels and deletes any
in-flight options of the name.
The last one does win.
If you have two update status
calls, the last one will win.
Finally, I love music, I love
the food fighters.  I was
building a playlist with all
their songs, there is a lot of
songs.  150 or 200 sounds.  I
was doing all of this.
I was adding a song, shuffling
two songs around, moving
something from the bottom of the
list, deleting a song because I
had it somewhere else.
These are all things I want to
do using WorkManager, but how
would I do that?  These all have
to execute in order.
So since the order is important,
we
provide the ability to use the
append existing work policy that
says do this
work at the end of the list of
update playlist operations.  So
just append this to the end of
the thing, so everything else
must successfully execute before
this executes.
So you can add operations to the
end.
So existing work policy, as a
summary, there are three types.
Keep, replace, append.
A few notes about periodic work.
It works similarly to everything
you have seen so far.  Just a
couple of notes on it.  The
minimum period length is the
same as job scheduler.  It is 15
minutes.
It is still subject to doze mode
and OS
background rec STRIKZs --
restrictions like other work we
talk about.  We can't have
delays.  That makes good API
sense.  It is much more
reasonable to think of it in
those terms.
All right.  So we have talked a
lot about code.  Let's talk
about how it all works under the
hood.
So you have got a work you
enqueue it, we store it in the
database.  What happens after
that?  Well, if the work is
eligible for execution, we send
it to the executor right away.
This executor, you can specify
it, but we provide one that is
default.  But let's say that
your process gets killed.
Well, what happens then?
How is it work woken up, how
does it run again.
API plus, send it to scheduler,
you wake up the process, go to
the same executor, that is where
it runs.
If it is an older device, and
you use Firebase job dispatcher
and use optional dependency, you
can send it to Firebase job
dispatcher, same thing,
invokeinvokes IPC, runs it on
the executor.  If you don't have
that or not using a Google Play
service device, you are using
something else, we have a custom
alarm manager and broadcast
receiver implexation.  Same
thing, using IPC, wakes up the
app when the time is right and
runs the job.
A couple implementation details.
Job scheduler, Firebase job
dispatcher through Google Play,
they provide
central load balancing manager
for execution.
If every app on the device is
trying to run jobs they'll load
balance them
and make sure you are not
running too much work on your
device and burning up your
battery.  The alarm manager
implementation
cannot do that because it is
only a variation of your own
app.
Your concepts like content URI
are only available at the levels
they're introduced at.
Those manages will be marked
with the appropriate API level.
We have pending wake locks.
This is true for the alarm
manager.
Don't take wake locks in your
workers you don't need to do
that, we take care of it for
you.
Finally, let's talk about
testing.  You want to test this
app.  We provide a testing
library.  It has a synchronous
executor.
Use WorkManager as normal to
enqueue your requests.  We
provide a class called test
driver
which executes enqueued work
with constraints.
We can pretend the constraint is
met.
Periodic and display measures
are coming.  We don't have them
yet.  If you want to look at the
code, you can use the task force
manager and get the test driver.
Create and enenqueue your work
as you would with a constraint
in this case.  You can tell the
test driver, hey, all
constraints are met for this
work.
Your work executes at that
point, synchronously and you can
verify the state of your app and
make sure everything is right.
I will want to talk about best
practices before I end here.
It is very important to know
when to use WorkManager.
WorkManager is for tasks that
can
survive process death, it can
wake up
your app and your app's process
to do the work.
It is okay to use it to upload
media to the server also okay to
parse data and store it in the
database.  It is not okay for
the example I gave
earlier, extracting the pallet
color from an image, and
uploading an image.  That is
foreground only.
It is not only when you parse
data and update a view.
It is not work that needs to use
WorkManager.  It doesn't need to
survive process death.
It is not okay to process
payment transactions in it, if
they care about timing right
then.
If you click bye and you want to
update the state of the app,
that needs something else.  The
last one needs a foreground
service, the other two may use
thread
pools or RX.
Also WorkManager is not your
DataStore.
Instances are limited to 10
kilobytes.
It is meant for light,
intermediate transportation of
information.
You can file your eyes or key
database if you want.
Put simple information to update
your UI.
If you want to use full
DataStore, I recommend using
room.  They would be happy I'm
saying this.  It is an awesome
database.
Finally, be opportunistic with
your work.  The filter compress
upload example again.
The reason these are not one big
job is because they all have
different constraints.
So they can execute at different
times.
Say I'm getting on an airplane
and I upload a bunch of images
and running this chain of work.
I go into airplane mode, maybe I
don't have network for the next
12 hours because I'm flying
across the world.  The other
work can still execute and it
should.  If you architect like
this, you can do that.  This
also, by the way, makes your
code more testable.  You can
write a test for filtering that
isn't conflated with compression
and upload.
All right.  I want to talk about
a few next steps for you.
If you need to reach us and talk
about
WorkManager, we are in the
Android
Sandbox, just behind us, I
think, over here.  That is more
information on the official
developer website about
WorkManager.
These are all the Gradle
dependencies.  The first one is
required.
The second one is if you use
Firebase job dispatcher include
that.
A testing library and of course
cogland extensions as well.
WorkManager is part of the
Architecture Components in
Android Jetpack.  And we have a
bunch of talks here.
Tomorrow, navigation controller
8:30 a.m.  I hope you make it
there.
And thanks for being part of
this talk.
We look forward to hearing back
from you soon.  Thank you.
(Applause) .
>> Thank you for joining this
session.
Brand ambassadors will assist in
helping you exit through the
designated exits.
We are making room for those
registered for the next session.
If you are registered for the
next session, we ask that you
clear the room and return via
the registration line outside.
Thank you.
(Session concluded)
.
What's new with the Android
build system.
>> At this time, please find
your seat.  Our session will
begin soon.
>> XAVIER DUCROHET: Good
afternoon, my
name is Xavier Ducrohet.
>> JEROME DOCHEZ: My name is
Jerome Dochez.
SOID we'll talk about the
improvements in Android since
last year.  It shipped out in
the fall.
The whole concept is all of the
variants of the module can
depend on other modules.
Debugs on debugs and release on
release.
It is working well with it on
each side.
We have seen a lot of
developers, over
the last six, nine months, see
an enormous stage like this and
don't know what to do with it.
We want to explain what is going
on,
help you solve such a problem.
First thing to look at, this
line does not publish library.
It is the project that is
consuming it
is in record by project
app the name of the
configuration.
It is the run time plus pass.
The error is able to find a
matching configuration.  The way
it is working really, the
library project is publishing a
bunch of
artifact for different buy in at
the integrations.
It has attributes associated
with it so it can match it.  It
is a request with similar
attributes, trying to do a
mapping and needs one exact map.
Here it can't find a match.  If
you go through the
configuration, you know, you can
look at all the attributes and
basically, by process of
elimination find out what it
needs.
What we see is two have an API
used by
combile test and the other two
are run time.
The attribute, they request Java
run
time, some use Java API, so we
can
ignore them.
If you more atribe tributes --
it is on both sides, we can
ignore it, we use to match
different type of plug in,
versus library and features,
just so ignore it.
The other
one buy out attribute.  It is
one you can ignore.
We find final attribute, which
is incompatible, we ask for
staging, it is finding other
values.
The name of type of attribute
here, it is, you know, the key
part.
It is basically
self-explanatory, this is the
build type attribute, we are
request being staging, it is not
finding it.  It means the
library does not have the build
type, you can train it there or
use the DSL to cradle for that.
You say if the staging is not
found, use debug.
You have the same exact
principle if you
have a missing dimension value.
Here, the error message is
different
because there are multiple
flavors, this
is the flavor dimension, same
problem.
Not finding trial when you look
for it the fix is the same.  We
do that on the consuming side,
the app side of the library.  If
it is a library that depend on
the
library, you can have the
consuming
side another type of problem, it
says cannot choose between the
following configuration.
It will find compatible matches.
It will only show the two
configuration that are not
matching, tell hide the others.
That is easier.  If you look at
it, there are attributes that
are compatible, you signal them.
You are down to the two.
It says it found an attribute on
the library side, but not
consumed by the consumer.
What happen is the library has a
dimension not defined in the app
of the consuming module and
doesn't know how to choose this
one.  It has the flavor
dimension in the app or
consuming model or go and say,
you
know, missing dimension
strategy, name of the flavor
dimension, name of the value.
All it is doing, really, is
adding the attribute to the
request.
You can add this either to the
default
config, which is all the buy
ins.
To a specific flavor or to a
particular variant.
>> JEROME DOCHEZ: Thank you.
Talk about some of the notable
changes
we have introduced in the
variation pipeline.
The first thing we have changed
lately is aapt2.
This is a new incremental
divider.  This is dividing into
the two phases.
The phase where it changes
resources into binary format.
And there is a final linking
phase where it will have the
final I.D.
If you want to use the latest
platform features, use aapt2.
In theory, it is compatible with
AAPT1.  It is stricter.
You might run into issues from 1
to aapt2.  We have given you a
flag so you can use it if you
have issues.
You should be aware the issues
may not be in aapt2 itself.  It
may be in your project.  So you
should find bugs, if you find
issues with aapt2, but you
should do your homework first,
look into maybe the problem is
in my project, so let's look,
maybe you have invalid
resources, and reference stuff.
Aapt2 will catch those.
So we're going to phase ought
AAPT1 soon, so it is important
that you switch
and find bugs, if you still find
some.
Next thing is desugar.
This is a tool to use old
synthetic
sugar that was in Java 8.  We
have two different versions.
The first version was external
process.
It used a lot of resource, was
slow.
With V8, it is integrated into
the pipeline.  It is better.  It
is faster.  Again, we're going
to phase out the old version in
theory, you should all be
switching to the integrated
version, shouldn't be seeing any
difference.
If you do, please file a bug.
It is probably our fault this
time, probably not your fault.
File a bug.
We will phase out of the old
external
process version soon.
Talking about dex.  It is
interested in 3.
.  It is default from
3.1.
The bugs are responsive at
fixing issues.
Again, we're phasing out old DX
soon.  We would like you to be
capable of building your
applications, file bugs.
We introduced 8, which is the
shrinker, but it is like a
different
thing than it used to
be, 8 takes over the entire
pipeline from class files to dex
files.
It is the desugar,
minimization and dex fall
files.
If you use it, see if it works
well.  File bugs, we will stop
supporting the
old shrinkers, not soon, but
midterm, I would say.
These are the flags you can use
to
enable or disable R8 and D8.
Use this if you run into
trouble, also file bug, okay?
Let's talk about the performance
we know well it is a subject you
are extremely interested in, so
are we.  One of the problem we
have is that we have a lot of
trouble reproducing issues that
may happen in the (?).
We don't have that many
applications internally to use.
However, here is an example
using the nest mobile app.
You can see a net will build as
improved about 13%
from 3 to 3.1.  And then from
3.2.  This is if the keep the
same features.  Not changing the
application, just the plug in.
If you have the Java A, things
vary, obviously.
Now, if you look a little deeper
at performance, things are more
complicated.  In particular,
when you look at incremental
builds you can see Java C
for the full build was 10 to 15%
of the build.
In incremental build, it jumps
to a
really bad 38% of the overall
build type.
Really, we can see that in
incremental
scenario, Java is the dominating
vactor.  It is not incremental
because people are using
annotation processors and so far
they're not incremental capable.
So we started a joint
application with an note, it is
called incap.
It is ready, shaped shipped in
4.7.  Now we're trying to make
all the
annotation process tors to be
incap capable.
If you have the processes, make
them incap capable.  It is not
complicated.
For the simple processors, it
will generate something from one
source, it
is a need to see the entire
world, adding few manifest
entries.  That is simple.
That will eventually, in all of
the annotation processes are
incap capable,
we'll be able to switch the
compilation
to be incremental, that will
have a huge
impact on the performance of the
incremental builds.
(Applause) .
>> Thank you.
Let's talk about Jetpack.  You
have heard about it a lot.  How
does it work?
Let's take the first example --
if you
have to the pure AndroidX
project.  It has the old
support, what you do is
use the refactoring tool in
studio to move the new stuff.
One issue is we add some
dependency to
the project, you use legacy,
data
binding, we will add
automatically, the multidex to
elaborate.
If you move to the pure AndroidX
world
where you now suddenly have the
AndroidX constraint instead of
the old support,
we need to know that we must use
the
AndroidX multidex library.
We need an indication of which
one we want to inject.
You need to tell the plug in,
this is for this flag, which
version you want us to use.
So if you want to move to
AndroidX world, use this flag.
If you are in a hybrid world,
which is who most likely will
happen to most people.
Yes, you moved your application,
all
the projects to use the AndroidX
stuff, you use an external
library that you have no control
over, it uses the old libraries,
you have no choice or control
about the sources, what can you
do?  We will provide a build
time translation facility that
will just basically change
automatically the
dependency from the old support
to the new one.
And will change the collaborate
itself by changing all the
import statements to the new
ones.
This is not like we will publish
the
library, but locally you can
have the illusion of the pure
world where everybody is
depending on the AndroidX
library.
There is a flag
jetifyjetifier.
>> XAVIER DUCROHET: Let's talk
about the app bundle.  We'll
tell you some greater things.
The first thing on the
application plug in, not the
library or feature plug in, but
the application plug in, on top
of the tasks you see here, we
have bundle tasks.
You can quickly without change,
go and
build a bundle, remember the,
bundle is a way to apply to the
Play Store, get
out of the bugs, with the API
and smaller (?) Time.
Locally, you can build an APK
the way the Play Store does it
in the APK.  If you want to
verify something, saying I have
a device, I don't want to build
an APK directly.
I want to build an APK the way
the Play Store would from the
bundle.  You can do that.  The
site is more involved than
directly building the APK.
You first build a bundle, then
use the
bund will -- bundle tool to
build a bundle, and then based
on the device configuration, we
can create the APK.  In general,
we don't necessarily want
you to create that, you know,
manually using the greater task,
however, a lot
of studio Android cannot use
that flow when you need it.
For example, the instant task,
if you
have the features it will build
the Pacific.
If you create I can nammic
features -- dynamic feature,
which we will talk about upon it
will go through the bundle
to make sure we can install on
on any device.
If you have a dynamic feature
and you
install on device, with the API
less
than 21, it needs to be done
together to install it.  We
don't want to be different than
the Play Store.
We want to be the same as the
Play Store.
If you try to run tests from the
line, the coding check, it will
go to the APK.
It will work later to add the
ability to run the test in the
bundle to simulate better
exactly the type of APK
that are created by the Play
StoreStore.
Deploying from studio, you have
a choice, directly from APK or
APK from the vendor.
Here the run configuration
inside studio has a check box to
check.  We recommend to not
check it when you do your
regular development.  You know,
as we saw earlier, building
an APK from the bundle is much
more complicated than building
it directly.  When you deploy
from studio, we look at the
device you want to target, and
then we inject that information
into Gradle.
And if you have the X, to take a
while
to build, when to device 21 or
above, we will use the index
that is faster.
We can't take that shock yet
when we build a bundle.
You have two, create one with
and one without the option.
You the APK as often as you can.
Use the other one only when you
have to, when you want to use
the APK developed by the Play
Store.  If you push to a device
that is pre-21, we're going to
use that option anyway and
always going through the
bundle, as soon as you have
dynamic features.
So you may may doing manual APK
and the DSL and the (?
) To compete conversion feet for
the APK that is generated.  If
you are doing that now and you
want to switch to the bundle,
you can erase all of the DSL.
It is unnecessary.
Nothing to do, you call the
bundle task, get your bundle,
you are done.  On the service
side we will do all of
this by density, API by default.
We have a DSL to allow to
disable it, if you are running
into problem.
We expect that would be very few
case where you need to do that,
but you have the able, if you
really have to, if you have that
also file a bug and talk to
the Play Store team, see if you
can sort it with them.
I mentioned dynamic feature
earlier.  What are dynamic
features?
They're small APK installed on
demand.
It is no need to install for
90%, have it for on-demand.
The way you organize the code,
it is in Gradle.  You have a
plug in called dynamic feature.
The layout is different compared
to
the library, normally in the
library, the application depend
on the library and refer to the
code of the library.  Here, the
features are actually sitting on
top and depend on the base.  We
can see horror the two base
feature, the two dynamic feature
in pluapply to dynamic feature.
Have a dependence on the project
app.  That is base one.
Those have to refer to the
dynamic feature.  It needs to
list them.  I will show you it,
it is complicated.  It is
unusual.  You need to list the
features.  It is the greater
path for all of the dynamic
features.
If you used instant app since
last year, it probably looks
similar.
It is you know, the feature plug
in, used for the features and
base feature,
except you have a small flag
using base feature equal true.
The base feature have to refer
to all of the features, using a
slightly different
DSL, which will probably migrate
to the dynamic feature version
soon, but you do
it now using the feature
configuration.
You probably heard about, you
know in
the future you can instance
enable that to have the caps
with the bundle.
This is why.
The feature plug in and dynamic
feature plug in are similar.
The features share probably over
95% of the code.  Extremely
similar.
So if you are architecturing
your app, switching would be the
same architecture with slightly
different plug ins.
If you are doing dynamic feature
now, allowing that to be in
instant app would be similar in
the future.
I mention bidirectional
dependancy where they need to
know about the base app
needs to know about the feature,
you
have the two module before, if
you are building APK, look no
more.
There is a bunch in each module.
What happens is the bundle task
belongs to the app bundle, the
app you use.
When you build the bundle, we
have to feature from the base
module and we need all the
dependency of the base module.
If you don't add to the base it
won't
show up in the bundle at all.
>> XAVIER DUCROHET: So when
developing
dynamic features, it is
penitentiary to understand
differents in the building.
There is differences in the
variant which won't change
between the base module, the
application I.D., version code,
version name, all of those
should be set in the base module
and we'll publish them back to
the features.
So they can be used in the task
when for instance, generating
the manifest or whatever.  It is
important to understand that you
set them in the base, you do not
repeat them in the features.  We
will automatically transfer
them.
Okay.
Let's talk about multidex.
So you are in a situation, not
using
features but doing the bundle
thing.  It is the same behavior.
Instead of shifting into MPK, it
is into a bundle which is
uploaded.  The dynamic delivery
will not do much.  It will take
the dex files and store them on
the device before execution.
So same behavior.  If you have
feature, not a lot of
difference.
Basically each feature can
develop and
goal can become itself a
multiple dex files.  Everything
is merged on to the base
module and you get all package
inside the bundle again.  Same
thing with our feature, it is
delivered on the phone, not a
big difference.
But default we enable the
multidexing.
Things get more complicated if
your
SDK is less than 21.
You need the multidex if you are
deploying on a device that is
25, but if
you are targeting and deploying
on 15,
we need to do something specific
for that.
What will happen is a dynamic
delivery will fuse all of the
text files into a
single one that will be
delivered.
This is important to realize,
even if none of the modules,
including the base module or
feature modules, if none of them
use multidexing itself, because
we combine those into a single
one, this
may actually go over the dex
limit and may require
multidexing.
So you need to manually enable
multidex in the base
application.
What that will do is basically
create the (?
) That it will ship along with
the dex files to the bundle.
The dynamic delivery will take
the bundle and be capable, if
you are trying
to deploy this on the 15 device,
it will
use the multimultidex for
diffusing and use the extended
dex correctly.
All right?  Shrinking and
obfusication.  It is the same as
before.
You set it on the base module
like the application.  You say
identify, enable, not a lot of
changes.
But how we implement it is
really, really different.  So
let's go through the motion
here.
First of all, this is only
supported
with R8, which is the shrinker I
talked about earlier.  What we
do, we take all the rules that
will be defined close to the
classes
they're applied to, the rules
and the features, we merge all
of them into a single one.
With the class files we field
this into R8.
R8 will create a combined dex,
big dex file is everything.
We will feed that dex file into
a dex leader which will split
the dex for the features and the
base.  It is a different
mechanism as before.
Now we have again, this dex is
shrinked, obfuse indicated.
It is two scenarios possible.
You are using the bundle or the
APK.
If you are using the bundle, it
is simple.
They're automatically
transferred into the bundle as
we saw earlier.
If you are using feature, it is
like the dex file published back
to the feature.
Then they will be packaged into
the APK.
All right.  It is a slightly
different mechanism as we have
seen in the past.  A lot of
going back and forth, we need
the dependency between features
and app.
>> XAVIER DUCROHET: We wanted to
talk about things that are not
introducted in 2.  We have been
working on it for a while.
We expect they will
ship soon.
We want to give you a heads up
and feedback as soon as
possible.  This is how we
process resources.
If you have a library
2, in the flow, the processing
of resources and just generate
another Java and nothing else.
So when this is consumed
by on or about library, library
1, it may be referring sources
from library 2.  To validate all
the resources references and
also with the overlimit
mechanism, we will merge the two
resource folder into a single
resource folder and process it,
generate another R class.  We
generate two.  One is for the
library itself, which everyone,
which contain all the resources
from library 1 to library 2.
And then we have another one,
which is
just a new version of the R
class generated by library two,
which is in case you want to
have tests you need the final
I.D. version of it.
That is consumed by an
application.  We cannot ask you
to do the same thing again.
We will remerge the app, library
one, library 2 and process all
of that.  And then generate the
final resource
binary format as well as all the
final classes that are needed by
the code from the app library 1
and 2.  As you can see, this is
not exactly efficient.  This is
probably one of the last
things that is very inefficient
in the way we build things.  The
resources from library 2 is
merged and processed three
times.  We generate a lot of
classes.  In fact, we're seeing
project with a few hundred
modules generating several
thousands of classes, which is
too many.
We need to fix this.  This is
the new flow we're working on
and what it looks like.
When we compile library 2, there
is binary resources.
We can't make it work with
aapt2.
We need aapt2 is the future.
We create the R class.
Rather than the source code so
we don't have to compile it.
When we depend on it, consume it
in library one, what we will do
is only process the resources of
that module.
Then we'll use the output of the
previous module, the same way,
basically, you use during Java
C.
It is mostly there to validate
the resource, and use the
packages that only contain the
resources.  There is no longer a
merge.  And the R class only of
that library.
That library R class only
contain the resources of that
library.  It does not contain
the resource I.D. of the
previous library and this one.
We don't merge those anymore.
When the app depends on library
1 and 2, it is the same.
It needs to merge to the final
one.  Create the final class.
You can see a lot less classes
and efficient.
You can see in the library 2 by
editing a string.
There is no reason to compile
library 1 again.  It is the
least of I.D.s that I need to
change against for reference is
exactly the same one.  No
changes.  So we can use the same
thing, like compilation
avoidance that we used and
we don't need to recompile
library 1 or the app, all we
have to do is the final link and
that's it.
We can do that also because the
R class for the app does not use
final I.D. any more.
Let's look at some of the impact
of the change.
So first, I said that the R
class of each module only
contained the (?) Of that
module, it doesn't contain all
of them.
If you want to reference another
resources from another module,
use the R
class from that module instead
of the R class from your app.
You are likely to impart more
than one R class.
We are looking at ways to make
that work.  It is not reason for
the R class to be R, it could be
whatever else.
Each library could define its
own name to reduce the amount of
conflicts.
The R class are not final, even
in the app, which means you
can't use Java switch cases any
more.
I mentioned we're not doing
resource merger any more.
If you have a module that
redefined a resource presented
in the library, that won't work
any more.  There is good reason
for that.  We definitely want to
hear from you if you are using
that in a strange way.
If what you are doing is well in
debug in the app I want to
everride an icon
coming from my library, you can
use that (?) In my library, have
a version of the debug in the
icon.  The app will contain the
debug, which was not the case
before 3.0.
That solves that problem.
If you have another use case,
talk to us, we definitely want
to hear about it.
So I mention name space and I
talked about the name space.
I said we don't have a resource
merger or resource available.
The application depend on a
third party here and here.
And both have the same resource,
same name with a different
value.
A string may be a layout or
night or something like that.
In the past the resource merger
takes one physically.  The first
one defined has a higher
priority and merge on top of the
other one and replace another
one, which is probably not what
you want.
So here what's happening if you
want to package both.
Both are going to be compiled in
their own name space.
We will package that internally,
the R class from those libraries
will have
different -- would have the same
string, with the different
values but interestingly they
will point to two
different resources, which is
much better.  When you reference
to a resource from the library,
you have to use the name space
of the library.
Using the R class of that is to
classify it.
You don't have a single R class
with all the I.D.
When you do that, it is
different.
You have to use the manifest --
the XML, you have to use the
name space directly in the
resources.
So at dot comlibrary one/X,
which is
very similar when you name an
Android.  Android column
something.
You have
atribattributes you probably do
the same thing.  Now you have to
case what the name space is.
This is out.
This is -- you know, this SML
constraint is that name space of
the library.  And I can use the
attributes.
So we are hoping to bring this
-- that in 3.3 Canary.
We will enable that with a flag.
We will include refractoring in
the studio, so all of those will
be changed for you.  We will
want a lot of feedback, it
will not be turned on in 3.3 or
redot.
There is a revision where there
is
changes, but we want a lot of
feedback.
>> JEROME DOCHEZ: Thank you.
Last thing we want to talk about
is the public API.
We are painfully aware that the
public API we provide is not
very good.
The plug in is bad not specific
to the module type.
It is not set in different
modules, but it is still there.
There is no access to the merge
man vest, class files, dex files
you name it, you can't do it in
a nice way.
The varying modal doesn't give
information coming from the
properties.
You only have access to part of
the truth.  This is too many
things that require internal PI,
hacking tasks, the separation
between public and internal API
is not well defined.  You don't
know when you switch from one to
the other.  It is a mess.  And
to give you an example, this is
how the configuration works
today.
So we have the DSL passing first
and create the variant, right.
That variant is created, then we
create all the tasks for the
variants
and eventually we have the RTPI.
This is where the scripts are
running.  The problem is there
in front of you, it is happening
after the tasks have been
created.
So there is no way to change
anything that will influence
tasks creation.
Say you want to switch from
legacy
multidex to regular multidesk,
you can't do that because we
have changed to legacy multidex.
You want DSL, you can't do that
either because we created the
task and chances
are that the input have already
been finalized.
So it is happening too late and
eventually, it creeps into the
system running later.
There is no way to do a lot of
things here.
So people do is excise the task,
try to find out the generator.
It is a mess.
What we would like to do is have
a
simple Gradle API interface that
is the one to depend on.  If you
depend on older ones, you should
talk to us, tell us what are
your needs, why are you doing
this?
Don't think that we're not
listening.  We are interested in
it figuring out why you need to
customize things and interested
in providing you a good
solution.  So one of the things
we're looking for, for instance,
is to give you access
to all of the intermediate
files.  All of the intermediate
files are really a type.
Classes, merge manifest, text
files, resources.
All of those should be accessed
and capable of being replaced.
You should be able to say give
me the merge manifest, change it
a little bit and I give you back
the new version.  That is the
one you should use to continue
the build process.  It should be
replaceable.  Dependable.
Maybe you want to add class
files directly.
Eventually, all of this should
be done through well defined
extension points.  We started
working on it.  We would like to
have feedback on this.
Proposed phases would be
different.
DSL parsing, invoke the custom
code there.
You have the ability to stop
changing
the DSL program atatally before
we create variants.  Then we
lock them up.  You can't change
any more.  Once it runs, it is
locked up.  We create a variance
from the information.
From the variant we can code
from variant to API.  That is
the ability for you to change
variant related information.
Now, be aware that this is
happening now before the task
creation.  There is no task
created yet.  This is really the
ability to say it
was using multidex, now I want
it to use
legacy multidex one these have
run, we will lockup the variant
object.
So again, if you use this later
on,
after
evaluate, it is too on late.  It
will throw an exception.
Then we create a task, we will
lock them up immediately.  We
will not allow you to modify the
task any more.
You have to go through the
buildable artifact, to inject,
replace, append, not with the
task, because we replace
them, we merge them, we delete
them, we split them to make
features or make things more
efficient.
Eventually, it will run.
The compatibility will be a
painful subject.
We will try to make use of the
DSL mostly unchanged.  We will
make an effort to be more
content friendly, and
unfortunately, we think the
variant API will change heavily,
since we realize it was not so
great, hopefully you will be
sympathetic to the idea that you
will have to change the script
using the variant API.
So we want to hear from you it
is important that we get
feedback from the community for
us.  I want to thank you for
coming tonight.  I know it is a
late session.
It was very nice to see so many
people here tonight.  Thank
youyou.
>> XAVIER DUCROHET: Thank you.
(Applause)
>> Thank you there joining this
session.
Brand ambassadors will assist
you with --
(Session concluded)